THE HEARING ON THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
COVERING PROPOSALS ON ISSUES
RELATED TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES. FOUR
WE BEGAN I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
READ SOME DIRECTIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE WHO IS HERE
TODAY WHILE ALSO ALLOWING FOR
FULL PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. TODAY'S HEARING WILL
BE AT THE STATE CAPITOL IN
HEARING ROOM FOR. MANY OF THE
PANELISTS WILL BE TESTIFYING
REMOTELY WHILE OTHERS WILL BE
HERE IN PERSON AT THE CAPITOL.
WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE END OF THE HEARING BOTH
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING OVER
THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER IS TOLL
FREE. 1-877-692-8957 THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. WE WILL BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER ALL MEMBERS HAVE
CONCLUDED THEIR QUESTIONS FOR
ALL OF THE PANELS. THERE WILL BE
NO VOTE IN TODAY'S HEARING.
FINALLY WE WILL ACCEPT PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND FEEDBACK. THAT ARE
WRITTEN THROUGH THE SUB ONE
EMAIL ACCOUNT AND THE ADDRESS IS
BUDGET SUB ONE ACT ASM DOT CA
DOT GOV. BEFORE WE BEGIN I CAN'T
HELP BUT ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
LENGTH OF THE AGENDA. WHAT'S
IMPORTANT ABOUT IT IT'S
MAGNITUDE OTHER THAN THAT MAYBE
WE WILL ALL BE HERE TILL QUITE
LATE INTO THE EVENING. IS THAT
IT REFLECTS TWO VERY IMPORTANT
TRUTHS. FIRST THE BREATH A
PUBLIC HEALTH IS EXTENSIVE AND
TOUCHES ON EVERY ASPECT OF OUR
LIVES AND IT IS DOWNRIGHT MIND
BOGGLING. FROM INFECTIOUS
DISEASE CONTROL TO DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE IT SYSTEMS TO
HOMELESSNESS AND CLIMATE CHANGE
TO THE IMPACT OF SEXUAL
ORIENTATION ON MENTAL WELL
BEING. TO PHYSICAL FITNESS FROM
EARLY CHILDHOOD LITERACY TO THE
END OF LIFE AND FROM THE BLACK
INFANT HEALTH TO THE HEALTH OF
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS. AND NO
DOUBT THERE ARE MANY MORE.
SECOND IT APPEARS THAT THE
PANDEMIC'S SILVER LINING HAS
BEEN TO CREATE AWARENESS OF AND
APPRECIATION FOR THE CRITICAL
VALUE OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AS IT
STATES IN THE AGENDA PUBLIC
HEALTHIS INVISIBLE AT LEAST
WHEN IT'S SUCCESSFUL. AND FOR
THIS REASON BOTH OF THE
DEPARTMENT CD P. H. AND M. SAW
HAVE BEEN IGNORED AND
UNDERFUNDED FOR TOO MANY DECADES
. WHILE THE LEGISLATURE MAY NOT
AGREE WITH EVERY DETAIL. WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THESE
DEPARTMENTS OVERALL IT IS
UNDOUBTABLY A LONG OVERDUE RIGHT
SIZING OF THE STATE'S INVESTMENT%
INTO THE FUTURE OF THE STATE'S
PUBLIC HEALTH. FINALLY AS WE ARE
MERGED FROM THE PANDEMIC I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT YOU ALL HAVE
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES OF
DEFENSE. WE OFTEN REFLECT ON THE
THOUSANDS OF LIVES THAT WE HAVE
LOST TO COVERT. YET WE ALSO NEED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE MILLIONS OF
LIVES THAT WERE NOT LOST TO COPE
ED AS A RESULT OF YOUR HER ROLE
WAKE AND TIRELESS EFFORTS. SO ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF US WHO ARE
STILL HERE THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR INVALUABLE SERVICE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WITH THAT
WE WILL BEGIN OUR FIRST PANEL.
WHICH WILL COVER BOTH ISSUES ONE
AND TWO BOTH OUR EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY
PROPOSALS WE WILL HAVE JUST 1%
ARE ON THIS PANEL RICK TRUSSELL
WHO IS THE CHIEF OF
ADMINISTRATION FOR EMSA. AFTER
YOU PRESENT YOUR FIRST PROPOSAL
WE WILL PAUSE FOR QUESTIONS
BEFORE GOING ON TO THE SECOND
CAN YOU PLEASE BEGIN. SURE GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN- MY NAME'S
RICHARD TRUSSELL AND THE CHIEF
OF ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY WHICH I REFER TO AS
EMSA. HAS REQUESTED I WILL
PROVIDE A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
TWO OF OUR THREE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS CURRENTLY UNDER
CONSIDERATION. ISSUE NUMBER ONE
IS THE CALIFORNIA POISON CONTROL
SYSTEM FUNDING AUGMENTATION. MS
IS REQUESTING A LOCAL ASSISTANCE
AUGMENTATION OF ONE MILLION
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. ONE
MILLION FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. AN ONGOING
FUNDING OF ONE MILLION SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND AND THREE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE THOUSAND REIMBURSEMENTS TO
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA POISON
CONTROL SYSTEM. THIS
AUGMENTATION IS BEING REQUESTED
DUE TO INCREASED SALARIES AND
BENEFIT EXPENSES RESULTING FROM
NEGOTIATED UNION BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS AND WILL CONTINUE
STABLE FUNDING FOR DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS. THE CALIFORNIA
POISON CONTROL SYSTEM AND
CONTINUED STATEWIDE ACCESS TO
POISON CENTER SERVICES IN THE
EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY. THANK YOU
I WILL BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS I WILL JUST-
SPEAK TO THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
POISON CENTER AND WANTS TO
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU WHO HAVE
WORKED HARD TO MAKE SURE IT
CONTINUES TO BE- A TOOL THAT
THOSE ON THE FRONT LINES CAN
USE. WITH THAT WE WILL NOW ASK
YOU TO PRESENT ON ISSUE TO
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR KIND
WORDS AND SUPPORT SIR- THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY- US TO BE ISSUE NUMBER
TWO IS THE PERMANENT
DISCIPLINARY REVIEW BOARD. MS IS
REQUESTING THREE POSITIONS AND
SEVEN HUNDRED THREE THOUSAND-
DOLLARS EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES PERSONNEL FUND IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND MSP
FUND IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AN ONGOING TO IMPLEMENT CHAPTER
FOUR SIX THREE STATUTES OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE OR EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY. WHICH ESTABLISHES
THE PARAMEDIC DISCIPLINARY
REVIEW BOARD TO TAKE
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS GETS A
PARAMEDIC. EMT P. LICENSE HOLDER
REVIEW AND REVISE THE CRITERIA
FOR THE REVOCATION OR SUSPENSION
OF INDIAN T. P. LICENSE THE
PROBATION OF EMT P. PERSONNEL IN
THE APPEAL OF A LICENSURE
DECISION BY MS- INTO HERE
KIEHL'S REGARDING THE DENIAL OF
LICENSURE BY MS- AB FOUR FIFTY
IS CREATING A SEVEN MEMBER
APPOINTED INDEPENDENT BOARD.
WITHIN MS UP WHICH IS
STATUTORILY AUTHORIZED TO DO THE
FOLLOWING. REVIEW AND DETERMINE
WHETHER TO ADOPT MODIFY TO
REJECT IN RETURN FOR FURTHER
HEARING PROPOSED DECISIONS FROM
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES. TAKE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION AGAINST A
CALIFORNIA PERMIC LIGHT HOLDER
HERE ACT ON APPLICANTS APPEALS
FOLLOWING MS IS DENIAL OF THE
LICENSURE OF LICENSURE
APPLICATION. DEVELOPED CRITERIA
FOR THE BOARD TO SUSPEND PLACED
ON PROBATION OR REVOKE A
PARAMEDIC LICENSE. DEVELOP
CRITERIA TO AID IN MAKING FINAL
DETERMINATIONS REGARDING APPEALS
LICENSURE ACTIONS IN TO REVIEW
AND REVISE EXISTING CRITERIA.
FOR THE SUSPENSION OF PERMANENT
LICENCES. ACTIVE JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TH THE BOARD OPERATE
UNDER MS IS OVERSIGHT THE BOARD
SHALL PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND DUE
PROCESS FOR PARAMEDIC LICENSES.
THROUGH ITS RESPONSIBILITY TO
DEVELOP THIS CRITERIA AND
MILLION MAKING FINAL
DETERMINATIONS REGARDING APPEALS
OF LICENSURE ACTIONS. THE BOARD
WILL REVIEW AND REVISE THE
REVOCATION AND SUSPENSION
CRITERION OF INDIAN CHIEF YOU
LICENSE THE PROBATION OF AN EMT
P. PERSONNEL. BOB AND THAT'S THE
END OF THE PREFOLD YOU SIR.
THANK YOU BRING IT UP TO THE
DÍAS- I'M AYE WE NOTICED THAT
YOU'RE PROPOSING A SECOND
LICENSING FEE INCREASE VERY SOON
AFTER THE LAST INCREASE. AND I'M
WONDERING WHETHER OR NT WE
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LICENSING FEE AND IF IT HAS NOW
BECOME. BURDENSOME ON
INDIVIDUALS THAT IT'S NOW A
BARRIER FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
ENTER THE FIELD. IF SO COULD YOU
PLEASE GIVE US A COST ESTIMATE
FOR THE STATE TO SUBSIDIZE THE
PROGRAM BE A GENERAL FUND.
RATHER THAN SUPPORTING A FEE
INCREASE. WELL TO ADDRESS YOUR
FIRST CONCERN IS THAT WE DID DO
A PHASED IN APPROACH OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS TO RAISE THE FEES
TO MEET OUR INCREASED OPERATING
COSTS FOR THE PARAMEDIC
LICENSURE ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM.
AB FOUR FIFTY WAS AN UNEXPECTED
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WHICH WAS
PASSED AND THE FUNDS COULD NOT
ABSORB THE ADDITIONAL EXPENSES
ASSOCIATED WITH A PERMANENT
BOARD SO. THAT THAT IS THE
PURPOSE OF THIS PROPOSAL AND THE
FEE INCREASE AT THIS TIME- DO
YOU FEEL THAT THE FEES ARE
BECOMING BURDENSOME AND BECOMING
A HINDRANCE FOR PEOPLE TO ENTER
INTO THE FIELD. I'M I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT IT'S A HINDRANCE AT
THIS TIME I MEAN A LOT OF THE
PARAMEDIC LICENSING FEES ARE
PAID BY THE EMPLOYERS. I'M SO
THAT OFFSETS THE COST- WE ARE
INCREASING IT BY SIXTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER LICENSE- AGAIN THAT
IS JUST THE COST OF ABSORBING
THE HERMETIC DISCIPLINARY BOARD
EXPENSES. I'M I CAN PROVIDE THAT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO YOU AS
A FOLLOW UP BECAUSE I JUST DON'T
HAVE A RIGHT HERE IN FRONT OF ME
ABOUT WHAT IT WOULD TAKE FOR THE
GENERAL FUND TO FILL THAT GAP.
PERFECT AND WITH THAT WE WILL
THANK VERY MUCH MISTER TRUSSELL
WE WILL MOVE ON THE PANEL TO
WHICH IS ON THE COMMUNITY
BENEFITS PROPOSAL WE WILL HAVE
SEVEN PRESENTERS WHO ARE ON THIS
PANEL INCLUDING. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND INFORMATION THE L. A. O. AND
SEVERAL STAKEHOLDERS. LET US
BEGIN WITH SUSAN FANELLI WHO IS
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND PROGRAMS AT CDPH.
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS I'M GONNA
FIRST TURN IT OVER TO SCOTT
CRESSMAN BECAUSE THEY RUN THE
COMMUTER BENEFIT PROGRAM HE'S
GOING TO GIVE YOU SOME OVERVIEW
AND THEN I'LL PROVIDE. ANSWERS
TO THE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
STUDENT THANK YOU TRUCKERS
ARAMBULA THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THE CHANCE TO SPEAK TODAY SCOTT
CHRISTMANN CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
INFORMATION. FOR EACH CAR. OF
THE STATE AND FEDERAL COMMITTEE
BENEFIT LAWS REQUIRE NONPROFIT
HOSPITALS PROVIDE COMMUNITY
BENEFITS AS A CONDITION OF THEIR
TAX EXEMPT STATUS. NONPROFIT
HOSPITALS CREATE COMMUNITY
BENEFIT PLANS WHICH PROVIDE A
DESCRIPTION OF THE ACTIVITIES
THAT THE HOSPITAL CONTRIBUTE.
WITHIN ITS MISSION AND FINANCIAL
CAPACITY TO ADDRESS IDENTIFIED
COMMUNITY NEEDS. CURRENT LAW
DOES NOT PRESCRIBE A REQUIRED
LEVEL OF COMMUNITY BENEFITS
PROVIDED BY NONPROFIT HOSPITALS
OR HOW COMMUNITY BENEFITS SHOULD
BE ALLOCATED. ADDITIONALLY
COMMITTEE BUT ORGANIZATION CBO'S
PLAY A KEY ROLE IN ADDRESSING
THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH AND MAY BE BASED IN THE
SECTOR OTHER THAN HEALTH WHICH
BRING ADDITIONAL SKILLED
PERSPECTIVES AND COMMUNITY
CONNECTIONS TO PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS. THIS COULD
INCLUDE HOUSING SECURITY FOOD
SECURITY ECONOMIC STABILITY
SCHOOLS AND CHILDCARE COMMITTEE
PILOTS AND HATE CRIMES YOU
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ENVIRONMENT AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
TRANSPORTATION. COMMITTEE
CASSIDY BUILDING. THE STATE
INTENDS TO LEVERAGE THIS
EXPERTISE TO ADVANCE EQUITY AND
REDUCE DISPARITIES IN HEALTH
OUTCOMES WITHIN COMMUTER. TO
PROMOTE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE FOCUSED ON PUBLIC
HEALTH EFFORTS THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
REQUIRE THAT NONPROFIT HOSPITALS
DEMONSTRATE HOW THEY'RE MAKING
INVESTMENTS IN LOCAL HEALTH
EFFORTS SPECIFICALLY COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT ADDRESS
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO PROPOSES
STATUTORY CHANGES THAT WOULD
DIRECT 25% OF THE NONPROFIT
HOSPITAL COMMUNITY BENEFIT
DOLLARS GO TO THESE LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH EFFORTS. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
EXCLUDES UNCOMPENSATED CARE
WHICH IS OFTEN REPORTED BY
HOSPITALS IN THEIR COMMITTEE
BENEFIT PLANS. H. CAR CURRENTLY
COLLECTS COMMUTER BENEFIT PLANS
FOR NONPROFIT HOSPITALS AND
POSTED TO OUR WEBSITE FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE BEEN COLLECTING
THESE PLANTS SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY SIX WHICH PREDATES THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
HOSPITAL COMMUNITY BENEFITS
ENACTED THROUGH THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT. AFFECTED SINCE TWENTY
TWELVE THE ACA AT THE NATIONAL
REQUIREMENT IN FEDERAL TAX LAW
FOR NONPROFIT HOSPITAL ENTITIES
TO REPORT COMMUNITY BENEFIT
SPENDING AS PART OF THEIR
NONPROFIT TAX STATUS
REQUIREMENTS. THE FEDERAL
REPORTING CAN BE DONE AT THE
HEALTH SYSTEM LEVEL CALIFORNIA
LAW REQUIRES REPORTING AT THE
HOSPITAL LEVEL. AND FOR
REFERENCE H. CAR COLLECTED ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT SUCH
REPORTS IN TWENTY TWENTY THIS
INCLUDES ALL NONPROFIT HOSPITALS
IN THE STATE EXCEPT A SMALL
NUMBER OF RURAL HOSPITALS. BUT
ARE NOT PART OF THE WHOLE
SYSTEM. AB TWO OH ALL BY. WOOD
SIGNED INTO LAW IN TWENTY
NINETEEN NOW REQUIRES HOSPITALS
TO DESCRIBE HOW NEEDS IDENTIFIED
IN THE COMMUNITY ARE BEING
ADDRESSED TO DESCRIBE THE
METHODOLOGY USED IN VALUING
BENEFITS THEY PROVIDE TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND FOR THE CHARITY
CARE AMOUNTS TO BE CONSISTENT
WITH THE CHARITY CARE COST IS
REPORTED TO EACH GUY IN THEIR
FINANCIAL DISCLOSURE REPORTS.
EIGHTY TWO OH FOUR ALSO REMOVED
A RESTRICTION FROM STANDARDIZING
COMMUNITY BENEFIT PLAN RECORDED.
THESE READING FULLER PREVENTS
THAT HELP MOVE TO A MORE
STANDARDIZED REPORTING THE
BENEFIT INFORMATION AND BETTER
TRANSPARENCY AROUND MANY BEEN A
BENEFITS BROADLY. THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL WOULD
FURTHER ADVANCE HOSPITAL
TRANSPARENCY REQUIRING EACH
PRODUCT REVISED REPORTING
SPECIFICATIONS AND REQUIREMENTS
THAT HOSPITALS MUST FOLLOW IN
THE REPORTS. THE PROPERLY
CATEGORIZED UNSPECIFIED
COMMUNITY BENEFIT SPENDING. TO
OTHERWISE DEMONSTRATE HOSPITAL
COMMUNITY BENEFIT TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON PUBLIC HEALTH
EFFORTS. AND TO BETTER ALIGN
CALIFORNIA'S REQUIREMENTS WITH
THE FEDERAL TAX REQUIREMENTS AND
SPENDING CATEGORIES. H. CHI
WOULD CONTINUE TO POST THE
COMMUNITY BENEFIT PLANS ON ITS
WEBSITE EXPANDING THE
TRANSPARENCY GOALS ABOUT IN THE
ORIGINAL AUTHORIZING STATUTE AND
FURTHER BY AB TOOL FOR TO BETTER
INFORM LOCAL COMMUNITY INTERESTS
AND NEED FOR THESE INVESTMENTS.
REGARDING OUR ROLE IN HR IN
MONITORING AND ENFORCEMENT OF
THE NEW POLICY WHICH WAS NOTED
IN YOUR AGENDA. EMPHASIS IS
PERFECT PLACE ON GREATER
TRANSPARENCY FOR HOSPITAL
COMMUNITY BENEFITS RECOGNIZING
THESE BENEFITS TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IMPORTANT AND SERVES
TO INFLUENCE COMMUNITY PARTNERS
AND STAKEHOLDERS. LIKEWISE
GREATER TRANSPARENCY GIVES
OPPORTUNITY FOR SHARING BEST
PRACTICES AND INNOVATIVE PUBLIC
HEALTH INTERVENTIONS AND CREDITS
NONPROFIT HOSPITALS REDUCE
IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTIONS AFFINITY
BENEFITS. AB TWO OH FOUR ALSO
CREATED A FINE OF UP TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A HOSPITAL
FAILURE TO COMPLETE A COMMUNITY
NEEDS ASSESSMENT WHAT WHAT
DOCTOR COMMITMENT OF A PLANT. OR
TO SUBMIT A COMMUNITY BENEFIT
PLAN TO H. CAUGHT. THIS PROPOSAL
WILL IN THAT AMOUNT OF THE UP
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND AND
EXPEDIENT. THE FINE TO ALSO
APPLY AT THE HOSPITAL BILLS TO
IDENTIFY THE PRIORITY COMMUNITY
NEEDS A BLUEGRASS OR FAILED TO
SPECIFY HOW THE SPENDING
THRESHOLD. WILL BE ALLOCATED TO
PRIORITY COMMUNITY NEEDS. H. GUY
WILL ENGAGE IN A PUBLIC RULE
MAKING PROCESS TO SPECIFY THESE
NEW REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
PROGRAM. THROUGH REGULATION HR
WILL DEVELOP STANDARDIZED
DEFINITIONS METHODOLOGY CAN
REPORTING WHICH WILL ALLOW
COMMUNITY BENEFIT AMOUNTS TO BE
QUANTIFIED AND ANALYZED. BUT WE
ALSO WORK WITH CDPH ON ANY
APPROPRIATE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO MEET THE GOALS
OF DEMONSTRATING INVESTMENTS IN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH INVESTMENT
AND SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS AND
CDPH AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
PROPOSAL GOING FORWARD. AND NOW
WILL LOOK BACK TO TWO SUSAN
CANNELLA TO SPEAK TO THE
QUESTION BECAUSE OF YOUR GENDER.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. GOOD
CARE MEMBERS I'M THIS PROPOSAL
REALLY IS ABOUT BETTER
CONNECTING THE INVESTMENTS OF
THESE HOSPITALS TO THE COMMUNITY
NEEDS AND TO THE- COMMUNITIES
AND WITH THE GREATEST NEEDS.
ANSWER THE FIRST QUESTION IS
WHAT TO THE HOSPITAL'S NOW SPEND
THESE FUNDS ON NOW. THE TRUTH IS
THEY SPEND ABOUT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND I'M- ON. THE
BENEFITS AND THAT INCLUDES ABOUT
FOUR BILLION WHICH IS REALLY-
UNCOMPENSATED CARE INCLUDING
CHARITY CARE AND THAT IS THINGS
LIKE MEDICARE. MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID ALL SHORTFALLS AS WELL
AS- INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT
INSURANCE. I AM RIGHT NOW THEY
SEND THEY SUBMIT QUALITATIVE
REPORTS NOT NECESSARILY
QUANTITATIVE THAT GO INTO THE
DETAIL OF EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
SPENDING ON WHICH INVESTMENTS
AND SO WHAT WE- BELIEVE IS THAT
MANY OF THEM ARE ALREADY
SPENDING SOME OF THESE BONDS IN
THE AREAS THAT WE MOST WOULD
WANT TO SEE THEM SPEND MY MEN.
AND ADDRESSING SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH BUT WE
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW MUCH OF
THAT TWO BILLION THAT IS NOT THE
UNCOMPENSATED CARE REALLY IS
GOING TO THIS EFFORT. AND SO
REALLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS TO GET MORE TRANSPARENCY AND
WITH THIS LIMITED INFORMATION. I
CAN'T REALLY TELL WHAT AREAS ARE
GETTING THE MOST INVESTMENTS
WHAT THEY'RE INVESTING IN AND SO
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FIRST STEP IS COLLECTING THAT
INFORMATION AND THEN THE SECOND
STEP IS SORT OF MAKING SURE THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO THE CBO
BECAUSE- I'M- AN TO UPPER
INVESTORS THAT WILL MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE. ALIGNING THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS- WITH THE
INVESTMENTS. I'M SO TO A-
REPRESENTATIVES OF HAAS HAVE
THAT THEY ALREADY CLOSELY WITH
COMMUNITIES. AND SO WE THINK
THAT THAT VARIES ACROSS THE
STATE AND THAT THERE ARE INDEED
SOME HOSPITALS THAT WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH. THE LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS COMMUNITY
ASSESSMENTS WORK WITH C. B. I
WAS ON THE GROUND I BET IT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS REALLY TO. LEVERAGE
THESE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING THOSE COMMUNITIES
MOST IN NEED BUT THEN THE
HOSPITAL SERVICE AREA AND
HOSPITALS DUE TO FIND THEIR
SERVICE AREA DIFFERENTLY AND SO
WE WANT TO MAYBE EXPAND ON THAT
SERVICE ORDERED. A SERVICE AREA
DEFINITION SO THAT WE REALLY CAN
REACH THOSE AREAS OF THE
COMMUNITY MOST IN NEED.
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN IMPROVE
THE COMMUNITY BENEFIT PROGRAM
BY. ADDING A LEVEL OF EVALUATION
AND IMPACT OF THESE INVESTMENTS
SO THAT WE CAN SEE WHAT'S
WORKING ON SOME OF THESE
COMMUNITIES AND BE ABLE TO SCALE
THAT UP WE CAN USE COLLECTIVE
IMPACT MODEL TO MAYBE- DEROZAN.
AREAS OF INVESTMENTS OF THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY SEE IMPACT ON THE
GROUND. WE REALLY NEED THAT
BASELINE INFORMATION WHICH IS
WHAT- AGE KIND WILL BE WORKING
ON AND STANDARDIZING SOME OF
THAT REPORTING. I'M AND WE WANT
TO REALLY ENCOURAGE. COLLECTIVE
IMPACT RATHER THAN SMALL
ISOLATED INVESTMENTS WHICH. MAY
NOT HAVE SUSTAINABLE IMPACT.
HELLO THIS AND SHE THESE BANNER
FUND ARE REACHING A- HIGH AREA
COMMUNE CALL HI NEED COMMUNITIES
AND STATE. I WE CAN'T ASSURE.
AND THIS IS NOT THE HOLES. TO
COMMUNITY BENEFITS. TO THE
COMMUNITY BASED. VAST AMOUNTS
THE GOAL OF THIS IS TO IMPROVE
THE COMMUTER BENEFIT PROGRAM
EVALUATE AND IMPROVE THE IMPACT
OF THESE INVESTMENTS. I'M AND
AGAIN. THERE'S A LOT OF
pAMBIGUITY IN THE DEFINITION OF
HOSPITAL SERVICE AREA I'M AND
CAN BE DEFINED BY. THEIR PATIENT
POPULATION AREA WHICH MAY OR MAY
NOT BE THE MOST NEEDY AREAS OF
THE COMMUNITIES. AND IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COLLABORATE WITH
HOSPITALS THIS IS REALLY THE
FIRST STEP IN HAVING BETTER
TRANSPARENCY ENGAGING OUR
HOSPITAL CBO'S AND LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS. TO ENSURE THAT
THESE INVESTMENTS HAVE THE
IMPACT IMPACT WE ALL WANT IN THE
COMMUNITIES WITH THE GREATEST
ME. WITHOUT ALL I'LL STOP THERE
AND CERTAINLY HAPPY ANSWER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS WE ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON ST
LANGUAGE THAT WE WILL BE SHARING
SHORTLY AND THAT WILL LAY THIS
OUT A LITTLE MORE DETAIL FOR
EVERYONE TO SEE AND THEN. WE'LL
BE WORKING WITH THE HOSPITALS
MOVING FORWARD WE HAVE. MET WITH
PH I KNOW THEY'VE DONE I HAVE A
REPORT THAT WE'VE MET WITH BEEN
GONE OVER AND WITH HEALTH
BACKSTOPS THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS. TO MAKE
THIS AS- STRONG AS WE CAN. THANK
NEXT WILL FROM SOME PET WITH THE
ANALYST'S. THANK YOU DR ANGELA
ON YOU PICK FROM THE L. A. O- AS
MS FINELLI JUST NOTED THAT THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS PROPOSAL IS NOT
PROVIDED YET THEN WILL OBVIOUSLY
REVIEW THAT WHEN IT COMES OUT-
AS YOU KNOW OUR OF OUR OFFICE IS
ALWAYS A FAN OF GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND MORE
INFORMATION- BUT IN THE MEANTIME
WE DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE PROPOSAL THAT WE AGREES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION. SO
FIRST- WHY IS THIS FUNDING BEING
DIRECTED TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS RATHER THAN
ALLOWING HOSPITALS TO FUND OTHER
PROJECTS THAT ALSO FOCUS ON
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH-
SECOND HOW WILL IT BE TO BE
DETERMINED WHETHER A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION PROJECT IS
RELATED TO SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH- THE THIRD HOW MUCH
FUNDING DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
EXPECT WILL BE DIRECTED TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
IF THIS PROPOSAL IS APPROVED.
AND FINALLY WHAT SPECIFIC
CONDITIONS WOULD TRIGGER A
PENALTY A FINANCIAL PENALTY
AGAINST THE HOSPITAL- IF THEY
DON'T ADHERE TO THE PROPOSED
REQUIREMENTS- THESE ARE JUST
SOME OF THE TYPES OF DETAILS
THAT WE WILL WE ARE HOPING WILL.
BE ADDRESSED BY THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WE HAVE DOCTOR KEVIN
BARNETT PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE
CENTER TO ADVANCE COMMUNITY
HEALTH AND EQUITY WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE. THANK
YOU. I'D LIKE TO SHARE A FEW
SLIDES WITH YOU IF ONLINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE A BIT OF THE OF THE
MATERIAL THAT WE COVERED IN THE
BRIEF- THAT WAS JUST REFERENCE
THAT WAS PUBLISHED- A
SIGNIFICANT DEGREE FOCUSING ON
BOTH SOME OF THE CHALLENGES AND
THE OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. FIRST AND
FOREMOST- IT'S IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND THEM AS WAS TOUCHED
ON IN THE OPENING PRESENTATION-
THIS IS FOLLOWING A LONG STRING
OF EFFORTS BOTH AT THIS AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL TO LEGISLATE. HOW
NONPROFIT HOSPITALS MEET THEIR
TRIP WHAT LOCATIONS- IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE REAL
STARTING POINT FOR THE SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE. THE IRISH
RULING THAT. BUT THAT BASICALLY
OUTLINED THE CONCEPT OF THE
PROMOTION OF HEALTH EXPANDING
BEYOND THE PROVISION OF CHARITY
CARE FOR NONPROFIT HOSPITALS. TO
THE BROADER PUBLIC HEALTH-
PURPOSE THAT WE ARE DISCUSSING
TODAY- A LOT OF STATUTES IN
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA'S THAT THE
SIX NINETY SEVEN AND NINETY
FOUR- AS REFERENCED EARLIER TO
OUR BOTH THE IRS REVISED
GUIDELINES IN THE PORTABLE CARE
ACT. FIVE A ONE ARE PROVIDING OF
A VARIETY OF MORE DETAILED
REQUIREMENTS HOWEVER I WOULD
NOTE THAT MANY OF THOSE
REQUIREMENTS IF ANYTHING HAVE
ADDED CONFUSION RATHER THAN
CLARITY TO HELP NONPROFIT
HOSPITALS. MEET THESE
OBLIGATIONS AND THEN A NUMBER OF
EFFORTS AND ENDS IN OTHER STATES
AS WELL AS IN OUR OWN STATE BOTH
CURRENT CREATES A FOCUS ON
EQUITY AND TO PROVIDE MORE
DETAIL. EXPECTATIONS WITH
OBSTACLES- MUCH OF THIS- WORK AS
REALLY JUST FOCUSED ON HOW MUCH
HOSPITALS ARE PROVIDED RATHER
THAN REALLY DIGGING INTO THE
QUALITY OF THE INVESTMENTS AND
TO THE DEGREE TO WHICH WE REALLY
FOCUSED. ON THE PROFOUND
INEQUITIES THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
CANDIDATES- WHEN YOU LOOK AT
MOST EXPENDITURES INCLUDING.
MEDICAID SHORTFALLS IN HEALTH
PROFESSIONS EDUCATION
EXPENDITURES BY HOSPITAL'S
CURRENT SPENDING ON SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH IS QUITE
SMALL SO THE PROPOSAL ONE OF THE
FACE OF IT IS IT IS AN
IMPORTANT. MOMENT IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION PARTICULARLY GIVEN
THAT HOSPITALS ARE ASSEMBLY
INCREASING RATES FOR KEEPING.
PEOPLE HEALTHY AND OUT OF THEIR
INSTITUTIONS- IT'S OF TO.
HOWEVER THAT IF IT NUMBER OF
WHAT IS WRITTEN. FOR EXAMPLE WE
THE FORM MEDICARE OUR- SHORTFALL
. IS ACTUALLY THE EMERGENCY ROOM
AND INPATIENT TREATMENT OF
PREVENTABLE CONDITION. SO
BEGINNING TO MATURE SHIFT
INVESTMENTS UPSTREAM IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. HOWEVER
AMONG THE MANY CHALLENGES IN
IMPLEMENTING THIS KIND OF
LEGISLATION AS UNDERSTANDING THE
PROFOUND DIVERSITY OF THE
HEALTHCARE SECTOR ITSELF. SAFETY
NET HOSPITALS IN PARTICULAR IN
OUR URBAN SETTINGS HOW MUCH LESS
FAVORABLE PAYER METHODS THANK
HAD A LARGER PERCENTAGE OF
PUBLIC PAY OF PATIENTS THAT HAVE
LOWER MARGINS OF THEY HAVE A LOT
MORE LOW INCOME PEOPLE IN THEIR
EMERGENCY ROOMS. AND MAKES IT
MUCH MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM
WHILE THEY HAVE GREATER
SENSITIVITY THE MANY CHALLENGES
FACED BY THESE POPULATIONS THEY
HAVE THE LEAST DISCRETIONARY-
REVENUE TO BE ABLE TO ALLOCATE
FOR THESE PURPOSES SO WE HAVE TO
TAKE THAT INTO CONSIDERATION.
TEACHING HOSPITALS- OF SPEND A
SIGNIFICANT PROPORTION OF THEIR
COMMITTEE BENEFIT OBLIGATIONS-
IT IN QUATERNARY AND TERTIARY
CARE FOR THIS POPULATION AS WELL
AS HEALTH PROFESSIONS EDUCATION
SHORTFALLS. SEVERAL HOSPITALS
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT PROPORTION OF
THEIR VERY LIMITED MARGINS
DIRECTED TOWARDS DIRECT SERVICES
SUBSIDIZED SERVICES DENTAL
SERVICES- OF BIRD WARDS OVER AN
ARRAY OF SPECIALTY CARE IT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE UNAVAILABLE FOR
THOSE POPULATIONS. IT HAS
ALREADY BEEN REFERENCE THERE'S
IN THE METALAC OF CLARITY IN THE
CURRENT IRS REPORTING CATEGORIES
A LOT OF THINGS ARE REPORTED
THAT PROBABLY SHOULDN'T MANY
OTHERS ARE NOT REPORTED BECAUSE
THERE'S A LACK OF CLARITY ABOUT
WHERE THEY BELONG. SO TO THE
DEGREE THAT ANY PROPOSAL SUCH AS
THIS IS A PLUMMETED REQUIRES
SOME SOME RIGOROUS EFFORT TO
STRENGTHEN THE REPORTING
CATEGORIES- THEN IT'S IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT TO THE DEGREE
THAT WE REQUIRE SPENDING IN SOME
AREAS IT MAY CHALLENGE THOSE FOR
NON EMERGENT CARE. FOR
HEALTHCARE SERVICES MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN THE LIFE OF
THIS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TIME
IT PUTS AN ADDITIONAL. STRAIN ON
HOSPITALS TO PROVIDE THE AS-
THAT HAVING BEEN SAID- ALTHOUGH
OF OFFER ARE PRETTY- WHAT WE
HEARD FROM OUR CALLING NATURE L.
L. IT TRYING THE IN MOVING
TOWARD A TOP FOUR TO THIS OF THE
THAT IT WILL INCLUDE COMMITTEE
BUILDING WHICH THE IRS ALLOW
FISH AGENT OR AGENCY DECLARED
THIS IS A PRIORITY ENABLES US TO
SPEND QUITE A BIT MORE IN THAT
AREA. H. BECAUSE I HAVE A WEALTH
OF DATA- THAT WE COULD- PUT
UNDER G. I. S. ANALYSIS- AND BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY SUB GEOGRAPHIES
WHERE THERE'S A HIGH RATE OF
PREVENTABLE BDNF PATIENT
UTILIZATION WHAT WE'VE DONE IS
ANALYSES IN IN OTHER STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WE HAVE RATES
OF PREVENTABLE ET IN THE PATIENT
WAS ELECTIONS THAT ARE FREE FOUR
SOMETIMES TEN TIMES HIGHER THAN
THE COUNTY AVERAGES SO IT'S
QUITE CLEAR WHERE WE CAN DIRECT-
BECAUSE THE MASSIVE SUPPORT
THOUGHTFUL- THIS IS ABLE TO
START REALLY FUNDAMENTALLY SHIFT
OUR FOCUS ON EQUITY- CREATING-
INATTENTIVE. FOR ABOUT
COMMUNITIES TO FOCUS WHERE THEY
NEED TO- AND TO- AND IMMOBILIZER
ASSETS IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES THIS
IS- WE SEE EFFORTS FOR EXAMPLE
WERE WORKING. WITH THE L. A.
PARTNERSHIP. AND THE COMMITTEE
TO COME CENTER THE MORE INTO.
ALL THE HOSPITAL TO THE GROUP
DEFO. ON THE ISSUE OF. AND A
LOOK AT AND TO LET. THEIR RAP IN
COMBAT. THIS IS- THIS IS AN EXAM
OF A OF A THE WITH CDC. THAT
ENABLES US TO SEE WHERE
HOSPITALS ARE LOCATED. WHERE ARE
THEIR CONCENTRATIONS OF
SIGNIFICANT POVERTY AND
CHALLENGE AND THE DEGREE TO
WHICH HOSPITALS ARE CORRECTING
THEIR RESOURCES IN THOSE
SUBJECTS ARE PERFECT WE HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY NOW. IN CALIFORNIA
AND WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH EACH TRY TO GET THESE
BIG DATA AND FINDING OUT THERE
TO SUPPORT. THE KIND OF LEVERAGE
INVESTMENT THAT WE NEED. SO IF I
THE PROPOSAL FROM FROM H. TRY-
IT IS IN LINE WITH A MORE
DELIBERATE APPROACH TO THIS
PROCESS FOR THE FIRST STEP IN
THE PROCESS THE STAFF WAS COMMON
DEFINITIONS AND RULES FOR
REPORTING. CAL SHOULD STATE
DATABASE A DATABASE FOR TARGETED
REPORTING. UP TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S AN IMPLICIT ADVISORY
STRUCTURE- AND TO REALLY
ESTABLISH THE KIND OF INCENTIVES
WE NEED FOR VOLUNTEERS
LEADERSHIP- OUT OF SEPARATE
TOPIC- THIS BODY TODAY WE'LL BE
DISCUSSING. OF THE EQUITY FUND.
THE PROPOSAL TO ESTABLISH A
HUNDRED MILLION FOR AN EQUITY
FUND OF THE STATE OF THIS I
THINK CALIFORNIA'S IS. IS FAR
SMALLER THAN IS NEEDED- PUTTING
A FUNDED ET AL IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF A BILLION
DOLLARS WOULD MAKE A LOT MORE
SENSE AND COULD BE USED AS
LEVERAGE. WITH HOSPITAL MATCHES
TO THOSE FUNDS IN. THE VERY
COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. SO WHAT IT TOOK TO PUT
SOME KEEP. REPORTER BODY I COULD
. HOW THIS BILL COULD SHAPE UP
TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT IS. THE
CHALLENGES HOSPITALS BUT LOOK AT
WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN PARTNER
WITH THEM TO REALLY ADDRESS THE
FUNDAMENTAL CHALLENGES MARCH
UNITS THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WE WILL HEAR FROM KAREN SAVAGE
SANGWAN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK. GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY- I WANT
TO START OUT BY THANKING THE
DEPARTMENT THE LEGISLATURE IN
ALL OF OUR LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
LEADERS AND FRONTLINE WORKERS
FOR THEIR TREMENDOUS WORK DURING
THE PANDEMIC. WHICH IS NOT OVER
YET AND WE KNOW THAT HER OAK
WORK WILL CONTINUE- TO SPEAK TO
THE COMMUNITY BENEFITS PROPOSAL
SO CURRENTLY AS WAS MENTIONED BY
THE LA- WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
SEE TRAILER BILL AND SO THERE'S-
NOT SUFFICIENT DETAIL FOR US TO
FULLY WEIGH IN ON THAT. HOWEVER
SEE PENN DOES BELIEVE THAT THE
PROPOSAL AS PRESENTED HAS MERIT.
CURRENTLY ONLY THREE CENTS OF
EVERY DOLLAR SPENT ON HEALTHCARE
IS SPENT ON PREVENTION. WE MUST
CHANGE THIS EQUATION IN ORDER TO
ADVANCE HEALTH EQUITY AND EASE
THE BURDEN OF CHRONIC DISEASE
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. BETTER
DIRECTING THE RESOURCES OF
NONPROFIT HOSPITALS WHICH DERIVE
A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL BENEFIT
FROM THEIR TAX STATUS. TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY HEALTH AND
ADVANCE THE PRIORITIES OF THE
STATE FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. IS AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THIS PUZZLE. E DO
SUPPORT REFORMING COMMUNITY
BENEFITS STANDARDS AND ENSURING
THAT TAXPAYER DOLLARS A CHEAP
IMPACT FOR MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. THAT SAID THAT
PROPOSAL ALONE IS NOT SUFFICIENT
TO ADVANCE HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE. IT MUST BE
PAIRED WITH THE GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT IN HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE. I WAS WAS
INCLUDED IN THE LEGISLATURE'S
BUDGET LAST YEAR AT THE HEALTH
EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE FUNDS
WHICH WE APPRECIATE. PUBLIC
HEALTH DOES NOT START AND END UP
THE DOORS OF GOVERNMENT AND
NEITHER DOES RACIAL JUSTICE IN
FACT IN ORDER TO BUILD AND
SUSTAIN HEALTHY COMMUNITIES. WE
MUST HAVE SHARED OWNERSHIP
LEADERSHIP AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS OR
THOSE WHOSE MISSION IT IS TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF HISTORICALLY
EXCLUDED COMMUNITIES. MUST BE A
PART OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS PLAY THREE
CRITICAL ROLES IN ADVANCING
PUBLIC HEALTH GOALS REDUCING
DISPARITIES AND PROMOTING RACIAL
JUSTICE. THEY MAKE THE INVISIBLE
VISIBLE THEY BUILD BRIDGES AND
THE INNOVATE TO TRANSFORM
SYSTEMS TO ALIGN WITH COMMUNITY
NEEDS AND PRIORITIES. FIRST ON
MAKING THE INVISIBLE VISIBLE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE ARISEN OUT OF UNMET NEED
OFTEN IN THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE MADE INVISIBLE BY OUR
SYSTEMS AND PRACTICES DUE TO
THEIR SIZE OR LACK OF POLITICAL
POWER. FOR EXAMPLE DURING THE
PANDEMIC PACIFIC ISLANDERS
EXPERIENCED THE HIGHEST CASE AND
DEATH RATES OF ANY RACIAL GROUP.
YET DUE TO THE SMALL SIZE OF THE
POPULATION AND IT'S DISBURSING
H. R. TRAP CALIFORNIA LITTLE
WITH READY TO RESPOND TO THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY. IN
RESPONSE PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS MOBILIZED AND
BUILT A STATEWIDE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT ADVOCATED FOR THEIR NEEDS.
PARTNERED WITH STATE AND COUNTY
EFFORTS DISABILITY TO TESTING
VACCINATION AND PP DISTRIBUTION
PROVIDED CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
PUBLIC EDUCATION. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY PROVIDED HOPE DURING
A PERIOD OF ISOLATION AND FEAR.
SECOND ON BUILDING BRIDGES
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE ABLE TO HAVE A FOOT IN EACH
WORLD AND TO NAVIGATE BETWEEN
THE STRUCTURES OF GOVERNMENT AND
THE REALITIES OF COMMUNITIES.
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES WERE
PARTICULARLY DEVASTATED BY THE
PANDEMIC BUT ALSO ISOLATED FROM
THE RESOURCES OF GOVERNMENT DUE
TO FEAR OF IMMIGRATION
CONSEQUENCES. COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE STUDENTS GAP ACTING AS
TRUSTED MESSENGERS TO BRING PP
FINANCIAL RELIEF AND OTHER
RESOURCES TO UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITIES. ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTAL AND STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH EFFORTS TO REACH THOSE
WHO OTHERWISE MAY HAVE BEEN LEFT
OUT. FINALLY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY ON INNOVATING TO
TRANSFORM SYSTEMS TO ALIGN WITH
COMMUNITY PRIORITIES. AFTER THE
LAST TWO YEARS I THINK IT IS
CLEAR TO ALL OF US WHO VALUE
EQUITY. THAT WE CANNOT GO BACK
TO HER PRE PANDEMIC NORMAL.
INSTEAD WE MUST INNOVATE AND
TRANSFORM TO ELIMINATE RACIAL
AND OTHER INEQUITIES COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS HOLD SYSTEMS
ACCOUNTABLE. ENSURE
PARTICIPATION IN DEMOCRACY AND
DEVELOP NEW AND CREATIVE IDEAS
TO SOLVE SEEMINGLY INTRACTABLE
SOCIETAL PROBLEMS. IT IS THIS
ROLE THAT WE WANT TO SUPPORT
THROUGH THE RACIAL JUSTICE
INNOVATION PORTION OF THE FUND.
WE MUST BE WILLING TO INVEST IN
NEW IDEAS AND EXPERIMENTS AND
COMMUNITIES IN ORDER TO EFFECT
EFFECTIVELY TACKLED THE
GENERATIONAL IMPACT OF SYSTEMIC
RACISM. BY FILLING THESE THREE
CRITICAL ROLES COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS COMPLEMENT AND
EXTEND THE REACH OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTAL AND STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH EFFORTS. WHILE MANY LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS RECOGNIZE
THIS AND ACTIVELY PARTNER WITH
CBO'S AS YOU WILL HEAR FROM THE
NEXT SPEAKER. IT IS AN
UNFORTUNATE REALITY THAT NOT ALL
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF THEIR BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS TO DO SO. THERE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE WHERE
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS IN PROGRAMS
THAT SUPPORT UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITIES COULD NOT BE
APPROVED AND OTHERS THAT HAVE
REVOKED FUNDING FOR COPING OUT
REACH TO VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THEIR CONTRACTORS ALSO
SUPPORT THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
MOVEMENT. IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE STATE TO
FILL THESE GAPS AND ENSURE THAT
ALL COMMUNITIES HAVE ACCESS TO
RESOURCES. AND ARE ABLE TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ADVANCE HEALTH
EQUITY AND JUSTICE. THE HEALTH
EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE FUND
HAS STRONG ACCOUNTABILITY
MECHANISMS BUILT IN TO ENSURE
IMPACT. WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO ONCE AGAIN INCLUDE THIS
INVESTMENT IN THE BUDGET. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM DR MOON TO DAVIS THE HEALTH
OFFICER FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU I'M DOCTOR MORE INTO
DAVIS THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HEALTH OFFICER. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE CHAIR ARAMBULA AND
AUDIBLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF ALL SAN
ANGELES COUNTY AND IN SUPPORT OF
THE HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL
JUSTICE ON. RESHAPED
ADMINISTRATION'S ONGOING COMMIT
THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THINK THE
LEGISLATOR FOR LEGISLATURE FOR
THEIR EFFORTS. LAST YEAR TO
DIRECT A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
MILLION IN FUNDING TO SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH IS PROUD TO JOIN OVER TWO
HUNDRED ADVOCATES AND
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
CRITICAL REQUEST FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING TO ENABLE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS. CLERICS AND
TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS TO ADVANCE
INITIATIVES THAT FOCUS ON RACIAL
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE AS PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING ACROSS ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE COUNTY CENTER FOR HEALTH
EQUITY. HAVE WORKS TO AUGMENT
EXISTING AND EMERGING COMMUNITY
EFFORTS STRENGTHEN AND CREATE
NEW PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN THE
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND
COMMUNITY EFFORTS AND REALIGNED
APARTMENT RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
PARTNERSHIPS THAT ADVANCE
CONDITIONS FOR OPTIMAL HEALTH.
CRITICAL TO OUR RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC WAS CREATING VERY LOS
ANGELES OUR COMMUNITY EQUITY
FUND TO SUPPORT THIRTY ONE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS TO DO
WHAT THEY DO BEST. CONNECTING
RESIDENTS ENGAGING IN POLICY AND
PRACTICE CHANGES ENSURING VITAL
INFORMATION ON RISK AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROVED
HEALTH OUTCOMES. MORE THAN THREE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED SERVICE
LINKAGES WERE MADE TO SUPPORT
FOOD ACCESS FINANCIAL HELP AND
HEALTH CARE NEEDS AND THOUSANDS
OF ADDITIONAL OUTREACH EVENTS
OUTREACH AN ESTIMATED THREE
MILLION PEOPLE. L. A. COUNTY
ALSO INVESTED IN THE COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS OUTREACH
INITIATIVE TO SHARE ACCURATE
INFORMATION ABOUT KOBE NINETEEN
AND BACKS THE NATION'S IN A
MANNER THAT IS TAILORED TO THE
NEEDS OF THOSE MOST IMPACTED BY
THE VIRUS. THE INITIATIVE
SUPPORTED FIFTEEN ORGANIZATIONS
THAT THE POINT OVER FIVE HUNDRED
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS AND
CONDUCTED MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND OUTREACH
ACTIVITIES HELPING TO REACH AN
ESTIMATED THREE POINT TWO
MILLION PEOPLE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. WHEN THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN AS
SUCCESSFUL IN ENGAGING WITH THE
COMMUNITY IN THIS WAY GIVE AN
UNDERSTANDABLE LACK OF TRUST IN
GOVERNMENT THE RESPONSE. AND
CBO'S INTIMATE KNOWLEDGE OF
BARRIERS AND SOLUTIONS TO
PROMOTING HEALTH IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES. AS YOU KNOW BLACK
LATIN ACTS NATIVE HAWAIIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN INDIAN
AND ALASKA NATIVE POPULATIONS
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE THE
DYSPORT AN IMPACT FROM THE
PANDEMIC. DUE IN LARGE PART TO
LONGSTANDING STRUCTURAL AND
SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES INCLUDING
EMPLOYMENT. OVERCROWDED HOUSING.
IRATE SOME UNDERLYING HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND A LACK OF STRONG
WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS. FOR
HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE
FUND WOULD ALLOW COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS IN L. A. COUNTY
AND ACROSS THE STATE TO ADDRESS
HELP HELP THE SEVERITY. AND
DISEASE DISEASES IMPACTING
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. SENATE
PROTECTIONS AND WORKERS RIGHTS
WE URGE YOU TO INVEST IN THE
HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE
FINE AS WE WORK COLLECTIVELY TO
COME BACK STRONGER POST PANDEMIC
WHICH AGAIN WERE NOTAT YET WE
NEED A SUSTAINED COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORT COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS
ACROSS ALL SECTORS TO CLOSE THE
AVOIDABLE AND UNACCEPTABLE GAPS
IN HEALTH AND WELL BEING ACROSS
RACIAL ETHNIC AND SOCIOECONOMIC
GROUPS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM HEAVEN
EAST LOS WHO IS THE FOUNDER AND
CEO OF CULTIVAR LAWCENTER PLEASE
BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON BONUS THAT
THIS COMMITTEE CHAIRED UNPLANNED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SIGNED HIM
OVER BY YOU SLICE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE BALLOT THAT
LOOT I AM A PROUD NEED OF A
FRESNO WHICH IS YOUR KIDS LANDED
ALSO THE DAUGHTER AND
GRANDDAUGHTER OF FARM NEIGHBORS.
WITH EVEN LESS THAN WHAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE AS AN INITIATIVE TO ADDRESS
CHRONIC ILLNESS AMONG VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY SPECIFICALLY OUR WORK
BEGAN IN RESPONSE TO THE ONGOING
OBESITY EPIDEMIC OUR EFFORTS
HAVE FOCUSED ON IMPROVING ACCESS
TO HEALTHY FOODS AND PROMOTING
INVESTMENTS TO CREATE SAFE
PLACES FOR PHYSICAL ACTIVITY AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. MOST
RECENTLY WE HAVE BEEN VERY
INVOLVED IN RESPONDING TO
COVERED BY OFFERING FOOD AND
SUPPLIES TO POOR AND DOCUMENTED
WOMEN PROVIDING HEALTH EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH TO LATINO IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS HOSTING
TESTING AND VACCINE EVENTS IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES. ARE PROMOTED
AS HAVE CONNECTED PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HARDSHIP DUE TO
KOBE TO RESOURCES SUCH AS
EMPLOYEE RIGHTS UTILITY
ASSISTANCE ANTI DICTION SUPPORTS
AS WELL AS ISOLATION AND
QUARANTINE SUPPORTS. THEY HAVE
BEEN EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEIR
COMMUNITY THEY SPEAK THEIR
LANGUAGE THEY UNDERSTAND THEIR
CULTURE AND BECAUSE OF THESE
CHARACTERISTICS ALLOW THEM TO
ESTABLISH TRUSTING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE MOST VULNERABLE.
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS. CURRENTLY
UP ABOUT THE HEALTH INEQUITY IN
RACIAL IN. ISSUES IN THE CENTRAL
. ONE IN THIRTEEN SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY RESIDENTS AGES EIGHTEEN
AND OLDER HAS DIABETES FRESNO
COUNTY HAS THE SECOND HIGHEST
ASTHMA RATE IN THE STATE AT
SEVENTEEN PERCENT. THE BATTLE HE
HAS HIGH RATES OF HEART DISEASE%
DEATHS FROM CANCER INFANT
MORTALITY AND LATE ACCESS TO
PRENATAL CARE ONE IN SIX VALLEY
RESIDENTS IS UNINSURED THE
VALLEY HAD. 30% FEWER DOCTORS
THAN THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE WITH
FORTY SEVEN POINT NINE.
PHYSICIANS PER HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE THESE POINTS CLARIFY WHY
THE COLBERT PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
SUCH A BURDEN IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THE PREVALENCE OF PRE
EXISTING CONDITIONS COUPLED WITH
THE LIMITED ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE. IS THE PERFECT BREEDING
GROUND FOR COAL BUT- OUR
VULNERABILITY HOWEVER IS THE
STATE'S VULERABILITY THE VALLEY
REPRESENTS 1% OF THE
AGRICULTURAL FARMLAND IN THE US
BUT WE PRODUCE OVER 25% OF ALL
THE TABLE FOOD BE. CALIFORNIA'S
FOOD SUPPLY LITERALLY DEPENDS ON
THE FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. THESE
DATA POINTS HOWEVER ALSO POINT
TO THE IMPORTANCE OF INVESTING
IN PREVENTION TO BUILD HEALTHIER
AND MORE RESILIENT COMMUNITIES.
PROMOTING HEALTH IS NOT
SOMETHING YOU DO IN A CRISIS
IT'S AN INVESTMENT THAT WE NEED
TO CONTRIBUTE TO CONSISTENTLY WE
CAN CULTIVATE GOOD HEALTH BUT WE
NEED THE RESOURCES TO DO IT. AS
I MENTIONED HAS BEEN IN
EXISTENCE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIVE BUT IT'S BEEN ONLY BECAUSE
OF MONUMENTAL LINKS TO PIECE
TOGETHER FUNDING STREAMS OF THE
NONPROFIT. WE GAIN RESOURCES WE
BUILT UP STAFF AND THEN THE
GRANTS AND THEN WE HAVE TO LET
STAFF GO AND SUSPEND ACTIVITIES
UNTIL FUNDING CAN BE IDENTIFIED
AND SECURED AGAIN. HAVING AN
UNSTABLE SOURCE THE FUNDING HAS
BEEN DETRIMENTAL TO OUR SUCCESS
. ONE EXAMPLE TO SHOWCASE- THIS
CHALLENGES OUR VENDORS FOR
HEALTH PROJECT THROUGH THIS
PROJECT WE PARTNERED WITH OTHER
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS TO
ESTABLISH A COMMUNITY KITCHEN WE
TRAINED MOBILE VENDORS- WE TRAIN
THEM IN PARTICULAR TO OFFER
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES- TO HELP-
SPREAD. ACCESS TO HEALTHIER
FOODS INCLUDED SECURING
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND SO THIS MEANT
THAT WE HAD TO WORK WITH THEM SO
THAT THEY COULD BE LICENSED AND
PERMITTED SO THAT THEY COULD
PASS ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
REQUIREMENTS AND GAIN FOOD
HANDLING CERTIFICATION THE
PROJECT OPERATED AS A PILOT WITH
REALLY GOOD SUCCESS HOWEVER OUR
NONPROFIT PARTNER LOST THEIR
FUNDING AND ULTIMATELY THE LEASE
ON THE KITCHEN. THAT WE HAVE
WORK TO ESTABLISH- THE PROJECT
COULD NO LONGER OPERATE WITHOUT
ACCESS TO A CERTIFIED COMMUNITY
KITCHEN AND SO I USE THAT STORY
TO DESCRIBE- JUST HOW DIFFICULT
IT IS- IN THE NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY. TO REALLY SUSTAIN
INNOVATIVE PROJECTS THAT HAVE A
LOT OF PROMISE. IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS- WE HAVE HAD TO FIGHT FOR
FUNDING WITH KERIS ACT IN ORDER
TO RESPOND TO THE NEEDS IN
PARTICULAR IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITY MEMBER CENTER COALBED.
WE ARE HAVING ALSO TO FIGHT FOR
FUNDING FOR ARPA AT WE'VE BEEN
DENIED FUNDING MANY TIMES
BECAUSE OF LOCAL POLITICS HI
THIS IS TRUE IN MANY OF THE
COUNTIES HERE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WHERE THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS DO NOT REFLECT. THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WHICH WE ARE TRYING TO SERVE.
AND NO ONE'S HEALTH SHOULD
REALLY BE UNDERMINED BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT HOLD THIS POLITICAL
POWER- AND IN THE ABSENCE OF
EQUITABLE REPRESENTATION IN
THESE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WE NEED
TO BE MORE EQUITABLE IN THE WAY
THAT FUNDING AND RESOURCES ARE
DISTRIBUTED. SO WITH STEADY
FUNDING TO PROMOTE HEALTH EQUITY
AND RACIAL JUSTICE COULD BE BY
LESS THAN WHO COULD. ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE LONG TERM EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES WITH COMPETITIVE
WAGES AMPLE BENEFITS WE COULD
SUSTAIN INTERVENTIONS THAT
REALLY HELP TO CHANGE THE FOOD
LANDSCAPE. INCLUDED SECURE
NEIGHBORHOODS WE COULD DIVE
DEEPER IN ADVOCACY- TO BRING THE
NECESSARY AND INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT PROMOTE DALY
IN REGULAR PHYSICAL ACTIVITY WE
COULD CONTINUE IN OUR LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES THAT
ALLOW DISADVANTAGE. I RESIDENTS
TO BE AGENTS FOR CHANGE- WE
COULD HELP TO PROMOTE PREVENTION
WE COULD HELP TO ESTABLISH
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES AND WE COULD
DEFINITELY HAVE A GREATER
IMPACT. AND HEALTH EQUITY. AND
IT WOULD ENSURE THAT MY
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT COME
CHILDREN AS WELL AS YOURS HAVE
AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE THE
FULL COURSE OF THEIR LIVES AN
OPTIMAL OUT. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
WORKING FOR AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
ASKING- FOR THIS HEALTH EQUITY
IN RACIAL JUSTICE FUND TO BE
ESTABLISHED AND FOR THE DOLLARS
TO BE EQUALLY DISTRIBUTED TO
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
MINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH
THAT I WILL BRING IT UP TO THE
DÍAS TO SEE IF ANY MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS. SEEING NINE I WILL
KEEP IT WITH THE CHAIR AND I
WILL TAKE A- MOMENT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE AND REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT I EAST LOS WHO I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH DURING
THIS LAST PANDEMIC. IT WAS JUST
ABOUT A YEAR AGO THAT SHE AND I
WERE WORKING ON THE FRONT LINES
IN PLACES LIKE ORANGE COVE.
DELRAY AND BY ALL WHICH HAPPENS
TO BE THE MOST VACCINATED. SMALL
CITY UNINCORPORATED CITY WE HAD
AN FRESNO COUNTY IT COULD NOT
HAVE OCCURRED WITHOUT THE
PARTNERSHIP OF THOSE. CBO'S WHO
ARE THE TRUSTED MESSENGERS ON
THE GROUND I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE DO APPRECIATE YOU ABOUT
THE- AND ALL THE HARD WORK THE
ORGANIZATION THIS TIME. WITH
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO TURN MY
FIRST QUESTION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION. IT SEEMS THAT-
SUSAN FINALE HAD SAID THAT WE
NEED BETTER TRANSPARENCY
REGARDING THESE DOLLARS THAT WE
NEED TO SEE MORE OF A COLLECTIVE
IMPACT ON THE GROUND THAT I'D
FIRST LIKE TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION IF THEY BELIEVE
ANYTHING IS CURRENTLY MISSING.
FROM THE COMMUNITY BENEFITS
PROGRAM FUNDING. AND AND IF SO-
CAN YOU IDENTIFY WHAT THAT IS. I
THINK I'LL I'LL START AND I'LL
TURN IT BACK TO SCOTT BUT I
THINK WE DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THAT GIVEN THAT THAT THAT
DATA IS NOT GRANULAR ENOUGH FOR
US TO SEE HOW MUCH IS INVESTED
IN WHICH AREAS WE KNOW THAT WE
ARE NOT INVESTING IN SOME OF THE
HIGHEST RISK AREAS AND WE KNOW
THAT NOT ALL HOSPITALS ARE
ENGAGING COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SO SETTING UP OUR
OF 25% TO GO TO DIRECTLY TO
CEOS. TO GET THAT TRUSTED
MESSENGER TO GET TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES MOST AT RISK BUT I
THINK THAT'S PART OF THE
TRANSPARENCY ISSUE IS WE WANT TO
SEE EXACTLY HOW MUCH AS BEING
ABOUT SEVEN WHERE AND SOME OF
THE REPORTS THAT WE HAVE DON'T
GO TO THAT LEVEL OF DETAIL. NOT
SCOTT IF YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING MORE FINANCES I WANT TO
THANK YOU SUIT JUST JUST IT TOOK
TO REPORT THAT'S CORRECT IT'S
ESSENTIALLY WE DON'T KNOW WE
DON'T KNOW THE NATURE OF THE
COMMUNITY BENEFIT PLANS REPORTED
IN CALIFORNIA TODAY ARE ARE
ESSENTIALLY QUALITATIVE- THERE'S
NO STANDARDIZED REQUIRED FORMAT
SO IN SOME CASES- THERE WELL
FLESHED OUT AND WE CAN WE CAN
SEE WHERE THESE THESE- THESE
BENEFITS ARE BEING SPENT OTHER
CASES WE CAN'T. THEY'RE NOT
COMPARABLE ACROSS THE WEEK WE
CAN'T DO ANY COMPARATIVE
ANALYSIS UP REALLY THE FIRST
PIECE OF THIS IS THIS TO DO
STANDARDIZED STRUCTURED
REPORTING ON CATEGORIES THAT WE
DEFINE TOGETHER- THROUGH RULE
MAKING PROCESS- TO GET IT THOSE
THINGS- TO KNOW WHERE THE
INVESTMENTS ARE AGAIN FROM
READING ALL OF THE REPORTS. AS A
STUDENT SAID IN SOME CASES WE
THINK SOME OF THIS IS HAPPENING
TODAY BUT WE CAN'T QUANTIFY AND
I THINK THAT THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT PIECE TO GET OUT IN
TERMS OF TRANSPARENCY IN IT AND
ALLOWING THE COMMUNITY TO BE
CLEAR. ON WHAT IS HAPPENING
WHAT'S NOT HAPPENING. I WILL
STAY CALL. WITHOUT NEEDING.
NUMBER BUT- ALL. YOU SAID THE
WERE SIX BILLION. FOR COMMUNITY
BAND FOR THE HOSPITAL AND THAT
FOUR BILLION OF THAT GOES INTO
UNCOMPENSATED CARE. WITH THE
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSIONS THAT ARE
EXPECTED FROM US AS A STATE OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS WHAT DO WE
ANTICIPATE TO HAPPEN. WITH
UNCOMPENSATED. CARE AND DO WE
EXPECT IT TO CONTINUE TO BE FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE UPCOMING
YEARS. IT ALL START TO THAT SB
IS IT KIND OF DEMONSTRATES HOW
DIFFICULT IS COULD NUMBERS THOSE
THOSE DATA WERE ACTUALLY TAKEN
FROM FEDERAL TAX RETURNS THAT WE
YOU KNOW WE THINK THAT THAT WAS
ACCURATE AND IN TWENTY NINETEEN
IT WASN'T- FULLY. CAPTURING THE
UNDERSTAND IN IN- OF MEDICAID
AND MEDICARE SO WE WOULD EXPECT
I THINK FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE
FOR A SORT OF MORAL TO YOUR
ACCOUNT IF YOU'RE A CALCULATED
WITHIN THE MANY BENEFITS. OF THE
SCHEME SO I THINK I WOULD I
WOULD START THERE AND- YEAH I
KNOW I ADD THE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THERE'S NO
MINIMUM. AMOUNT BENEFITS
PROMISED INVEST IN THEIR
COMMUNITY BENEFITS SO BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT INCLUDING
UNCOMPENSATED CARE IN THE
FORMULA. IT WOULDN'T CHANGE THE
INVESTMENTS POTENTIALLY THAT
PEOPLE ARE MAKING. FUN WE DON'T
KNOW THAT. I THINK WHAT I'M
TRYING TO SAY IS IF THE LEVEL OF
UNCOMPENSATED CARE IS NOW LOWER
SINCE WERE COVERING MORE
INDIVIDUALS. IS THERE ARE MORE
RESOURCES FOR US TO BE
DISCUSSING. THAT THEN WILL BE
AVAILABLE AT.
I WOULD SAY YES I THINK THE
QUESTION IS THAT THE LATE INTO
MORE INVESTMENT CAN. THIS IS.
NOT THAT. I WILL TRY TO ANY.
SURE. THE FACT THAT. TO TRY JUST
TODAY. THE EXTRA BUCKS TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE PROPOSAL I HAVE
SPECIFIC CRITERIA SOME TELEPHONE
. THE QUESTION. FINANCIAL FOR
THE HOSPITAL'S TRACKING. SURE
STORE. SURE. THAT AT.
AT BEST. BUT IN. SO THE STANDARD
REPORT. BASED ON THAT.
I'M GOING TO LOG OFF AND LOG
BACK IN AND SEE IF THAT HELPS
THAT SOUNDS GREAT- I WILL
REITERATE I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S
ON YOUR AND IT'S WE NEED TO
FIGURE IT OUT ON THE SIDE BUT
OKAY- HAPPY TO GIVE YOU THAT%
SPACE AS WELL OKAY. OKAY LET ME
JUST TRY IT. THANK YOU. GIPSON.
I GOT A TEXT THAT IT STARTED
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES AGO YEAH
DECEMBER TWENTY. BEFORE THE. I
GOT A HEARING SERVING CAME BACK
. OKAY. CREATIONS OF THE PROJECT. I REMEMBER. THE DOCTOR GOT HIM
BACK IN. I CAN HEAR YOU LOUDLY
AND CLEARLY AND LET'S HOPE IT
WORKS IF YOU WANT TO BEGIN
DOCTOR GOT. OKAY I'LL START OVER
AGAIN YOU MIGHT HAVE TO PUT ME
ON SPEAKER- OF THE PANEL SO THAT
YOU CAN SEE ME YOU CAN. SEE
VIDEO OTHERWISE I'LL GO AHEAD
AND JUST THE- REQUESTED. AS SOON
AS YOU BEGIN SPEAKING WE SHOULD
APPEAR. HELLO KATHY OKAY
HOPEFULLY THANK OUT TAKING CARE
OF THEM TO GO AHEAD JUST ALL
START OVER AGAIN. I'M STOP AMP
REALLY ARE HERE TO BE PRESENTING
ON THE FOUNDATION THE FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH OVER THE PAST
DECADES PUBLIC HEALTH ACTIONS
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO PROTECT THE
INTENT OF PROVIDING HEALTH WELL
BEING AND QUALITY OF LIFE. FOR
ALL OF CALIFORNIA HOWEVER WE NOW
FACE SOME OF THE BIGGEST THREATS
TO HUMAN HEALTH. CALIFORNIA
FACES NUMEROUS PUBLIC HEALTH
CHALLENGES WHICH IMPACT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
AMPLIFY SOCIAL INEQUITIES THESE
CHALLENGES WILL INCREASE THE
SCALE SCOPE AND SEVERITY. OUR
POPULATION IS GROWING AS WELL AS
THEY JEAN WE SEE THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE INCLUDING DROUGHT
WILDFIRES HEAT WAVES IMPORTER
QUALITY. ECONOMIC DISPARITIES
AND SOCIAL DISPLACEMENT
INTENSIFIED STRESS AND ANXIETY
WE ARE WITNESSING AN ESCALATION
OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH CONCERNS
INCLUDING ISOLATION TRAUMA AND
ADDICTION. OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS THE COBIT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC UNLEASHED PROFOUND AND
DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES ON THE
ESPECIALLY OUR MOST VULNERABLE.
THE PANDEMIC ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
THE NEED FOR ADEQUATE
INVESTMENTS IN PUBLIC HEALTH AND
EXPOSE SIGNIFICANT GAPS IN THE
ABILITY OF CV PH. A LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS TO RESPOND RAPIDLY
AND SUSTAINABLY TO THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. FOR DECADES THE
LEVEL OF PUBLIC INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC HEALTH AT THE NATIONAL
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL. HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY BELOW WHAT IS
NEEDED FOR AN EQUITABLE PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM THAT CAN KEEP
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTHY AND SAFE.
CITY PH NOW HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO LEVERAGE PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACHES TO SHAPE AN EQUITABLE
RECOVERY AND ADDRESS THE FULL
RANGE OF FACTORS THAT INFLUENCE
A PERSON'S OVERALL HEALTH AND
WELL BEING. NEW AND EXISTING
POPULATION HEALTH CONCERNS HAVE
HEIGHTENED THE IMPORTANCE OF
INVESTING IN A MODERNIZE PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM FOCUSING ON
PROTECTION PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS. THIS INVESTMENT
ENABLES US TO NOT ONLY BUILD
BACK BETTER BUT BUILT BACK MORE
EQUITABLY LEAVING NO COMMUNITY
BEHIND. THE FOUNDATION FOR THE
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH PROPOSAL
WILL BUILD CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM. THAT IDENTIFIES CORE
GOVERNMENTAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
FOUNDATIONAL FOUNDATIONAL PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICE INVOLVEMENT
CAPABLE OF MEETING CURRENT AND
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS. CDPH
REQUEST FOUR HUNDRED AND FOUR
POSITIONS AND GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF THREE
HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALLY TO
MODERNIZE CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEMS. OF THESE
RESOURCES TWO HUNDRED POINT FOUR
MILLION WITH SUPPORT
CALIFORNIANS SIXTY ONE LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS AND NINETY
NINE POINT SIX MILLION WOULD
SUPPORT STATEWIDE PUBLIC HEALTH
PRIORITY THE CDPH. CALIFORNIA
STATE GOVERNMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE REQUIRE
SUSTAINABLE INVESTMENTS IN SIX
FOUNDATIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICE AREAS THE FIRST WHAT IS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
RECRUITMENT. BUT THIS IS THE
FOCUS ON IMPROVING OUR CAPACITY
AND ABILITY TO RECRUIT RETAIN
RETAIN AND DEVELOP A DIVERSE
WORKFORCE. THE CITY PAGE PLAN
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
POSITIONS AND FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION TO INCREASE TRAFFIC
CAPACITY TO ATTRACT DEVELOP AND
RETAIN THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE. IT INCLUDES-
INITIATIVES SUCH AS THE STUBBLE
SEEN OUR FIRST OFFICE OF POLICY
AND PLANNING STRENGTHENING OUR
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT- A
CAPABILITIES FOCUSING ON LEAN
METHODS TO DELIVER RESULTS IN
ELIMINATE WASTE. ESTABLISHING A
REGIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICE TO
SPECIALLY MADE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
NEEDS OF A LOT OF. YES OF
CALIFORNIA TO HELP OUR HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
RESOURCES. AND STREET OF COURSE
STRENGTHENING RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION THE SECOND AREA IS IN
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS OUR
RESPONSE. FOCUSING ON IMPROVING
OUR CAPACITY TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES OF ALL KINDS FROM
NATURAL DISASTERS TO INFECTIOUS
DISEASE OUTBREAKS TO
BIOTERRORISM. THE CDPH PLAN
INCLUDE SEVENTY SEVEN POSITIONS
AND TWENTY SEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION FOR A SCALABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE STRUCTURE THAT CAN
IDENTIFY AND RESPOND
EFFECTIVELY. WE WILL DEVELOP A
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN INTELLIGENCE
HUB WE'RE GOING TO IMPROVE OUR
PLANNING TRAINING AND EXERCISES
ACROSS THE EXERCISES ACROSS THE
STATE. FOR DISASTER WERE
REPAIRED PREPARED AS A RESPONSE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE WHAT'S
CALLED A REGIONAL RESOURCE THE
MODEL TO REALLY FACILITATE- THAT
UP THE- COORDINATING EFFORT
EFFORTS ACROSS THE STATE WITH
RESPECT TO THE SEVENTEEN A
PUBLIC HEALTH RESOURCES WHEN
REQUIRED. AND DEVELOPING OUR
FIRST DEDICATED RECOVERY UNIT
THE THIRD AREA IS IT DATA
SCIENCE AND INFORMATICS THE PLAN
INCLUDES THREE POSITIONS AND
FEEDS FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
EXPAND. OUR CALIFORNIA BIRTH
DEFECTS MONITORING PROGRAM A
SEPARATE B. C. P. BOB IS BEING
SUBMITTED TO FOCUS. ON
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS. THE
NEXT AREAS PUBLIC EDUCATION
ENGAGEMENT AND BEHAVIORAL CHANGE
THIS IS TO IMPROVE OUR ABILITY
TO ENGAGE DIVERSE PUBLIC
AUDIENCES WITH TIMELY SCIENCE
BASED. CULTURAL CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
HEALTH INFORMATION. THE CITY
PEACE PLAN INCLUDES TWENTY SIX
POSITIONS AT FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO ACHIEVE THIS
EFFORT. INITIATIVES INCLUDE
CREATING A CORE PUBLIC HEALTH
COMMUNICATION STRATEGY ED.
BOLSTERING OUR OPERATIONAL
CAPABILITIES AND ADEQUATE
CAPACITY TO DISSEMINATE
COMMUNICATIONS. THE NEXT AREA IS
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS THIS IS
TO IMPROVE OUR ABILITY TO ENGAGE
COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS AND TO
CREATE CROSS SECTOR
COLLABORATIONS THE CITY PEACE
PLAN INCLUDES FIVE POSITIONS AND
TWO POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
TO ACHIEVE THIS. INITIATIVES
INCLUDE DEVELOPING A COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIP STRATEGY AND PLAN
AND ALSO A DEDICATED COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT PERSONNEL. AND THEN
THE LAST AREA IS OUR COMMUNITY
HEALTH IMPROVEMENT AND THAT'S TO
IMPROVE OUR ABILITY TO PARTNER
WITH HEALTH SYSTEMS IMPLANTS A
COMMUNITY HEALTH EQUITY AND- AN
IMPROVEMENT. THE CITY PAGE PLAN
INCLUDES TWENTY THREE POSITIONS
ARE SIX POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS EFFORT
INITIATIVES INCLUDE COMMUNITY
HEALTH FINANCING STRATEGIES.
DEDICATED COMMUNITY HEALTH
IMPROVEMENT TEAM AND ALSO
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING A
COORDINATION AROUND BEHAVIORAL
MENTAL HEALTH PREVENTION ACROSS
THE STATE. THE LOCALS WILL ALSO
BE DOING IT WILL ALSO HAVE-
SOME. FOCUS AREAS AS WELL
INCLUDING A FOCUS ON WORKFORCE
EXPANSION WERE 70% OF THE FUNDS
WILL BE USED TO HIRE THE STAFF.
ALSO FOCUS ON REDUCING HEALTH
DISPARITIES WITH A MINIMUM A
MINIMUM AMOUNT OF THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS GOING TO
EACH HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. AND
THEN THE REST OF IT BEING
ALLOCATED BASED ON POPULATION
DATA POVERTY INDEX AND ALSO UP
PROPORTIONS OF THE DIFFERENT
RACIAL ETHNIC ETHNICITIES. AND
THEN THE OUT OF FOCUS ON DATA
COLLECTION AND MONITORING.
THAT'S AN OVERVIEW OF THE OF OUR
PROPOSAL I'M GOING TO TURN IT
OVER TO SUSAN FANELLI CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR POLICY AND
PROGRAMS AT CDPH WILL ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE SUBMITTED TO
THEM. WHO SERVE. REALLY HAPPY TO
BE HERE TODAY AS YOU KNOW IT'S
BEEN A LONG COUPLE OF YEARS AND-
EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO HIRE NEW
POSITIONS AND THE FIRST QUESTION
IS WHAT IS THE OUR STRATEGY TO
ENSURE AN ADEQUATE POOL OF
CANDIDATES- WE'VE BEEN.
SUCCESSFULLY USING VARIOUS
RECRUITMENT PLATFORMS AND
POSTING SITES TO RECORD FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH PHYSICIANS WILL
CONTINUE TO SOURCE RECRUITMENT
OPTIONS. THAT REALLY TARGET
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES AND
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THOSE VARIOUS RECRUITMENT
OPTIONS SUCH AS THE NUMBER OF.
CANDIDATES THAT WE GET TO
PARTICIPATE IN VIRTUAL
RECRUITMENT EVENTS NUMBER OF
CANDIDATES THAT APPLIED THROUGH
POSTING SITE AND QUALIFICATIONS
OF THOSE CANDIDATES. WE'VE
CONVENE DEPARTMENT WORKS TO PRE
PLAN FOR OUR INCREASED OUTREACH
AND RECRUITMENT. SORRY IT'S
ALLERGY SEASON FOR ME
RECRUITMENT TO EFFECTIVELY RAMP
UP HIRING. BLESSED ARE. COME
BACK TO ME SORRY. YOU WANT TO
TAKE A SIP OF WATER. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO BRANDON NUNEZ CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
SO I DON'T THINK IDEALLY
PRESENTERS FOR THIS SPECIFIC
ISSUE WITH GOING TO BE MYSELF
AND FENCES AND FANELLI. I'M BACK
. ALL RIGHT SORRY MISPRONOUNCING
YOU CAN PLEASE CONTINUE IF YOU
CAN. SURE SO WE HAVE CONVENE THE
DEPARTMENT WORKGROUP TO PRE
PLANNED FOR. ANGRIEST OUTREACH
AND RECRUITMENT AND I'M RAMPS
AND WE'VE BEEN RAMPING THAT UP
CREATED DEDICATED TEAMS.
REPRESENTING BOTH HUMAN
RESOURCES AND PROGRAM AREAS TO
STRATEGIZE SOURCES OF NEED A
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES. AND TO
DIVERSIFY OUT OF REACH. THESE
TEAMS HAVE ASSISTED IN RECENT
HIRING OF OVER TWO HUNDRED-
STAFF FOR COVERT RESPONSE AND WE
THINK THAT. MANY OF THOSE FOLKS
COULD TRANSITION INTO NEW
PERMANENT POSITIONS. I WE ARE
DANCING EFFORTS TO UP SKILL OUR
WORKFORCE BECAUSE WE DO BELIEVE
THAT IF WE HIGHER BUT WE WHOSE
STAFF. BUT WE WILL NOT BE IN THE
RIGHT WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO ADD. THE EFFORTS TO
UP SKILL THE WORKFORCE TO
PROVIDE FOR DANCE MEANT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EXISTING
EMPLOYEES. WHILE WE'RE
INCREASING RETENTION OF BUILDING
OUR LEADERSHIP PIPELINE TURKEY
DEPARTMENT POSITIONS. UPSKILLING
YOUR WORKFORCE INCLUDES ENHANCE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND CAREER
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. SO SORRY
SITTING HERE TO BE WORKING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES TO UPDATE OUR
CLASSIFICATION SYSTEM. AND PAY
SCALES AS NEEDED TO REMOVE
BARRIERS TO RECRUITMENT OF
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS AND
INCREASE RETENTION OF EXISTING
EMPLOYEES. THIS WILL LOOK AT
DIVERSITY IN OUR WORKFORCE I AM
THE NEW TYPES OF COMPLICATIONS
THAT. REVISIT THE MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS WORK THINGS LIKE
EDUCATION ALLOW FOLKS WHO HAVE
LIVED EXPERIENCED YOU APPLY FOR
SOME OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
POSITIONS EXPANDING SOME OUR-
EFFORTS LIKE OUR PATHWAYS
PROGRAM WHICH IN WHICH WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO. BRING ON FORTY
FIVE PEOPLE FROM ACROSS THE
STATE AND PLACED THEM ON OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND THEY'RE
PERFORMING A VARIETY OF PUBLIC
HEALTH FUNCTIONS. THE SECOND
QUESTION WE HAVE IS HOW WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INVESTMENT
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH STAFF
ALLOWED TO SUPPORT OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. WE REALLY BELIEVE
THAT SPRING BUT NEVER
FOUNDATIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
FOR STRUCTURE THESE INVESTMENTS
WILL SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPAND OUR SUPPORT FOR LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. THE FULL
SPECTRUM UP C. PAGES EFFORT
EXPERTISE WILL BE MOBILIZED TO
SUPPORT L. A. J. IS RESPONDING
TO AND RECOVERING FROM THE
CULVERT PANDEMIC AND TO ME
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE AND
CHANGING PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS. WE
PLAN TO BUILD OUR REGIONAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICE THAT WILL
PROVIDE EXPERTISE JUST SMALLER
LOW RESOURCE OUT DEPARTMENTS
PARTICULARLY IN THE AREAS OF
COMMUNICATIONS AND IBM DATA
ANALYTICS. PROVIDING A FORMAT-
FORM FOR STANDARDIZATION OF
POLICY ACROSS EACH PUBLIC HEALTH
REGION AND FOR GATHERING INPUTS
ON THE STATE POLICIES. INCLUDING
PUBLIC HEALTH POLICY AGENDA FOR
THE STATE HELLO IN COLLABORATION
WITH OUR NEW YORK OFFICE OF
POLICY AND PLANNING. WE
ADMINISTER IT WILL BE
ADMINISTERING THE STATE GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS DEVELOPING METRICS
GOALS AND OTHER STANDARDS FOR
INVESTING IN THESE BONDS. WE
WILL CONDUCT ANALYSIS OF OTHER
REGIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS
SUCH AS REGIONALIZATION OF
TRAINING LABORATORY CAPACITY AND
OTHER ISSUES. OUR STATE LEVEL
PUBLIC HEALTH LEADERSHIP AND
CAPACITY WILL ALSO PROVIDE
RESOURCES TOOLS AND SUPPORT FOR
ALLEGE DAYS IN CRITICAL AREAS
WHERE STATEWIDE ALIGNMENT AND
PROGRAMMATIC SUPPORT CAN BOLSTER
AND ADVANCE LOCAL EFFORTS. IT'S
AGAIN WILL INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
THE STATEWIDE COMMUNICATIONS
DATA STANDARDS OPERATIONS
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS
EVALUATION METHODOLOGIES
PLANNING REGENCY RESPONSE IN
EQUITY. STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
STAFF WILL ORGANIZE AND
IMPLEMENT THESE CRITICAL
ACTIVITIES IN SUPPORT OF AND IN
COLLABORATION WITH L. H. DAYS TO
PROMOTE IMPROVED PUBLIC HEALTH
PRACTICE AND OUTCOMES STATEWIDE
. INVESTMENT IN STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORK FIRST WILL ALSO
RESTORE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
MODIFIED OR TEMPORARILY
SUSPENDED AND PROVIDE MORE
COMPLETE PROGRAMMATIC SUPPORT.
IN ADDRESSING THE CONSEQUENCES
OF POPULATION HEALTH BURDEN.
WORKFORCE EXPANSION WILL ALSO
ENGAGE A NEW SET OF STRATEGIC
SKILLS AND TECHNICAL
COMPETENCIES REQUIRED TO BE
CUTTING EDGE IN PUBLIC OUT SUCH
AS WORKING MORE CLOSELY ON
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
PREDICTIVE ANALYTICS CLIMATE
CHANGE NERD MEET MORE
EFFECTIVELY. TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
SERVE IN SUPPORT- ALLEGE THEY
WORK IN THESE NEW DOMAINS. OUR
OFFICE OF POLICY AND PLANNING
WILL BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ESTABLISHING CLEAR QUANTIFIABLE
PERFORMANCE TARGETS TO ROUTE
ROGRESS ON THESE INITIATIVES AT
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL AND
BUILD CAPACITY FOR STRATEGIC
LEADERSHIP TO ANTICIPATE AND
ADDRESS NEW AND EMERGING PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUES. SUCH AS ON
BEHALF. YEARS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE LAST
QUESTION WAS HOW DO WE PROPOSED
TO ENSURE THAT COUNTIES DON'T
SHIP EXISTING REALIGNMENT
FUNDING AWAY FROM PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPACTS FELT. I'M WILL LEVERAGE
THE DISTRIBUTION OF THE TWO
HUNDRED FOR. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR MILLION AND LOCAL SYSTEMS
TO JUMPSTART ADVANCEMENT OF THE
IN THE OF THE VISION THAT WE'VE
OUTLINED WE'VE ENGAGE WITH SHE
ACTUALLY C. O. H. I. O. N. S.
YEAH YOU TO DROP THE
METHODOLOGY. TO ALLOCATE THE
FUNDING TO ALL ALLEGE DAYS WITH
THE INTENT OF DISRUPTING THAT
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF
PREVENTABLE DISEASES IN
POPULATIONS HISTORICALLY
IMPACTED. ENCOURAGING
COLLABORATION ACROSS COUNTIES
AND MAKING SURE FUNDS ARE USED
TO SUPPLEMENT RATHER THAN
SUPPLANT. ADDITIONALLY THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE IS INCLUDED
FOR FUNDING TO SPECIFICALLY
PROHIBITS A PLANTATION- AS THE
PLANNING OF EXISTING PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICE SETS. LANGUAGE
INCLUDES LOCAL REAP REALIGNMENT
DOLLARS AS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
DOLLARS THAT COULD NOT BE
SUPPLANTED. THE LANGUAGE ALSO
REQUIRES LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS TO ANNUALLY
CERTIFY THAT IS NOT USING THE
FUNDING PROVIDED JUST A PLAN ALL
OTHER LOCAL COUNTY FUNDS. WE'RE
REALLY WORKING WITH THE ACT AND
CCLI JELENT S. YEAH YOU'D YOU
SET THOSE METRICS AND BAN THOSE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS FOR THIS
FUNDING SO THAT WE CAN TRACK AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE EVALUATING
WHAT'S WORKING AND WHAT
IMPROVEMENTS ARE BEING MADE WITH
THESE DOLLARS AND SO. THAT
REGIONAL HEALTH OFFICE WILL HAVE
A STAFF NOT ONLY OF THE
EXPERTISE IN COMMUNICATIONS AND
HAPPY AND- LOCAL COORDINATOR-
AND DATA ANALYTICS BUT WE ALSO
HAVE A SECTION THAT WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ADMINISTERING
THESE BOMBS. AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE ACTIVITIES ARE.
HAPPENING THERE ARE NONE AS
PROPOSED. IN THEIR WORK PLANS
AND BUDGETS. WITHOUT I WILL AND
THEN HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU AND JUST TO
CONFIRM THERE ARE NO OTHER
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH-
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL IS THAT
CORRECT. THAT'S THAT'S CORRECT
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM SONYA
PADDOCK WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THANK YOU SIR
AND YOU PICK THE L. A. O. WE
THINK THE PROPOSED PLAN HAS
NUMEROUS MERITS- FOR EXAMPLE
INCREASING REAL TIME
SURVEILLANCE DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE COORDINATING
REGIONAL EPIDEMIOLOGICAL AND
COMMUNICATIONS ACTIVITIES AND
IMPROVING STRATEGIC PLANNING.
WE'D LIKE TO IDENTIFY A FEW
ISSUES WHICH IF ADDRESSED WE
BELIEVE COULD POTENTIALLY
STRENGTHEN THE PLAN. SO FIRST
WOULD NOT THAT THE PLAN DOES NOT
INCLUDE THREE KEY OBJECTIVES.
FIRST CREATING A WORKFORCE
PIPELINE ALTHOUGH THE PLAN DOES
INCLUDE A MULTI FACETED APPROACH
TO RECRUITMENT TRAINING-
RECRUITMENT TRAINING AS WELL AS
INTERNAL EDUCATION AND
ADVANCEMENT OPPORTUNITIES IT
DOESN'T- INCLUDE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR- DEVELOPING A PIPELINE FOR
FUTURE WORK FORCE- WE UNDERSTAND
THE DEPARTMENT FOR EXAMPLE DID
NOT- CONSULT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION ON- SOME OF THEIR
WORK FIRST PIPELINE. A PROGRAMS-
SECOND THE PLAN DOES NOT INCLUDE
STRENGTHENING THE STATE WIDE
PUBLIC HEALTH LAB NETWORK- IT
DOES INCLUDE FUNDING FOR THE
STATE LAB IN FOR LAB FIELD
SERVICES. GARCIA COMMERCIAL LAB
YOU KNOW LICENSING OF COMMERCIAL
LABS BUT THERE ARE NO
REQUIREMENTS ARE PLANS FOR
ENSURING THAT THE TWENTY EIGHT.
REMAINING LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
LABS ARE STAFFED AND SUSTAINED-
THIRD THE PLAN DOES INCLUDE
LAYING OUT AN OVER ARCHING I. T.
STRATEGY. CDPH NOTED TO OUR
OFFICE THAT IT DOESN'T TEND TO
HIRE A CHIEF IT STRATEGIST. AND
DEVELOP A STRATEGY. BUT WHEN
THIS PLAN WOULD BE AVAILABLE AND
HOW THAT FUTURE VISION I. T.
VISION WILL BE FUNDED REMAINS
UNCLEAR. OUR NEXT WE THINK THAT
THE PLAN COULD HAVE STRONGER
OVERSIGHT OF LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS AS WRITTEN THE
PLAN DOES NOT LAY OUT. A MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS OR GOALS FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. REGARDING TYING
THE LOCAL PLANS TO THE COMMUNITY
HEALTH ASSESSMENTS OUR COMMUNITY
HEALTH IMPROVEMENT PLANS WOULD
NOT A COUPLE OF THINGS FIRST-
NOT ALL LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
COMMUNITY HEALTH ASSESSMENTS OUR
COMMUNITY HEALTH IMPROVEMENT
PLANS- WE ALSO KNOW THAT THESE
PLANS AND ASSESSMENTS- CAN
SOMETIMES INCLUDE GOALS THAT GO
BEYOND THE PURVIEW OF PUBLIC
HEALTH- JUST TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE
IT COULD INCLUDE STRENGTHENING
HEALTH CARE. WORKFORCE OR
INCREASING STABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS- TYING LOCAL PLANS
DIRECTLY TO THESE MAY NOT BE THE
BEST SUBSTITUTE FOR A MORE
DELIBERATE AND CONSISTENT TYPE
OF A LOCAL PLAN ACROSS THE LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS- A MORE
CONSISTENT TYPE OF PLAN WOULD
ALSO MAKE STATEWIDE EVALUATION
TO BE EASIER- SO WE WOULD JUST
REYES AND CLOSING A FEW ISSUES
FOR LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION-
FIRST WE'D SUGGEST CONSIDERING.
REQUESTING MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE OBJECTIVES THAT WERE
NOT INCLUDED IN THE PLAN SO WORK
FIRST PIPELINE PUBLIC HEALTH LAB
NETWORK AN OVER ARCHING I. T.
STRATEGY- SECONDS SO WE WOULD-
SUGGEST CONSIDERING REQUIRING
MORE CDPH MANAGEMENT OF THE
LOCAL PLAN DEVELOPMENT AND
OVERSIGHT OF LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS USE OF FUNDS. IN
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER CONSIDER IDENTIFYING-
COMMON PUBLIC HEALTH OBJECTIVES
OR GOALS THAT WOULD PRIORITIZE
UNIVERSALLY ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT. AND THEN. YEAH YEAH.
YEAH. OKAY A LOT OF PEOPLE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE A POSITIVE SIGN TO
CASTING. SO HAVE. GET THAT CODE
SET UP SO. BEFORE I PUT THE GUY
ON THE LINE I SHOULD CONNECTS
WITH SORT OF AN ACCOUNT THE
PASSWORD AND THEN. SURE THE CLUB
THEN THE CONNECTION SURE. HOUSES
ARE MORE THESE MAYBE WE SHOULD
HAVE PASSWORD SOMETHING. RIGHT.
FIVE
IN YOUR.
ZERO
THIS IS. YOU HAVE A JOB. YEAH AB
ON.
THIS IT'S. ONE SIX PEOPLE. THIS
IS. LOOK AT MY HEAD IN THERE
ANYTIME SOON.
INSPECTION OKAY.
SHE WAS HEARINGS. TALKING. IT'S
TALKING- SO.
THIS IS. YEAH.
WHICH IS. TO SHE. CHIEF.
RIGHT.
MORE FOR YOURSELF YEAH. BUT IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN IN A VACUUM IT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED THE FOURTEENTH
. NOTING THAT I'M PART OF IS A
MULTI DISCIPLINARY. FOR A COUPLE
OF THE PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF. IT
ALSO INCLUDED WITH THE AUGUST.
HI I AM ASK US TO HIT PAUSE
AGAIN WE'RE HAVING THOSE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES THE
GENERAL PUBLIC ARE UNABLE TO
HEAR WHAT YOU'RE TESTIFYING IN
SO I MAY JUST HAVE US WAIT A
MINUTE OR TWO UNTIL IT GETS UP
AND RUNNING APOLOGIES- WE WILL
BE RIGHT BACK TO. ASSEMBLY THE
WORKING. THE.
I GOT A TEXT THAT IT'S BACK ON.
JULIO LET'S GIVE IT ANOTHER
EFFORT- YOU MAY WE MAY BE BACK
ONLINE- IF YOU CAN BEGIN AGAIN.
SURE I COULDN'T BEGIN BEGINNING
SO MY NAME IS WHATEVER MAYOR.
SPONSORED WITH WALKING COUNTY
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S. ALL TO PROVIDE AND
ALTHOUGH ON GOING SUPPORT COULD
BE BUILT- STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. WHAT WAS I'M PART
OF A SMALL TOOL NEED A SMALL UP
RESEARCHERS IN WASHINGTON. BONTA
WILL BEGIN AND NEEDS LABORATORY
. FIVE I WAS PART OF THE THAT
BROUGHT ON OF ITI THINK THE
OFFENSE BUT I'M ALSO IN WITH THE
COULD THE- AND THE BOTTOM
BACTERIA WE- THE WORK I DO IN
THE- SURVEY THAT WE PROVIDE
WALKING. IS IT'S NOT ON FIRE
STOP BY BY PEOPLE WHO WHAT PART
OF THE GROUP OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. THIS IS A WHAT
THEIR DISCIPLINARY THAT SUPPOSED
WHAT MYSELF AS FAR. AS POSSIBLE
THAT IT COULD BE ALL JUST. THANK
YOU PETER SOMETHING SKATERS
INTERMEDIATE WORKERS. WHAT WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS AS A RESPONSE. SB
ADVANCE. BARRON PARK. AN OLD
BOARDING HAD A LOT OF SUCCESS.
THIRTEEN MORE IMPORTANT TO BE
THE- Y. W. LOST AT THE
SUPERVISORS A VERY. BUT THE WORK
I WOULDN'T CARE SUCCESS WERE
HELD THERE OUT OF REACH OUT OF
BY WORK THAT BOTH PEOPLE. FOR
EXAMPLE. HERE SO OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WORK AFFECTED
BY OKAY BABBAGE BUCKLE. YEAH
MOTOR CARE. AND THE LIKE WERE
ARE NOT BEING ALSO MADE BY THE
RULES RENDON ORGANISED OR DOWN.
THERE IS AN ORGAN CALL CANADA.
NOW WHY IS IT IMPORTANT. ALL IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT'S HIGHLY
RESIST. HELLO THAT WE OUT THAT
IN OTHER SAME THING DEVELOPER
DEVASTATED. IN THE BEGINNING THE
FACT THAT MAKE ALL BE OVERDRAWN
BY STATE OF THIS ORDER THE. IT
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT EXIST
INTEL. YOUR AND NOW IT'S SEE IF
I CAN ASK FOR OFTEN TELL ONE SO
THE REASON WHY THE SAP BECAUSE-
LARGER. WITH A BEARD WALKED FOR
THE WITHOUT FUNDS. CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC HEALTH.
ONE POINT FUND. THE STOCK. I
WOULD LIKE YOU GUYS TO KNOW MIND
THAT BUT INSTEAD GUYS ARE OF
THIS VETERANS OFF THE RIGHT. BY
LAW OF PEOPLE LIKE ME TO DO MY
JOB. THERE BY INCREASE
INCREDIBLE POLITICS OF WE
PROVIDE. I'M GOING TO IMPROVE
THE WHY HELP SIR. THANK YOU FOR
THE FAR. THANK YOU MUCH WITHOUT
IT WILL BRING UP TO THE DAY FOR
ANY THAT WE MAY HAVE. SEEN NINE
I WILL KEEP IT HERE WITH THE
CHAIR I WILL ASK MY FIRST
QUESTION OF DOCTOR ERAGON AND TO
SUSAN FANELLI. I'M TRYING TO
FOLLOW UP- GIVEN OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE CHALLENGES THAT
WE HAE HEARD ABOUT BOTH IN THIS
HEARING TODAY AS WELL AS IN THE
JOINT HEARING THAT WE HAD LAST
WEEK DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THE
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION IS
SUFFICIENT FOR US TO ADDRESS OUR
WORKFORCE CHALLENGES AND SECONDS
CAN YOU SPEAK ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT YOU'VE CONSIDERED. UTILIZING
EACH COP HEALTH PROFESSION
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
WHICH ALSO GOES THROUGH EACH GUY
AS A PIPELINE PROGRAM TO HELP-
STUDENTS INTO PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE HOPING YOU CAN COMMENT
ON THAT. I'M SUSAN COME AHEAD.
SURE I'M SO AT IN TERMS OF
WORKING THAT ON A KILEY WE WORK
WITH THEM IN TERMS OF SOME OF
THE RECRUITMENT HARD TO REACH-
RECRUITMENT CLASSIFICATIONS I
HAVEN'T WE KNOW THAT THE
MICROBIOLOGIST SERIES ARE HEALTH
OF FACILITIES EVALUATOR NURSE
SAYS SOME OF THE AREAS WHERE WE
KNOW WE HAVE DIFFICULTY IN
RECRUITING I THINK WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF STRATEGIES TO TRY TO
BUILD THAT PIPELINE AND WE WILL
WORK WITH H. K. BUT WILL ALSO.
DO THINGS LIKE WE'RE GOING TO DO
A CAMPAIGN TO WORK ACROSS THE
STATE WITH WORKING OUT I'M WHY
COME TO PUBLIC HEALTH WHY IS
THAT A GOOD PLACE TO WORK WE NOW
WE HAVE TO GET DOWN AS WE BUILD
THE LONG TERM WE NEED TO GET
DOWN TO THE FOLKS IN HIGH
SCHOOLS AND BRING THEY MAKE
EVERYBODY KNOWS WITH THAT DOCTOR
ARE FIREMEN ARE BUT NOT
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT A PUBLIC
HEALTH SEGMENT AS THE AND SO WE
NEED TO. DO BETTER ACROSS THE
STATE WILL CERTAINLY BE LOOKING
UP PIPELINES PERSON NEEDS WITH
COMMUNITY I'M TRAINING COLLEGES
AS WELL I'M AND CONTINUING TO
BUILD THAT I DON'T I CAN'T
COMMENT ON THE FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION I'M YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT WE ALL NOW IT'S GOING TO
COST DOLLARS DO YOU REALLY AND
MAKE SURE THAT RECRUITMENT
EFFORTS ACROSS THE STATE NOT
ONLY WITH THE STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT BUT WE SEE REALLY BIG
CHALLENGES AND SOME OF OUR SMALL
RURAL AREAS AND IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND RECRUITING POSITIONS
AND SO WE WILL BE WORKING WITH
THEM. ON. IN PARKWAYS PROGRAM
WHICH THINK IF YOU EVER GET A
CHANCE TO MEET ANY OF THOSE YOU.
FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE PATHWAY
PRO. THERE INCREDIBLE COME WITH
A- OF BACK. AND REALLY CAN. IN
PUBLIC HEALTH IN WAYS THAT IN I
THINK WE WILL SEE FOR YEARS TO
COME IF WE CAN CONTINUE THAT
TYPE OF A PROGRAM. TO RECRUIT
PEOPLE THAT I'M HAVE VERY
DIFFERENT LIVED EXPERIENCES AND
REFLECT OUR POPULATION- DO YOU
WANT TO APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
AND REALLY- I HEAR YOU ON NOT
WANTING TO- MAKE A COMMENT ON
THE WORK FORCE NUMBER. BUT HOPE
THAT YOU HEAR FROM THE
LEGISLATURE A WILLINGNESS TO
ENGAGE AND WORK IN THE SPACE AND
ADDRESS THE NEED HEAD ON WE SEE
WE HEAR THOSE WHO ARE COMMITTED
TO PUBLIC SERVICE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MAKE SURE WERE
APPROPRIATELY SUPPORTING THEM.
THAT I'D NOW LIKE TO REALLY DAY
AND IF I CAN TO THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT NON
SUPPLEMENTATION LANGUAGE I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT
FOR US AS WE ARE- YOU SAID IT
WOULD BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE I
WOULD AGREE WITH THE L. A. ABOUT
THE NEED FOR US TO PUT THIS TO
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. SO THAT
WE CAN ANNUAL. WHY CAN YOU
SPEAK. WITH THE CLARITY THAT
YOU- HAVE ABOUT HOW WE- ARE
GOING TO WRITE IN NON
SUPPLEMENTATION LANGUAGE INTO
THE FUNDS WE ARE. GOING TO BE
SENDING DOWN TO THE LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS. WE DO ACTUALLY
HAVE THAT LANGUAGE AND WE'VE
USED IT IN A NUMBER OF FEDERAL
GRANTS AS WELL THE FUNDS
APPROPRIATED IN THIS ITEM SHALL
BE USED TO SUPPLEMENT RATHER
THAN SUPPLANT EXISTING LEVELS OF
THE SERVICES PROVIDED BY
QUALIFYING LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTION. EACH YEAR LOCAL
JURISDICTION RECEIVING FUNDS FOR
THIS ARTICLE SHALL ANNUALLY
CERTIFY TO THE TO THE DEPARTMENT
THAT'S PORTION OF THE FUNDING
SHOULD BE USED TO SUPPLANT NOT-
TO SUPPLEMENT AND NOT SUPPLANT
ALL OTHER SPECIFIC LOCAL COUNTY
FUNDS INCLUDING. BUT NOT LIMITED
TO LOCAL REALIGNMENT AND COUNTY
GENERAL FUND RESOURCES UTILIZED
HEALTH CARE SECTION PURPOSES AND
EXCLUDING FEDERAL FUNDS IN THIS
DETERMINATION IN ADDITION EACH
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS ALL
CERTIFY THAT 70% OF FUNDS WERE
USED TO SUPPORT STAFF INCLUDING
BENEFITS AND TRAINING AND THAT
REMAINING FUNDS NOT TO EXCEED
THIRTY PERCENT. MAY BE USED FOR
A QUICK MINUTE SUPPLIES AND
OTHER ADMINISTRATIVE PURPOSES
SUCH AS FACILITY SPACE
FURNISHINGS TRAVEL AND SIMILAR
ACTIVITIES AND EVERYTHING.
LANGUAGE THANK YOU UNDER PENALTY
OF PERJURY AFTER- SAYING THEY
ARE NOT- SUPPLEMENTING EXISTING
PLANS. MAYBE IT. WHAT'S THE-
THEN SO I UNDERSTAND THE
LANGUAGE ON THE FRONT AND- HOW
AND- HAVE WE EVER ENFORCED THIS
IS THIS A COMMON PRACTICE FOR US
TO- FOLLOW UP ON THAT LANGUAGE.
HOW CAN WE ENSURE THAT COUNTIES
ARE. FOLLOWING THE LETTER OF THE
LAW THAT YOU'RE READY. SO IT IS
A REQUIREMENT IN MOST OF OUR
FEDERAL FUNDING- THEY DO GET
AUDITED. I'M ON A ROUTINE BASIS-
AND SO I THINK THAT YOU HAVE
THAT THERE ARE METHODS TO REALLY
LOOK AT THAT I ALSO THINK THAT
IT WILL BE AN EVERYONE'S BEST
INTEREST TO POINT OUT ANY-
SUPPLEMENTATION AND PART OF
WORRIES AND YOU. HAVE THIS
LANGUAGE IN HERE IS SO THAT OUR
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS CAN
CALL OUR ATTENTION IF NEED BE-
THOSE ISSUES BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO PROTECT THESE DOLLARS AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE AS WELL. I'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO ASK THE SAME QUESTION
OF MICHELLE GIVENS IF I CAN WITH
JACK. YOU CAN PROVIDE SOME
COMMENTARY YEAH HAPPY TO I THINK
THE FIRST THING I WOULD MENTION
IS THE LANGUAGE THAT THEY'RE
READING OFF OF THIS LANGUAGE
THAT WE ALSO CRAFTED FOR THEM AS
WELL. SO I THINK THE FIRST AND
FOREMOST THING IS THAT OUR
MEMBERS ARE NOT LOOKING TO
SUPPLANT. WE REALLY ARE LOOKING
TO BOLSTER WORKFORCE I THINK
THERE'S BEEN A WIDESPREAD
RECOGNITION THAT LIKE THIS IS
NOT THE TIME TO GO BACKWARDS.
AND I THINK AND THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE PAST IS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE FUNDING THAT
COMES DOWN RIGHT SO. WE'RE
EXCITED AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT THAT LANGUAGE
BEING IN THERE ALSO TELLS THEIR
BOSSES THAT YOU CAN'T MOVE THAT
AND THAT'S A GREAT ASSURANCE FOR
US TO HAVE. THE OTHER PIECE THAT
I WOULD MENTION TO YOU IS THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE METRICS AND
WE WELCOME THOSE METRICS BECAUSE
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO SHOW YOU. THE VALUE
THAT THESE DOLLARS ARE BRINGING
BECAUSE WE WANT TO COME BACK TO
THE TABLE AND SAY LOOK WHAT WHAT
WE CAN DO. AND HOW MUCH MORE WE
CAN. AND SO WHAT WE HAVEN'T
FLESHED OUT EXACTLY WHAT THOSE
METRICS ARE GOING TO BE I CAN'T
IMAGINE IT BEING SOMEWHERE
AROUND LIKE WHAT. WHAT STAFF DID
YOU HIRE WHAT HAVE YOU DONE WHAT
PROGRAMS THAT BE FOCUSED ON AND
I THINK WITH THOSE METRICS
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SEE GROWTH
VERSUS SHRINKAGE. WHO WAS HOPING
TO FOLLOW UP ON YOUR COMMENT
REGARDING THE ELIMINATION OF.
COST BARRIERS. CAN YOU HELP US
TO QUANTIFY AND- DIRECT WHERE
THOSE. ARE AND WHETHER OR NOT.
THEY ARE HINDERING OUR ABILITY
TO. RECRUIT AND- RETAIN
QUALIFIED PUBLIC HEALTH
INDIVIDUALS. YEAH THERE'S-
THERE'S SEVERAL SO THE FOR THE
FIRST AND MOST OBVIOUS ONE IS
AROUND PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES. SO
IN ORDER TO GET YOUR PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE CERTIFICATION
YOU'RE ALREADY A REGISTERED
NURSE AND THEN YOU GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND AND GET AN ADDITIONAL
CERTIFICATION. THAT
CERTIFICATION COSTS ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS. AND
THEN YOU HAVE TO RECERTIFY EVERY
TWO YEARS. AND I BELIEVE THAT'S
ANOTHER ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY.
AND WHILE THAT AMOUNT ON ITS OWN
MIGHT NOT SEEM LIKE A LOT. OF
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES ARE NOT
GETTING PAID AS MUCH AS THEIR-
THEIR COUNTERPARTS IN THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS. AND SO THEY'RE
THEY'RE ASKING. THEY'RE
BASICALLY PUTTING OUT MORE
MONEY- TO WORK. AT IN THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND THAT'S A
CHALLENGE FOR THEM. BEFORE
BEFORE THESE- CERTIFICATION FEES
WERE. AT HIGHER. YOU WOULD HAVE
MORE INDIVIDUALS WHO ACTUALLY
WOULD JUST GET THEIR PUBLIC
HEALTH OUR CERTIFICATION. JUST
IN CASE THEY WERE INTERESTED IN
MAKING A CAREER CHANGE OR JUST
SO THAT THEY HAVE THAT BACK. THE
BACKGROUND AROUND PUBLIC HEALTH.
WE DON'T SEE THAT AS MUCH
ANYMORE AND SO THAT'S A HUGE
ISSUE. I THINK THE OTHER THING
IS ON A FEW OF THE TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT I MENTIONED THAT
MICROBIOLOGISTS. EPIDEMIOLOGISTS
AND- EXCUSE ME LET ME JUST WENT
DOWN A QUICK PUBLIC LAB. THESE
PROGRAMS ARE IN EXISTENCE TODAY
THEY'RE ON A SMALL SCALE AND THE
REASON WHY THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
RAMPED UP IS THAT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HAVE TO PUT UP.
EITHER FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO.
OFFER TRAINING SLAUGHTER
FELLOWSHIP FLAG OR THE
DEPARTMENT HAS HAD A LITTLE
LIMITED BUDGET. AND SO SOME OF
THESE COST BARRIERS THINKING
ABOUT A HEALTH DEPARTMENT WHO
ARE YOU DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
FUNDING. TO BE ABLE TO PUT
DOLLARS TOGETHER. YOU SEE A LOT
OF THAT THE TRAINEES ARE THE
<c.cyan>OLLOWS THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS</c>
LANDING AND IN LARGER
JURISDICTIONS AT TIMES BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
RESOURCES. AND SO IT'S NOT
EQUITABLE AND SO THAT'S WHY WE
WANTED TO HAVE STATE
INVESTMENTS. WERE YOU COULD
TRAIN AND GROW THE COHORTS AT
THE DEPARTMENT. AND TRAIN AND
EXPAND THE AVAILABILITY TO ALL
JURISDICTION. CAN WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT COMMENT ON WHAT-
MICHELLE GIBBONS HAD JUST
COMMENTED ON. YEAH I THINK WE'RE
IN AGREEMENT WITH MICHELLE WE
ARE LOOKING AT THOSE TRAINING
PROGRAMS I'M TRYING TO- EXPAND
THEM AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND WE
WILL BE WORKING WITH THEM WE DID
DO A REVIEW OF THE- COMMITTEE
HEALTH ASSESSMENTS COMMUNITY
HEALTH IMPROVEMENT PLANS AND
STRATEGIC PLANS AS WE TRY TO SET
UP METRICS WILL BE WORKING WITH
G. AXES L. H. O. AND M. C. I. U.
I'M IN THE- IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF MONTHS TO REALLY LOOK AT THE
STATE WIDE METRICS BECAUSE WE DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE. WE'RE
EVALUATING WHAT WE'RE GETTING
FROM THESE DOLLARS AND IN THE
BEGINNING IT WILL BE FOCUSED ON
SOMEONE ON SOME OF THE INITIAL
HIRING AND TRAINING AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS AS WE THEN MOVED
TO PUBLIC HEALTH OUTCOMES- YOU
KNOW MAYBE AND- STDS OR OTHER
AREAS OF FOCUS BUT WILL BE
WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE SOME STATEWIDE. BUT
SOME LOCAL FLEXIBILITY AND WHAT
THEY DETERMINE. IS MOST NEED IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. AT TO KNOW
FOLLOW UP THE L. A. O.'S- WE
SPOKE BRIEFLY ABOUT WORKFORCE
PIPELINE I'D LIKE TO NOW ADDRESS
SPECIFICALLY. THE NEED FOR US TO
STRENGTHEN THE PUBLIC HEALTH LAB
NETWORK AS WELL AS AN
OVERARCHING IT STRATEGY. HOPING
YOU CAN COMMENT ON- BOTH THE
NEED AND PLAN. FOR BOTH OF THOSE
AREAS. SO I'LL START WITH THIS-
STATEWIDE LIVE NETWORK AS YOU
KNOW THAT. CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
HEALTH LABORATORY SERVICES OUR
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
AND LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
SINCE THE FIRST. STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH LABORATORY WAS
ESTABLISHED WAY BACK IN NINETEEN
OH FIVE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS
BEEN PROVIDING AND COORDINATING
LAB SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIA. I'M
GENERALLY OUR LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH LABS PROVIDE SCREENING
CASTING FOR COMMON DISEASES AND
THE C. PAGE LABORATORIES PROVIDE
CONFIRMATORY A REFERENCE TESTING
GUIDANCE AND TRAINING IN THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS THERE HAVE
BEEN INCREASED COSTS AND
STAGNANT PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING.
HAVE REALLY IMPACT THAT
FOUNDATIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICES INCLUDING OUR LABS
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC WE AT
APERTURE UNDER WAY TO MEET WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH LAB LEADERS TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND STAFFING NEEDS
AND TO ASSESS THE NEED FOR.
REVITALIZING ENHANCING THE STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH LAB NETWORK. I'M
WE HAVE. WE WILL BE. THE PUBLIC
HEALTH LABORATORY WORKING GROUP
TO OVERSEE THAT CONTINUED
FORMATION OF THE- OUR LABORATORY
NETWORKS THIS GROUP LIVE MEMBERS
FROM CDPH CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
HEALTH LABORATORY DIRECTORS. CCI
JOE GEAC AND OTHERS THAT CHARGE
TO THE GROUP WORKGROUP WILL BE
TO DEVELOP A CLEAR STRATEGY FOR
INTEGRATING OUR TWENTY EIGHT.
PUBLIC HEALTH LABS- IDENTIFYING
STEPS THAT THE STATE LAB AND
PUBLIC HEALTH LABS CAN TAKE TO
IMPROVE AND COORDINATE
COMMUNICATION STATEWIDE. WILL BE
ESTABLISHING STANDARDS FOR
TESTING AND SERVICES THAT BY THE
STATE IDENTIFIES SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
LABS TO PRIORITIZE IT-
UNIVERSALLY AND LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH. REQUIRING PUBLIC HAVE
HEALTH LABS TO MEET SPECIFIC
GOALS ARE SPEND. AMOUNTS OF AT
SOME PREDETERMINED AMOUNTS OF
FUNDING FOR SPECIFIC PURPOSES I
AM AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
AS A GROUP AND TRY TO COME UP
WITH. THE NEW WAYS TO MAKE OUR
PUBLIC LAB SYSTEM WORK FOR
EVERYONE WE KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN
STAFFING CHALLENGES AND THAT WE-
HAVE SEEN SOME LABS YOU KNOW
BREATHING. I'M NOT BE ABLE TO
GET A LAB DIRECTOR AND THEREFORE
HAVE TO CLOSE AND SO WE REALLY
DO WANT TO- WORK WITH THAT. I'M
AND WE WILL BE CENTRALIZING OUR
OWN STATE LABORATORIES- COME
JULY JULY OF THIS YEAR AND INTO
SEPTEMBER AND WE THINK THAT WE
WILL. ESTABLISH A GROUP THAT CAN
REALLY WORK ON TIS WITH OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AS WE COME
UP WITH A PLAN FOR THE FUTURE
I'M WE ARE. IN THE PROCESS RIGHT
NOW OF SCHEDULING KEY INFORMANT
INTERVIEWS SO THAT WE CAN BRING
THIS WORKER BACK TOGETHER-
HOPEFULLY IN SOMETIME IN JUNE-
WITH A DRAFT OF SOME OF THE
IDEAS THAT PEOPLE HAVE IN TERMS
OF THE- THE PUBLIC HEALTH
LEADERS ACROSS THE STATE. SO WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S WORK TO BE
DONE OUR STATE LABS WE'VE BEEN A
LITTLE BIT DELAYED BY THE
PANDEMIC BUT WE'RE ANXIOUS TO
GET BACK TO WORK AND WORK WITH
OUR NEW. CENTRALIZED CENTER-
THAT WILL BE HELPING TO RE
ENVISION- AND. STRENGTHEN OUR
LABORATORY NETWORK. UP UNTIL TO
PULL MICHELLE WITH. THANK YOU I
WOULD ECHO EVERYTHING THAT THE
FINALE IS SAYING THE ONE PIECE
THAT I WOULD JUST ADD THOUGH IS
THAT. AT BECAUSE OF FUNDING-
INADEQUATE FUNDING AND AS IN THE
FINALE STATED THAT THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE'RE HAVING WITH FINING
LAB DIRECTORS. SEVERAL LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE CLOSED
OVER THE PAST DECADE AND SO ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW YET IS WHAT IS THE
PROPER NUMBER. OF LABS TO HAVE
IN OUR STATE PUBLIC HEALTH LABS
WHO ARE UNIQUE FROM OTHER
LABORATORIES IN OUR IN OUR
STATE. AND SO ONE THING THAT WE
WOULD JUST AFTER THAT IN THESE
WORKING GROUPS AND THESE
DISCUSSIONS THAT THERE REALLY BE
A STUDY A STRONG STUDY OF. WHAT
SHOULD OUR CAPACITY BE IT IS IT
PER POPULATION IS AT HER LIKE
SIZE AND REGION. I KNOW CAREER
SERVICES AND THINGS LIKE THAT
HAVE TO BE INVOLVED AS WELL SO
WE WOULD JUST ASK FOR A DETAILED
STUDY INTO. IS THE ADMIN.
AMENABLE TO A NEEDS ASSESSMENT
TO ANALYZE THE LAB NETWORK FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YES WE
DID YEARS OUR NATIONAL- BUT HELP
LABS THE SYSTEM TO A AND IF YOU
LOOK AT OUR CENTRALIZED LAB OUR
STATE LAB AND THEY DID DO AN
ASSESSMENT MADE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR US AND I THINK WE NEED A
SIMILAR PROCESS. HOW FINAL
QUESTIONS GOING O BE REGARDING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH COR I THINK
IT'S ON PAGE TWENTY EIGHT OF THE
AGENDA YOU STATE THAT YOU WILL
BE ESTABLISHING APPROXIMATELY A
THOUSAND PUBLIC HEALTH
VLUNTEERS WHO ARE TRAINED
CENTRALLY WHERE IS THAT CENTRAL
LOCATION WHERE YOU WILL BE
TRAINING THEM HAVE WE
ESTABLISHED THAT TRAINING
PROGRAM CAN YOU ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT MORE ON THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH COR. THERE WERE SO IT'S
VERY MUCH LIKE OUR COCONUT
PROGRAM IN FACT THE PEOPLE
MANAGING IT ARE THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO MANAGED OUR CAL CONNECT. OUT
WHERE WE TRAINED OVER TEN
THOUSAND CAL- CONTACT TRACERS
AND SO THEY WILL BE CREATING
THAT SYSTEM OF- VOLUNTEERS AND
SOME OF THOSE. THOSE VOLUNTEERS
FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICE
WILL BE I'M- SOMEWHAT I'M STATE
PEOPLE WHO WILL VOLUNTEER TO
SERVE IN THAT CAPACITY WILL BE
ON THEIR STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
THEIR SUPERVISORS WILL. AND WORK
WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE AN IMMEDIATE SIDE OF STATE
PEOPLE WHO CAN- JUMP INTO
RESPONSIBLE. I AM SO WILL BE
PARTNERING WITH OUR ACADEMIC
PARTNERS TO DEVELOP THE
TRAINING. I WILL HOLD MY
QUESTIONS ON OVERARCHING NIGHT
T. STRATEGY UNTIL ISSUE SEVEN-
TWO ISSUES FROM NOW TO DISCUSS
MORE IN DETAIL- WITH THAT I WILL
NOW MOVE US ON TO- ISSUE NUMBER
SIX IF WE CAN- THANK VERY MUCH
THIS PANEL WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER SIX AND WE CAN
START AT THE TOP. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M GONNA MAKE SOME OPENING
COMMENTS THE DOCTOR OUT OF ON
AGAIN. AND THEN I'M GONNA HAVE A
BRANDON NATIVE IT'S GO FOR THE
BUDGET. BOB GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN- DOCTOR ARAMBULA MEMBERS.
TWO YEARS AGO- TWO YEARS AGO
ALMOST TO THIS DAY CALIFORNIA
WAS THE FIRST DAY TO ISSUE A
STAY AT HOME ORDER IN THE UNITED
STATES. CALIFORNIA WAS ABLE TO
FLATTEN THE CURVE TO SAVE LIVES
WHILE BUYING TIME FOR VACCINE
DEVELOPMENT. LEARNING ABOUT THE
BIOLOGY OF THE NEW CORONAVIRUS
AND ITS TRANSMISSION. AND ALSO
THE TIME TO DEVELOP AND
DISTRIBUTE EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS
. IN CALIFORNIA WE FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE AND TODAY CALIFORNIA
EIGHTY THREE POINT 6% OF PERSONS
FIVE YEARS OR OLDER HAVE
RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE DOSE OF A
VACCINE SEVENTY FOUR POINT 3% OF
PERSONS FIVE YEARS OR OLDER ARE
FULLY VACCINATED. AND SEVENTY
THREE POINT 1% OF PERSON SIXTY
FIVE YEARS AND OLDER ARE
BOOSTED. AMONG THE SIX MOST
POPULOUS STATES CALIFORNIA HAS
THE LOWEST CUMULATIVE DEATH RATE
. WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS FARED
BETTER THAN THE STATE'S MANY
CALIFORNIA HAVE SUFFERED LOSS IN
SOME COMMUNITIES WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED. AS
OF TODAY WE HAVE OVER EIGHTY
SEVEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS HAVE
DIED FROM KOBE. IN TWENTY TWENTY
ACCESS THAT'S FOR ALL FROM ALL
CAUSES INCREASED BY 15% IN
CALIFORNIA'S BEYOND COVERT DEATH
. ID TWENTY TWENTY UP BUT THE
REAL LIFE EXPECTANCY DECREASED
BY THREE POINT SIX YEARS. I WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT THIS WITH
ANALYSIS THAT OF TWENTY TWENTY
DATA AND WHEN WE COULD THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DATA WE EXPECT
THESE NUMBERS TO BE EVEN HIGHER
GIVEN THAT THOUGHT THAT'S WHEN
WE HAD A BIG PUT YOUR SEARCH.
ALTHOUGH WE ARE RECOVERING FROM
THE WINTER WAVE OF THE
OVERCROWDING VARIANTS BE A POINT
ONE. WE NOW FACE A THREAT FROM
THE OMICRON VARIANT BA TO THAT
SPREADING INTO OTHER PARTS OF
THE WORLD. OTHER COUNTRIES ARE
FACING YOU SEARCHES OF COVERED
CASES AND DEATHS. MORE
TRANSMISSION AROUND THE WORLD
MEANS NEW VARIANTS WILL EMERGE.
LIKELY MORE CONTAGIOUS AND
POSSIBLY CAUSING MORE SEVERE
DISEASE. THE GOVERNOR'S SMARTER
PLAN ISABOUT BEING SMARTER
TAKING OUR LESSONS LEARNED AND
BALANCING BOTH READING THIS
RECOVERY. THE COVERED BUDGET
WILL CONTRIBUTE WILL CONTRIBUTE
TO OUR READINESS TO TACKLE
FUTURE KOBE THREATS. I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO BRANDON NUNEZ CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS AT
CDPH WILL REVIEW THE BUDGET
BRANDON. THANK YOU DOCTOR ARE
GONE- GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
BRANDON UNISON THE CHIEF DEPUTY
FOR OPERATIONS HERE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH- AS
YOU KNOWN AS YOU MAY REMEMBER
BACK IN EARLY FEBRUARY WE HAD A-
HEARING ON THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE. THAT WAS PASSED LAST
MONTH- WHICH INCLUDED ONE POINT
SIX BILLION FOR ONGOING COVERT
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES- AND THAT
EARLY ACTION SUPPORTED RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES THROUGH THIS CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR SO GEN. SO FOR THE
ISSUE AND FOR ANY TODAY- WHAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING OF THOSE SME
TYPES OF COVERED RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES BUT FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR SPECIFICALLY THROUGH
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO- AND
THAT'S PART OF WHAT IS DRIVING-
THAT EXTENSION THROUGH THIS
FIRST HALF OF THE BUDGET YEAR
COMING UP. IS WHAT'S DRIVING
THAT ADDITIONAL SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ONE MILLION THAT'S
BEFORE YOU ON THE AGENDA ON
PAGES THIRTY FOUR AND THIRTY
FIVE DOES A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
LAYING THIS OUT IT'S ALL JUST
KIND OF GET SOME OF THE HIGH
POINTS- OF EACH OF THESE
DIFFERENT COST CATEGORIES. AND
THEN WE HAVE SOME OF OUR TEAM
HERE FROM THE VARIOUS THE
TESTING PASSPORTS VACCINE IT'S
BETTER- IF THERE'S ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY. ON OF
THESE APPROACH- BUT SPECIFICALLY
IN THE AREA OF VACCINATIONS-
THERE'S A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO
MILLION BEING REQUESTED. AND
THIS IS GOING TO SUPPORT OUR
VARIOUS VACCINE BOOSTER OUTREACH
EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE CAMPAIGNS. IT
PROVIDES SOME OF THE ENDS AND
ADMINISTRATION AND MANAGEMENT
SERVICES FOR VACCINES SITES ARE
STRIKE TEAMS. AND THAT SUPPORTS
SOME OF OUR VACCINE MOBILE
UNITS- THAT GO ACROSS COUNTIES
AND LOCAL ALL JURISDICTIONS TO
RIDE UP A CLINIC SERVICES- IN
THE AREA TESTING THERE'S A
REQUEST OF. APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO MILLION.
AND THIS IS GONNA GO TO PROVIDE
SPECIMEN COLLECTION SERVICES- TO
PARIS MODALITIES SUCH AS DRIVE
THROUGH MOBILE AT HOME- AS WELL
AS SOME SITE EXPANSION FOR
EXISTING COLLECTION SITES SUCH
AS EXPANDING LANE OURS ARE
SORRY- INCREASING LANES. HOURS
DAYS OF SERVICES OFFERED- AND
THEN OF COURSE PART OF THIS-
BUDGET GOES TO PROVIDING
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING SERVICES AS
WELL- IN THE AREA OF CONTACT
TRACING THERE'S EIGHTEEN MILLION
BEING REQUESTED- MUCH OF THIS
FUNDING IS GOING TO ESTABLISH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH RESERVE CORPS
THE YOU JUST TOUCHED ON- IN THE
AREA- MEDICAL SURGE STAFFING
THERE'S A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION BEING
REQUESTED. AND THAT GOES TO
SUPPORT REGISTERED NURSES NURSE
ASSISTANTS CLINICAL TAX- AND
OTHER HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONAL
IN BOTH THE AREAS OF MEDICAL
SEARCH NEEDS AND HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES. AS WELL AS TO HELP
ON TO IT IT MINISTERING
VACCINATIONS. AND THEN FINALLY I
HIGHLIGHT THAT AS PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL THERE'S ARMS. FOR
MILLION DOLLAR FOR BORDERS
SEVENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
BORDER ACTIVITIES- AND THIS IS
OUR BORDER ACTIVITIES IT'S
CURRENTLY BEING DONE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH FEDERAL LOCAL
AND NONPROFIT PARTNERS- THAT
THOSE ACTIVITIES ARE BEING DONE-
DOWN ON THE BORDER AND IMPERIAL
SAN DIEGO AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTIES- INCLUDE SERVICES JUST. TESTING TEMPORARY SHELTER
VACCINES- AND CORNISH FOR ONWARD
- STALL ALL HOLD IT THERE AGAIN
YOUR GENDER IS A REALLY GOOD JOB
OF LAYING THESE OUT AND ALL STOP
FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
. THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT FROM SONYA
PADDOCK- WITH LA- SO I WILL
BRING IT UP TO THE DENTIST TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE AND HAVING DISCUSSED
THIS DURING OUR INITIAL HEARING
WANTED TO THANK VERY MUCH THIS
PANEL WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
PANEL FOR. AND ISSUE SEVEN-
WHICH IS THE DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE READINESS- RESPONSE
RECOVERY AND MAINTENANCE OF IT
OPERATIONS B. C. P. WE WILL HAVE
THREE PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
FROM CDPH AND ELLIE- LET US
BEGIN WITH DOCTOR JAMES BOND WHO
IS THE ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. FOR THE CENTER FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASES AT CDPH. CAN
YOU BEGIN MITCHELL GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR ARAMBULA
MEMBERS- I WILL BEGIN WITH SOME
BRIEF CONTEXT AND THEN JOHN
PURCELL THE CHIEF OF OUR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT
DIVISION WILL DESCRIBE THE
PROPOSAL. PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
CDPH HAD INFECTIOUS DISEASE
INFORMATION SYSTEMS THAT WERE
SUFFICIENT FOR ROUTINE
ACTIVITIES. BUT WE'RE LIMITED IN
FUNCTIONALITY DUE TO LIMITED
RESOURCES AND THE SYSTEMS WERE
NOT SUFFICIENT FOR THE PANDEMIC
RESPONSE. THE DISEASE REPORTING
SYSTEM WAS QUICKLY OVERWHELMED
BY THE VOLUME OF DATA BEING
REPORTED ON ALL POSITIVE AND
NEGATIVE COVERED NINETEEN TESTS.
WE WENT FROM AN AVERAGE OF FEWER
THAN TEN THOUSAND INCOMING
MESSAGES PER DAY TO MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND BY JULY OF
TWENTY TWENTY. AND IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE WERE
RECEIVING UP TO SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND PER DAY. IN RESPONSE WE
SET UP A NEW SYSTEM FOR
RECEIVING LABORATORY DATA. AND
IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF MEASURES
TO BE ABLE TO RECEIVE ANALYZE
AND REPORT LARGE VOLUMES OF DATA
QUICKLY AND CONSISTENTLY. WE DID
NOT HAVE FLEXIBLE TOOLS TO
SUPPORT CASE INVESTIGATION AND
CONTACT TRACING PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. SO WE SET UP A NEW
STATEWIDE SYSTEM TO SUPPORT
THESE ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS TO
MOVE DATA BETWEEN SYSTEMS. WE
COULD NOT SEND AUTOMATED
COMMUNICATIONS TO PERSONS
INFECTED WITH ARE EXPOSED TO
COVER NINETEEN PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. BUT WE HAVE NOW
DEVELOPED THESE TOOLS AND
SENDING AUTOMATED MESSAGES HAS
BEEN VERY IMPORTANT PARTICULARLY
IN TIMES WHEN CASE COUNTS HAVE
BEEN VERY HIGH. WE ALSO NEEDED
NEW TOOLS TO SUPPORT COULD
NINETEEN VACCINATION EFFORTS
THAT WERE NOT NEEDED BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED A
TOOL FOR PEOPLE TO DETERMINE
THEIR VACCINE ELIGIBILITY FIND A
VACCINATION SITE AND SCHEDULE AN
APPOINTMENT. NEW TOOL FOR TO
SUPPORT ORDERING AND INVENTORY
MANAGEMENT BY VACCINE PROVIDERS
. NEW TOOLS TO SUPPORT VACCINE
ALLOCATIONS IN ORDER MANAGEMENT
FOR LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
AND THE SYSTEM FOR THE PUBLIC TO
OBTAIN VACCINE VERIFICATION. AND
FINALLY WE ENHANCE THE
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY TO MANAGE
GREATLY INCREASED DATA VOLUME
AND COMMUNICATE WITH HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS. IN THE PANDEMIC THE
NUMBER OF DOSES REPORTED DAILY
TO THE IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY HAS
DOUBLED AND THE NUMBER OF
QUERIES TO THE SYSTEM FOR
VACCINE RECORDS HAS INCREASED
FIVE FOLD. CHAU STOP THERE AND
HANDED OVER TO JOHN RISA. THANK
YOU DOCTOR WHAT. I'M JOHN
RUSSELL I AM THE ACTING DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES DIVISION BUT
CALIFORNIA PARTNER PUBLIC HEALTH
. IT ALWAYS SPEAKING ON THE I.
T. PORTION. CHECK YOUR PH AS
LEVERAGE FEDERAL AND STATE
FUNDING TO INVEST IN HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AND DATA
SYSTEMS CREATED AND MODIFIED
DURING THE PANDEMIC. WE ADOPTED
OUR CURRENT TECHNOLOGY TO WORK
WITH NEW MODERN ARCHITECTURES
THAT PROVIDE SHE COMPONENTS OF
THE HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
NECESSARY TO RESPOND TO THE KOBE
NINETEEN. AND THE URGENT NEED
FOR ENHANCED DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS SUCH AS-
HOW CONNECT MY FEEDBACKS MY
CHURCH. DIGITAL COBIT ACTING
RECORD IN VIRTUAL ASSISTANT. IS
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE ALSO
ESSENTIAL FOR CD PH AND THE
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
TRIFECTA THE TRACK AND GATHER
DATA ON KOBE NINETEEN TEN OTHER
INFECTIOUS DISEASES. PERFORMING
CONTACT TRACING TO MINIMIZE
DISEASE SPREAD OFFICIALLY
ADMINISTER LIFE SAVING VACCINES
RAPIDLY PERFORMER COBIT NINETEEN
TESTS AND DEPLOY PERSONNEL IN
ALL AREAS OF PANDEMIC RESPONSE.
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SERVICE
DIVISION IN THE CENTER FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASES IS
REQUESTING A HUNDRED THIRTY
POSITIONS FORTY FIVE FOR
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE FOR
PROGRAM AND HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
POINT TWO MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. A
TOTAL OF A HUNDRED FORTY
POSITIONS AND HUNDRED FIFTY SIX
POINT ONE MILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. AND A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED FORTY POSITIONS IN. AND
SIXTY ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION.
IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. IN ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
FROM THE GENERAL FUND. THIS
PROJECT IS A FUNDING REQUESTED
ARE NEEDED TO MAINTAIN AND
OPERATE THE CRITICAL TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SYSTEMS.
PORTCHESTER PROGRAMMATIC
SERVICES STATEWIDE PREPARE FOR
AND RESPOND TO FUTURE
EMERGENCIES ON LARGE SCALE
DISASTERS AND BUILD CDPH
OPERATIONAL AND TECHNOLOGY
RESULTS. THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE
L. A. O. THANK YOU SO NAY
PARTICULARLY- AS WE NOTED
EARLIER WE REALLY THINK- CDPH
NEEDS AN OVERARCHING I. T.
STRATEGY FOR ALL PUBLIC HEALTH
PROGRAMS. AND THE DEPARTMENT DID
INDICATE TO OUR OFFICE THAT IT
WILL BE DEVELOPING A STRATEGY
UNDER HE LEADERSHIP OF A NEW
CHIEF IT STRATEGIST. I'M THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO NOTED TO OUR
OFFICE THAT IT'S IN THE PROCESS
OF CONDUCTING A HOLISTIC
ASSESSMENT OF THE D. DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY
ECOSYSTEM SPECIFICALLY- WHICH
WHICH IS GOOD- BUT IN THE
MEANTIME WE RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
EXISTING SYSTEMS- IN THE
PROPOSAL ARE CRITICAL FOR BOTH
COVERED NINETEEN RESPONSE AND
INFECTIOUS DISEASE SURVEILLANCE
OVERALL WE THINK IT DOES SEEM
REASONABLE TO BRING SOME OF THE
MANAGEMENT OPERATIONS OF THESE
SYSTEMS IN HOUSE SO THAT CDPH
HAS GREATER VISIBILITY INTO EACH
SYSTEM AND THE ABILITY TO MAKE
CHANGES AS NEEDED SO WE ARE NOT
RAISING ANY. ISSUES WITH THAT
THIS PARTICULAR REQUEST. THANK
YOU AYE- AND THAT CONCLUDES THIS
PANEL OF BRING IT UP TO THE
DIETS FOR ANY MEMBER QUESTIONS I
WILL KEEP IT HERE AT THE CHAIR-
MY FIRST QUESTION IS FOR CDPH-
WE HEARD ABOUT THE NEED FOR THE
OVER ARCHING IT STRATEGY AND-
THE DIRECTION THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING IS TO
HIRE A CHIEF. HI T. STRATEGIST.
BUT I'D LIKE TO GET A SENSE OF I
CAN- DOES THE DEPARTMENT PLAN
WITH THE STRATEGIST-
CENTRALIZING COORDINATE MANY OF
THE I. T. SYSTEMS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE SO THAT THEY WORK
TOGETHER AS A CENTRALIZED
SYSTEM. IS THAT THE OVER ARCHING
GOAL THAT WILL COME WITH THE
HIRING OF THIS CHIEF IT
STRATEGIST. SO THIS JOB OR SELL
AGAIN- THE GOAL IS THAT THE I.
T. STRATEGIST REALLY TO ASSESS
OUR OUR CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE
IN DETERMINE WHAT ARCHITECTURES.
AND TECHNOLOGIES CAN FIT
TOGETHER AND BE CONSOLIDATED TO
BEST MEET THE NEEDS ARE FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH. INITIATIVES AND
FORMULATE A CLEAR DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION STRATEGY ROAD MAP
TO GOVERNOR PRIORITIZE IN A LINE
CRITICAL PLANNING ACTIVITIES
INITIATIVES AND PROJECTS FOR THE
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
INITIATIVES. I'D BRING IT UP
BECAUSE THE BEST TIME TO PLAN
FOR EMERGENCIES WHEN YOU'RE NOT
IN ONE. AND IF WE HAVE A CHANCE
TO ACTUALLY IMPROVE OUR I. T.
SYSTEMS FOR THE NEXT ONE. I
THINK IT'S IMPERATIVE FOR US TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S FULLY
FUNCTIONING. AND I AND I GUESS
WHAT I'M TRYING TO. I STILL
THINK BACK TOWARDS CAL READY AND
SOME OF THE DIFFICULTIES MANY OF
US HAD INTERNED IN INTERFACING
WITH THAT PROGRAM REPORTING
INFORMATION- TO THE STATEWIDE
SYSTEM THAT- THAT I WOULD LIKE.
TO BE ABLE TO HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT WHAT THAT OVERARCHING
STRATEGY IS- FIRST OFF THIS NEXT
QUESTION I HAVE WILL BE FOR THE
L. A. O. AND IT'S TO- SEE IF YOU
CAN HELP ME TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER OR NOT THESE OF GONE
THROUGH THE POWER PROCESS- AND
WHETHER OR NOT. ARE THESE
PROJECTS. SHOULD BE GOING
THROUGH THE POWER PROCESS OR
SHOULDN'T SAY WHAT'S YOUR
UNDERSTANDING. OUR UNDERSTANDING
AND MR CELL CAN CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG- IS THAT A NUMBER OF
THESE ARE SORT OF EXISTING
SYSTEMS THAT NEED SOME KIND OF A
GRADE OR THEY'RE BRINGING MAYBE
SOME EXTERNAL FONG- MANAGEMENT
IN HOUSE. AND THEN SOME OF THE
OTHER PROJECTS THAT ARE NEW OR
ARE GOING THROUGH- THE HELP
PROCESS AND I DON'T. HAVE MY
NOTES WITH ME ON HAND TO
IDENTIFY A WHICH WHICH OF THOSE-
ARE GOING THROUGH THE POWER
PROCESS BUT- OUR OFFICES-
GENERALLY IN AGREEMENT THAT
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY A **** A GOOD
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION AND- AND GOOD
FOR A. T. PROJECTS SO. I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
AS THE LEGISLATURE WORKED HARD
TO ESTABLISH THAT PROCESS TO
OVERSEE THE IT PROJECTS. TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAD
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH PUBLIC
DOLLARS- THAT THAT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SEND AS MANY OF
THESE ID PROJECTS AS- AS ARE
NEEDED THROUGH THE APPROPRIATE
PROCESS SO WE HAVE THAT
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION- BUT WOULD
LOVE TO- HAVE YOU COMMENT- IN
RESPONSE TO. WHAT MISS PEDICABS
JUST SAID. YES WE AGREE WITH
MISS PADDICK AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE- LET YOU MENTION ABOUT TO
SYSTEMS THAT WE STOOD UP TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF COBIT IN RESPONSE.
THOSE SYSTEMS CURRENTLY IN HOUSE
WE'RE OPTIMIZING AND
RATIONALIZING THOSE TO BE MORE
EFFICIENT MORE EFFECTIVE AND BE
MORE RESPONSIVE THERE ARE ALSO
ADDITIONAL- EFFORTS GOING ON TO
UPGRADE OR- BUILT NEW SYSTEMS
AND THOSE WILL GO THROUGH THE
POWER PROCESS AS IDENTIFIED- I
THINK ONE OF THE- EXAMPLES OF
THAT IS C. C. R. S. THAT IS
PROBABLY. ONE OF THE BEST
EXAMPLES THAT I CAN GET RIGHT
NOW- BUT OTHERS ARE IDENTIFIED
WE WILL DEFINITELY GO THROUGH
THE POWER PROCESS AND MAKE SURE
THAT- WE ARE- REPORTING AND A
FULL. ALL THE REGULATIONS EVER
CONTROL AGENCIES. WITHOUT A WILL
THANK VERY MUCH PANEL FOR WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO A PANEL FIVE
WHICH WILL BE PRESENTING ON
THREE CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED
PROPOSALS UNDER THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY WE WILL HAVE THREE
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
INCLUDING DR ROSHAN
RADHAKRISHNA. DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY AS
WELL AS LINDA HELEN'S CLIMATE
CHANGE AND HEALTH EQUITY SECTION
CHIEF WITH CD PH AND SONYA
PADDOCK WITH THE L. L. WE WILL
PAUSE AFTER EACH PROPOSAL IS
PRESENTED SO THAT WE MAY ASK
QUESTIONS CAN WE PLEASE BEGIN
WITH DOCTOR RADHAKRISHNA ON
ISSUE EIGHT. THANK YOU CHAIR
ARAMBULA MEMBERS JOINING TODAY
THAT'S MY HONOR TO BE
REPRESENTING THE DEPARTMENT ON
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS. AND ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELFTH TWENTY REGARDING
THE CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL ON HOMELESSNESS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE TWENTY IT
IS REQUIRED TO HAVE THE
PARTICIPATION AND LEADERSHIP
FROM OVER TWENTY UNIQUE STATE
AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS AND OTHER
BODIES OF GOVERNMENT ON THE NEW
PAL INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS WHICH INCLUDES FOR
THE FIRST TIME CAL HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SECRETARY DR
GALLEY AS THE NEW CO CHAIR. END
CDPH DIRECTOR DIRECTOR ADAM GONE
AS A NEW MEMBER. THIS PROPOSAL
REQUESTS TO POSITIONS AND THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM GENERAL FUND AN
ONGOING TO PROVIDE CDPH PROGRAM
COORDINATION. DATA ANALYTICS AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO MAXIMIZE
THE POPULATION HEALTH BENEFITS
AND THE HEALTHCARE COSTS SAVINGS
BY ENDING HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH FOUR MAIN GOALS
FOR OUR PROPOSED INVOLVEMENT.
FIRST TO SUPPORT MORE
COORDINATION OF INTERAGENCY
WORKGROUPS AND TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND EQUITY ACOSTA STINTS
AND POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE COUNCIL OVERALL. SECOND TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC HEALTH DATA AND
ANALYTICAL SUPPORT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL AND STATE
GRANTEES WHO ARE PARTICIPANTS IN
THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT'S
CONTINUUM OF CARE PROGRAM. THIRD
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
ON PUBLIC HEALTH INTERVENTIONS
TO STATE STRATEGIES TO MAXIMIZE
THOSE POPULATION HEALTH BENEFITS
AND HEALTH CARE COST SAVINGS.
AND FOURTH TO PROVIDE POLICY AND
PROGRAMMATIC RECOMMENDATIONS ON
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION TO THE
DIRECTOR AND SECRETARY FROM THE
FIRST MEETING IN JANUARY I THANK
YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA AS AN
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN IN ME AS A
FAMILY PHYSICIAN CAN AGREE I'LL
SHARE A QUOTE FROM THAT FIRST
COUNCIL MEETING IN JANUARY WHICH
IS THAT THERE IS NO MEDICINE. AS
POWERFUL AS HOUSING HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM LINDA
HOLLAND. YES THE CLARIFIED MISS
HELEN WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR MORE
DETAILS ON ISSUE NUMBER NINE
INTENT BUT NOT FOR ISSUE GREAT
GREAT NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
SONYA PADDOCK WITH YELLOW. THANK
YOU A DOCTOR IN THE LAB- SUNAPEE
KALLIO WE'VE REVIEWED THIS
PROPOSAL AND DON'T RAISE ANY
CONCERNS. I WILL NOW BRING IT UP
TO THE DÍAS TO SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS I WILL
KEEP IT HERE WITH THE CHAIR- I'M
GONNA BEGIN- FIRST- DR
RADHAKRISHNAN. I WAS REALLY
IMPRESSED WE RUN A PANEL A FEW
WEEKS AGO AND YOU HAD. SHARED A
QUOTE FROM ONE OF YOUR MENTORS.
ABOUT HOW THE ORIGIN OF SO MANY
OF OUR PROBLEMS IN LIFE IS
SEEING OTHERS AS LESS THAN.
YOURSELF AND I BELIEVE SO OFTEN
WITH HOMELESSNESS WE DON'T
RECOGNIZE THAT THOSE WHO ARE ON
THE STREETS ARE MEMBERS OF OUR
FAMILIES AND MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HEY. GO TO R. TWELVE
THOUSAND GO TO SCHOOLS WITH US
THAT I AT THE START OF THIS
CONVERSATION WANTED TO HUMANIZE
AND NORMALIZE. AND MAKE SURE
WE'RE RECOGNIZING THAT THOSE ON
THE STREETS ARE ABSOLUTELY ARE
EQUALS AND DESERVE OUR FULL
ATTENTION. NOW I'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO DIG IN A LITTLE BIT AND
I'M GONNA PUSH A LITTLE HERE I
APOLOGIZE. BUT FOR US TO
IMPLEMENT EFFECTIVELY AB TWELVE
TWENTY WERE COMBINING TWENTY
DIFFERENT UNIQUE STATE AGENCIES
AND YET I COULDN'T HELP BUT
NOTICE. THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
JUST TWO POSITIONS I WAS HOPING
YOU COULD EXPLAIN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S THINKING IN
THIS REGARD AS IT SEEMS A LITTLE
AN ADEQUATE FOR US TO ADDRESS
THE CRISIS THAT'S BEFORE US. AND
THE MULTITUDE OF ASPIRATIONS
FROM WITHIN THIS BILL. THAT ARE
ON PAGE FORTY OF THIS AGENDA I
WAS JUST HOPING TO HAVE YOU
COMMENT ON THAT IF POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU CHAIR FOR THAT
QUESTION- THIS IS A START THERE
ARE EXISTING HOUSING PROGRAMS
SERVICES STAFF ACROSS THE
SEVENTEEN DEPARTMENTS AND
OFFICES WITHIN AGENCY- AND WHILE
THE AGENCY HAS HAD
REPRESENTATION ON THE COUNCIL
BEFORE IT IS NEVER HAD THE
SECRETARY BEING CO CHAIR SO
THAT. IS NEW AND DESERVE SOME
ADDITIONAL BAND WITH. SECONDS WE
FOR THE FIRST TIME HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
JOINING THIS NEW COUNCIL IN ITS
NEW VERSION TWO POINT OH THAT
WAS LAUNCHED IN JANUARY. AND
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS MANY ASSETS-
DIRECTOR ARE GOING SPEAKS ABOUT
THE FOUR PILLARS THE ECO SOCIAL
APPROACH. CENTRING EQUITY
CENSURING PRIMARY PREVENTION-
AND FOCUSING ON ON THE ANTI
RACISM. AND I THINK THAT HAVING
AT LEAST TWO DEDICATED STAFF TO
BEGIN- HELPS US LEVERAGE OUR
DATA SKILLS AND OUR PREVENTION
AREA OF SPECIALTY. SO WHILE THE
OTHER- SECRETARY- LOTUS KATHRADA
NEAR AS HAS STOPPED SUPPORTING
THE COUNCIL AND CERTAINLY OUR
AGENCY DOES AS WELL. WE HAVE ON
A NEW ASSISTANT SECRETARY-
SUPPORTING COMING YOU CAN AND-
AS A DEPUTY SECRETARY AND MANY
OTHERS WHEN IN PUBLIC HEALTH
THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST TME
THAT WE ARE REALLY. MEANING
DEDICATED FULL TIME STAFF TO NOT
JUST FOCUS ON COATED AND
HOMELESSNESS. OR A DIFFERENT
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTION
LIKE SYPHILIS SAY AND THE RISKS
OF HOMELESSNESS BUT REALLY TO
BRING OUR DATA AND POLICY
EXPERTISE SO WE'VE OUTLINED IN
THE JOB DESCRIPTION VERY
SPECIFIC ROLES. FOR THOSE TO
STAFF- AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
JOINING THE BROADER STAFFING
COMMUNITY WITH AN AGENCY TO
SUPPORT I'M MORE EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTION FOCUSED.
ORIENTATION. FOR OUR
PARTICIPATION ON THIS COUNCIL. I
LOOK FOR TO THE RESULTS OF
THESE- DATA SKILLS SPECIALIST-
IT WILL BUT WILL PUT FORWARD
SINCE ASSEMBLY MEMBER REVERSES
FROM OUR HOUSE THE M. PORTENTS
FOR MANY OF US OF MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE STANDING UP THIS BILL
AND THEN APPROPRIATELY
RESOURCING AT THAT I WOULD LOVE
FOR US TO ENGAGE IN WHETHER OR
NOT THIS IS SUFFICIENT FOR US TO
ADDRESS. THE DATA NEEDS FOR THIS
COUNCIL AS WE GO THROUGH THESE
NEXT FEW WEEKS BUT WITH THAT I
WILL THANKS VERY MUCH- THIS
PANEL WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ISSUE SEVEN. CAN WE PLEASE
BEGAN- DR RADHAKRISHNAN OR LINDA
HOLLAND. YES AND FOR
CLARIFICATION- ISSUE NINE- IS
NEXT AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR YOUR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS ON ON THE PRIOR ISSUE
WE WELCOME ANY ONGOING
ENGAGEMENT- AND ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT THE ACTION PLAN. WILL
BE UPDATED AND SO WILL CERTAINLY
BE CONTRIBUTING TO THAT FROM A
DATA PERSPECTIVE AS WELL SO FOR
ISSUE NINE WHICH FOCUSES ON
CLIMATE AND HEALTH SURVEILLANCE
I'LL BEGIN BY SHARING THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS CONSIDERED AS
THE GREATEST GLOBAL PUBLIC
HEALTH THREAT OF THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY AND IS IMPACTING
THE HEALTH OF CALIFORNIANS
ALREADY TODAY. WE SEE THAT FROM
INJURY AND ILLNESS TO DEATH FROM
WILDFIRES WILDFIRE SMOKE EXTREME
HEAT DROUGHT EXTREME WEATHER
EVENTS VECTOR BORNE DISEASES AND
MENTAL HEALTH IMPACTS AS WELL WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THESE HARMS ARE
IMPOSED DISPROPORTIONATELY ON
LOW INCOME AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR IN CALIFORNIA. THE PUBLIC
HEALTH REQUEST THIRTY POSITIONS
AND GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. IN ORDER FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE NEAR REAL TIME
NOTIFICATION FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS FIRST RESPONDERS AND
THE COMMUNITY FOR A MERGING OR
INTENSIFIED CLIMATE SENSITIVE
DISEASES. AND I'LL BRIEFLY
MENTION IT'S MORE THAN THE
COMMON ONES WE THINK OF LIKE
SHEETS ARE WILD FIRE IT ALSO
INCLUDES WATER MORE CONDITIONS
FOOD WARM CONDITIONS LIKE
SALMONELLA E. COLI- IN THE BRIO
DOES PORN VALLEY FEVER- AS WELL
AS MENTAL HEALTH IMPACTS WHICH
IS AN EMERGING AREA OF RESEARCH.
THIS BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL IS
PART OF A LARGER EFFORT WITHIN
OUR DEPARTMENT TO ESTABLISH
SYSTEMS FOR EARLY DETECTION OF.
HEALTH CONDITIONS IN GENERAL AND
THIS. OP B. C. P. FOCUSES ON
SPECIFICALLY DETECTING CLIMATE
CHANGE RELATED CONDITIONS
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD ENTAIL
COLLABORATION WITH THE CENTER
FOR HEALTH STATISTICS AND
INFORMATICS TO ASSURE THAT
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS ARE
CONNECTED. TO THAT BROADER
CENTER. OUR STATE IS A ONE OF
THE FEW STATES IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT LACKS A STATEWIDE
SYNDROMIC SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM.
AND AS A RESULT WE ARE NOT ABLE
TO PROVIDE EXTREMELY COUNTED MRS
DURING HEAT WAVES FOR EXAMPLE.
I'M DEVELOPING THIS TYPE OF
METHOD WOULD ALLOW US TO GET
BETTER AT BEING ABLE TO. BOB
EARLY IDENTIFICATION FOR EVENTS
MONITOR TRENDS TRACKED ILLNESSES
AND REPORT TO OFFICIALS AS WELL
AS THE PUBLIC. THE FEDERAL
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
ADMINISTERS A PROGRAM CALLED BIO
SENSE ALSO KNOWN AS THE NATIONAL
SYNDROMIC SURVEILLANCE PROGRAM.
AND THIS IS A PROGRAM TO COLLECT
ANALYZE AND SHARE ELECTRONIC
PATIENT ENCOUNTER DATA RECEIVED
THROUGH URGENCY DEPARTMENTS.
CURRENTLY WE DO NOT ACTIVELY
FACILITATE THE SUBMISSION OF THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS
BUT THIS PROPOSAL AIMS TO
INITIATE THAT CHANGE. IF THIS IS
IMPLEMENTED SUCCESSFULLY EVEN
EVERY CHIEF COMPLAINT DISCHARGE
DIAGNOSIS FROM AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT WOULD ENSURE THE
AND FUNDS WOULD BE USED TO HELP
SUPPORT THESE FACILITIES TO
START PROVIDING. THIS TYPE OF
CRIME THAT SURVEILLANCE DATA
THROUGH THAT PORTAL.
ADDITIONALLY DATA COMING FROM
THIS PLATFORM CAN BE ANALYZED
TRANSFORMED AND DISPLAYED AND
MORE USER FRIENDLY WAYS- WE
WOULD CONDUCT MODELING TO BE
ABLE TO BETTER QUANTIFY THE
POTENTIAL REDUCTIONS OF HARMS
ANY FOR PREVENTION. AND FUNDING
WOULD ALSO HELP SUPPORT THE FEES
FOR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS PAY
FOR SOME OF THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED- FINALLY WE WOULD
HAVE SOME STAFF AND BETTER THAN
OTHER CENTERS ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT TO ALLOW FOR
SURVEILLANCE OF OTHER CLIMATE
RELATED INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
SMOKE HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS AND
OCCUPATIONAL EXPOSURES AS WELL
WE WOULD ALSO ENGAGE A
COMMUNICATIONS SPECIALIST TO
IMPROVE OUR ABILITY TO SHARE
THIS WITH THE PUBLIC AND BROAD.
POLICYMAKERS AND STAKEHOLDERS.
NEXT I BELIEVE WE WILL HAVE
LINDA HILL AND FOLLOWED BY SOME
NEW PRODUCT. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
CREDIBLE- AND- COMMITTEE I AM
MAY I HAVE CARE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT MAY COME UP BUT I
DEFERRED TO DOCTOR ABOUT THE
CHRISTIAN FOR THE PRESENTATION.
SOUNDS GREAT NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE .
L. THANK YOU SO PECK L. A. O. WE
BELIEVE THIS PROPOSAL REALLY
DOES ADDRESS A CURRENT GAP IN
THE STATE'S RESPONSE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE RELATED HEALTH EVENTS AND
HAS A NUMBER OF MERITS- AS-
WE'RE ALL AWARE OF THE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW PARTICULARLY AS
THE NUMBER AND SEVERITY OF
CLIMATE RELATED EVENTS. INCREASE
SO THIS PROPOSAL WOULD HELP THE
STATE- PROVIDE REAL TIME
ANALYTICS AS DR RADHA KRISHNA-
DETAILED ALLOWS FOR THE EARLY
DETECTION OF OUTBREAKS IT WILL
ALSO INCREASE THE AND ARE THE
STATE'S UNDERSTANDING OF THE
MAGNITUDE AND POTENTIAL FUTURE
MAGNITUDE OF VARIOUS HEALTH
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE RELATED
EVENTS AND HOW THESE IMPACTS
AFFECT DIFFERENT GROUPS- AS WELL
AS DIFFERENT REGIONS. AND THE
VARIOUS DATA COLLECTED COULD
FACILITATE ANALYSIS AND
EVALUATION OF THE POTENTIAL
EFFECTIVENESS OF VARIOUS
INTERVENTIONS TAKEN TO REDUCE
THE HEALTH IMPACTS. I'M ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT APARTMENT ALSO-
NOTED TO OUR OFFICE IS THAT
PARTICIPATION IN THE BIO SINCE
PLATFORM- ENABLES CALIFORNIA TO
PARTICIPATE IN A COMMUNITY OF
PRACTICE WITH OTHER STATES AND
ALSO ENGAGE LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS IN THE STATE
LEVEL- COMMUNITY OF PRACTICE.
AND AS DR RADHAKRISHNA ALSO
NOTED CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
ONLY STATES THAT'S NOT ACTIVELY
ENGAGED RIGHT NOW. SO THE ONE
ISSUE THAT WE WOULD RAISE THAT'S
NOT NECESSARILY ABOUT THE
DETAILS OF THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL- IS JUST TO NOTE THAT
WHILE THIS TYPE OF SURVEILLANCE
MAKES IT POSSIBLE TO DETECT
ISSUES AND OUTBREAKS EARLY AND
TO DO REAL TIME ANALYSIS. IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY DETERMINE
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT SO- BEYOND IS
SORT OF BEYOND THE NOTIFICATION
SO FOR EXAMPLE HOW WILL THE
STATE USE THIS INFORMATION IN
REAL TIME TO ACTIVATE A RESPONSE
BY RELEVANT STATE AND LOCAL
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES- AND- OUR
OFFICE DOES THINK THIS IS WHAT
ALSO MAKES- THE DEPARTMENT
SECOND PROPOSAL AND REGIONAL.
REGIONAL CLIMATE PLANNING
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU WITH
THAT'LL BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS
REMEMBER QUESTIONS I'LL KEEP IT
HERE AS CHAIR. OF MY FIRST
QUESTIONS GOING TO BE FOR DR
RADHA KRISHNA- REGARDING BIO
SENSE I I'D LIKE TO GET A SENSE
WHETHER OR NOT THE FEES. HAVE
BEEN A BARRIER FOR HOSPITAL
PARTICIPATION FIRST AND THEN
SECOND- THE FUNDING SEEMS TO BE
ONE TIME- IS THERE A NEED FOR ON
GOING FUNDING TO ENSURE. AND
ENCOURAGE YOUR PARTICIPATION IN
BIOSCIENCE. YEAH THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION AND ALL DEFERRED
LINDA HELEN'S TO GIVE A LITTLE
MORE DETAIL BUT START BIKE
SHARING- FROM OUR REVIEW AND
ENGAGEMENT OF FACILITIES AS WELL
AS LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AS
WELL AS INTERACTING WITH THE
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
LEARNING FROM OTHER STATES- WE
DON'T VIEW THE FEES TO BE. A
MAJOR BARRIER CERTAINLY BEING
ABLE TO SUPPORT THEM FOR SMALLER
FACILITIES AN ONBOARDING WOULD
BE OF BENEFIT AND THAT'S WHY WE
OUTWEIGH A MODEST AMOUNT OF
FUNDS TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THAT
BUT REALLY SETTING THE
EXPECTATION. THE ONGOING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND- VERY
HANDS ON- I. T. SUPPORT IS THE
MAIN ISSUE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS AND I'LL JUST CLARIFY
WE'RE STILL ON ISSUE NUMBER NINE
WHICH IS ONGOING IT'S NOT ONE
TIME- SO IT WOULD ALLOW OUR
STAFF TO BE ABLE TO. ON BOARD
FACILITIES ON A ROLLING BASIS
AND WE WOULD START WITH FORTY
FIVE EMERGENCY ROOM FACILITIES
THAT ALREADY USE THE PLATFORM
BUT NOT FOR CLIMATE SPECIFIC
CONDITIONS- TO GET THEM THAT
THAT HANDS ON TA AND THEN TO
CONTINUE THE ROLLOUT FROM THERE.
HAPPY TO HAVE LINDA ANSWER
ANYMORE QUESTIONS THERE. THANKS
I WILL JUST ADD THAT- WE HAVE
BEEN CALLING EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO TRY TO FIND OUT
MORE ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCES SO
FAR- PARTICIPATING IF THEY DO OR
WHY THEY HAVE NOT AND- SO FAR WE
HAVE NOT GOTTEN A SPENT THE
DEFINITIVE NUMBER FROM THEM.
ABOUT HOW MUCH THEY HAVE TO PAY
OR IF THEY HAVE TO PAY FOR
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD VENDORS
SO IT REALLY DOES SEEM TO VARY
ACCORDING TO THE ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORD VENDOR. WHETHER OR
HOW MUCH THE SECURITY NEEDS TO
PAY TO PARTICIPATE IN THE CENTER
OF THAT SURVEILLANCE MODUL- SO
WE'RE FINDING THAT THAT DOES NOT
SEEM TO BE A SIGNIFICANT BARRIER
TO PARTICIPATION. AND 71% OF
FACILITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
YOU HAVE TO PAY- SO WE EXPECTED
ONCE WE GET THE SYSTEM UP AND
RUNNING THAT- BE- INCENTIVES
INVOLVED IN WHAT WAS CALLED
MEANINGFUL USE KNOWLEDGE NOW I'M
DATA INTERPRET BILITY THROUGH
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT. WILL BE
SUFFICIENT INCENTIVE FOR MOST
FACILITIES TO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE AND HAVE THAT DATA
FOR THEMSELVES. AND THEIR
COMMUNITY IN THEIR OWN TIME. IT
WOULD WITH AN- TEN UNDER. TO FOR
FOUR ON THE UP. AGENDA IF I CAN
. IN IT YOU MENTION THAT CDPH
WILL USE SOME OF THE RESULTS TO
DEVELOP PROTECT PREDICTIVE
ANALYTIC MODELS OF FUTURE
INCIDENTS OF CONDITIONS SUCH AS
HEAT RELATED ILLNESSES AND
DEATHS I WAS HOPING YOU COULD
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THIS AND THEN AS THE L. A. O.
WAS REFERENCING HOW WE CAN HOPE
TO EFFECTIVELY COMMUNICATE THIS
WITH THE PUBLIC TO NOTIFY THEM.
OF LET'S SAY EITHER POOR AIR
QUALITY OR OF EXTREME HEAT
CONDITIONS HOW ARE WE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO ACTUALIZE THIS
IMPLEMENTED. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- AND BEING FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO
PREVENT- NOT JUST ACCOUNT-
SUFFERING OR ILLNESS OR DISEASE
OR INJURY IN THE MOMENT SO IT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION. I'M
I'LL GIVE ONE EXAMPLE THAT COULD
PERHAPS BRING TO LIGHT HOW THIS
TYPE OF INFORMATION COULD BE
USED IN ADDRESS SOME CURRENT
SHORTCOMINGS. RIGHT NOW WE DON'T
HAVE GOOD ANNUAL VISIBILITY LET
ALONE REAL TIME VISIBILITY INTO
THE HUMAN HEALTH IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CONDITIONS AND IF WE
JUST TAKE EXTREME HEAT. AS AN
EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW WHEN A HEAT
WARNING IS ISSUED IT'S BASED ON.
OUR AVERAGE TEMPERATURES WHICH
DON'T NECESSARILY CORRELATE TO
THE IMPACT ON HUMAN HEALTH- AND
SO AS WE'RE ABLE TO GET DATA OUT
FOR WHAT PARTICULAR THRESHOLDS
ARE IMPACT HUMAN HEALTH FROM
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT ENCOUNTERS
WERE ABLE BETTER TO BUILD OUR
MODELS. TO BE MORE SENSITIVE TO
HUMAN HEALTH SPECIFICALLY SO FOR
EXAMPLE WE COULD WORK WITH THE
NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE TO HAVE
WARNINGS AND NOTIFICATIONS BE
MORE ROOTED IN ACTUAL EXPERIENCE
OF CALIFORNIANS BEING SENSITIVE
TO CLIMATE CHANGES RATHER THAN
JUST THE GENERIC- TEMPERATURE
AVERAGE- AS I DID BRIEFLY
MENTION WE DO HAVE ONE OF THE
POSITIONS. DEDICATED FOR A
COMMUNICATIONS SPECIALIST NOTING
THAT CERTAINLY IN THE FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH WE'RE BUILDING OUT
A COMMUNICATIONS TEAM MORE
BROADLY. GIVEN THAT THIS IS THE
GREATEST PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS
OF THE CENTURY HAVING A
COMMUNICATION SPECIALIST
DEDICATED TO CLIMATE WILL BE
VERY IMPORTANT TO HELP CONNECT
THE DOTS TO THE BROADER PUBLIC
FOR- NOTIFICATION AS WELL AS
EARLY WARNINGS. AND YOU KNOW
PRACTICES AROUND WE THINK OF
FIRST AID IN PREVENTION AND
BEING ABLE TO ENGAGE THE PUBLIC
FOR A CLIMATE AS WELL WOULD BE
VERY IMPORTANT I'LL JUST SHARE
YOU KNOW MANY OF US ON A- CELL
PHONES CAN NOW KNOW WHAT THE AIR
QUALITY INDEXES. AS ONE EXAMPLE
IN RECENT INNOVATION BUT THERE'S
VARIOUS COLOR CODED SCHEMES
BASED ON YOUR CERTAIN
VULNERABILITIES ON HOW YOU MAY
PROTECT YOUR HEALTH- BASED ON
AND AN AIR QUALITY INDEX SCORE
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THAT. THAT'S
JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING
THAT BETTER DATA COULD HELP US
BE MORE PRODUCTIVE AND MORE
PROACTIVE IN MORE PREVENTIVE
MOVING FORWARD. I WILL FOLLOW UP
ON THAT EXAMPLE THEN- FRESNO
COUNTY HAD THE MOST NUMBER OF
BAD AIR QUALITY DAYS OF ANY
COUNTY IN THE STATE. HOWEVER WE
THAN AFFECTIVELY ABLE TO EDUCATE
AND INFORM COMMUNITY WHEN WERE
IN THE MIDST OF ONE OF THOSE BAD
AIR QUALITY DAYS. AND THEN A
FOLLOW UP HOWEVER WE ENSURING
I'M PREACHING TO THE CHOIR I'M
SURE BUT THEY WERE DOING IT IN A
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
COMPETENT WAY FOR THE DIVERSE
CITY OF OUR GREAT STATE- JUST
WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP EVEN
OFFLINE IF THAT'S. THAT COMES
WITH THIS PROPOSAL AND US BEING
ABLE TO CLOSER TO REAL TIME
BEING ABLE TO. BOTH ACT AND BE
INFORMED ABOUT THE SITUATION
THAT OUR STATE IS FACING I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THIS PROPOSAL AND-
WITH THAT I WILL. THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING ON ISSUE NINE AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE TEN-
IF WE CAN PLEASE BEGIN AT THE
TOP. THANK YOU CHAIR ARAMBULA
AND I'LL JUST ADD- CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP WITH POWELL OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH FOR EVERYTHING YOU
MENTIONED WILL BE ESSENTIAL
MOVING FORWARD FROM MULTIPLE
THREATS CURRENTLY WE FOCUS WITH
THEM AROUND HEATING COOLING
CENTERS AND AIR QUALITY AND- ON
THE PLAN TO IN THE FUTURE AS
WELL SO THANK YOU FOR.
ADDRESSING THE NEED FOR
COORDINATION I'M REGARDING ISSUE
TEN PUBLIC HEALTH REGIONAL
CLIMATE PLANNING. I WANNA INVOKE
DIRECTOR ADDED GOLEMS INITIAL
COMMENTS THAT THE HEALTH IMPACTS
OF PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS LIKE
CLIMATE CHANGE WILL ONLY
INCREASE IN SCALE SCOPE AND
INTENSITY. AND THIS REQUIRES US
TO IMMEDIATELY START PLANNING AT
A REGIONAL LEVEL FOR THOSE
IMPACTS THAT WE CAN ARE YOU SEEN
AS YOU MENTIONED IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
YOUR DISTRICT. AND REGION OF THE
STATE SO THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE THIRTY
OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION. IN
TWENTY THOUSAND TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY THREE WHICH IS AVAILABLE
FOR ENCUMBRANCE OVER SEVERAL
YEARS THROUGH JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE BUT IS A ONE TIME
FUNDING. AND THESE RESOURCES
WOULD ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND TRIBES IN
ORDER TO DEVELOP REGIONAL
CLIMATE AND HEALTH RESILIENCE
PLANTS. IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT
THIS PROGRAM WE WOULD
ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE ESTABLISH
EIGHT POSITIONS AND THE MAJORITY
OF THE FUNDS WOULD GO TO GRANTS.
ON TO PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
HOW CLIMATE CHANGE AFFECTS. ALL
PARTS OF OUR LIVES IT AFFECTS
ALL ORGAN SYSTEMS BUT IT GOES
BEYOND JUST HUMAN HEALTH AND
ALSO AFFECTING BUSINESSES
LIVELIHOODS CROPS HOMES
CONTRIBUTING TO UNEMPLOYMENT
POVERTY AND EVEN DISPLACEMENT IN
THE HOUSING CRISIS. SO THE
DIRECT IMPACTS AND THE CASCADING
EFFECTS AFFECT CHRONIC DISEASE
INFECTIOUS DISEASE MENTAL HEALTH. IN THE HEAT AND SMOKE RELATED
ILLNESSES WE JUST I'D I'M BEING
PERVASIVE AND CROSSED. AND
AFFECTING EVERY COMMUNITY AN
INDIVIDUAL BUT SOME MORE THAN
OTHERS. REALLY WARRANTS TO HELP
FOCUSED RESILIENCE PLANNING
APPROACH- SO WITH THESE FUNDS WE
WOULD SUPPORT LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS CBO'S IN TRIBES TO
DEVELOP PLANS AND THIS WOULD
BOLSTER THE ACTIONS OF LOCAL
HELP JURISDICTIONS THAT STILL
MAY BE RESOURCE LIMITED AND
HAVING STAFF DEDICATED. TO
CLIMATE RESILIENCY WITH THE
GOALS AGAIN OF PREVENTING AND
REDUCING AN EQUITABLE HEALTH
IMPACTS BY BEING BETTER
PREPARED. ON THIS FUNDING WOULD
ALLOW EACH OF THE FIVE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER REGION'S TO WRITE
AT LEAST ONE CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HEALTH RESILIENCE PLAN THAT
WOULD BE COORDINATED BY ONE TO
TWO. LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
FROM THAT REGION. ONE OR TWO
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WOULD
BE SELECTED TO LEAD THESE
REGIONAL PLANS IN THE PROCESS
AND WILL BE SELECTED BASED ON A
PROCESS THAT PRIORITIZES.
GREATEST CLIMATE AND HEALTH
INEQUITIES AS MEASURED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY PLACES INDEX.
WITH TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM
OUR DEPARTMENT AWARDEES WOULD
HELP RIGHT THE PLANS AND ADDRESS
PRIORITY CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HEALTH EQUITY IMPACTS IDENTIFIED
BY A VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENT.
TO IMPROVE THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH AND HELP
BOLSTER CLIMATE RESILIENCY
REGIONAL COALITIONS CONVENTIONS
INTERVENTIONS FROM A LIST OF
BEST PRACTICES PROVIDED FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE.
INCLUDING POLICY OBJECTIVES FOR
LONGER TERM CHANGE THIS PLAN
WOULD INCLUDE METRICS TO
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
PROCESS AND OUTCOME MEASURES
INCLUDING ENGAGEMENT IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR THE PLANNED
DEVELOPMENT. I'M ALL AND MY
NOTING- WHILE THIS IS A ONE TIME
FUNDING AND WON'T BE ENOUGH FOR
ALL JURISDICTIONS AND ALL
ASPECTS OF POTENTIAL
IMPLEMENTATION IT WOULD BE A
STRONG START FOR REGIONAL LEVEL
PLANNING. WITH TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THANK YOU
WE WILL HEAR FOR LINDA AND.
HELLO AGAIN I'LL JUSTICE FOR
CONDUCTOR- RATHER CHRISTIAN
OFFERED UP PRESENTATIONS AND
BIGGER TERRIFIED TO COST. NEXT
WE WILL HEAR FROM SONYA PADDOCK
WITH YELLOW THANK YOU SENATE
PECK FROM THE L. A. O- WE WANT
TO. TAKE A STEP BACK FOR A
MOMENT AND JUST NOTE THAT THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS IN THE
CDPH BUDGET THIS YEAR THAT
REQUEST ONE TIME FUNDING FOR A
SPECIFIC PURPOSE INCLUDING THIS
ONE- OTHER ONE TIME PROPOSALS
WILL BE DISCUSSED LATER IN THE
YEAR GENDO INCLUDING BOOKS FOR
CHILDREN IN THE WITH PROGRAM-
SUPPORT FOR THE FITNESS COUNCIL
GRANTS FOR ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
PROGRAMS. ETCETERA AND THESE ONE
TIME APPROPRIATIONS MAY MAKE
SENSE THIS YEAR FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS INCLUDING THE FACT THAT
THE STATE CURRENTLY HAS A
DISCRETIONARY BUDGET SURPLUS.
BUT NO GUARANTEE THAT REVENUES
WILL REMAIN AT THAT LEVEL- AS
YOU ARE LIKELY AWARE OUR OFFICE
REGULARLY CAUTIONS AGAINST OVER
COMMITTING FUNDING TO ONGOING
PROGRAMS DURING GOOD TIMES IF IT
CANNOT REALISTICALLY SUSTAIN
THOSE STRENGTH DURING THE
DOWNTURN. CAN ALSO MAKE SENSE IF
THE DEPART IF A DEPARTMENT WANTS
TO TEST A PROGRAM ON A LIMITED
BASIS TO SEE IF IT BRINGS VALUE
. HOWEVER WITHIN CITY PH. WE
WOULD NOTE THAT SUCH ONE TIME
AUGMENTATIONS CONTINUE THE
HISTORIC TREND OF PROVIDING ONLY
LIMITED. SHORT TERM FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH- SO. WE RAISE THIS
ISSUE JUST TO SAY THAT WE WOULD
MAINLY SUGGEST MAKING SURE THAT
ONE TIME FUNDING PROPOSALS
EITHER LEVERAGE EXISTING
RESOURCES OR LAY A FOUNDATION
THAT CAN BE USED IN THE FUTURE.
WHICH APPEARS. IN OUR APPEARS
THAT THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL IS
TRYING TO DO THAT- ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL WE THINK IT
DOES HAVE MERITS WERE AWARE THAT
MANY LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE STAFF FOR
EXPERTISE TO CONDUCT PLANNING
RELATED TO CLIMATE CHANGE. I'M
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
CONCERNS THAT WE WOULD RAISE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WISH
TO ASK THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT-
SO FIRSTOF ALL- AT RIGHT AT THE
END THEIR DOCTOR WROTE A
CHRISTIAN I MENTIONED THE FACT
THAT THESE PLANS ARE AT THE
REGIONAL LEVEL AND DON'T GO TO
EVERY LOCAL HOLD JURISDICTION
BUT AT LEAST IT'S A GOOD START.
OUR CONCERN- WITH THIS EVEN
THOUGH CLIMATE CHANGE IS
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T- RESPECT
LOCAL JURISDICTION BOUNDARIES-
ARE CONCERNED REALLY IS- WHETHER
THE LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
THAT DON'T RECEIVE THE FUNDING.
WILL BE FULLY ENGAGED IN THE
REGIONAL PLAN ESPECIALLY IF THEY
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE THE
CAPACITY AND THEN DON'T GET THE
FUNDING THROUGH THIS GRANT
PROGRAM- SECOND IT'S UNCLEAR-
THIS SORT OF WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
THESE PLANS ARE DEVELOPED SO FOR
EXAMPLE WHAT WOULD BE REQUIRED
BY THE STATE. WHAT OVERSIGHT
WOULD OCCUR. AND PER OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE DEPARTMENT-
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WOULD HAVE TO
DESIGN ACTIVITIES THAT COULD BE
CONDUCTED WITH EXISTING
RESOURCES- HOWEVER THAT
OBVIOUSLY LIMITS THE EXTENT. OF
WHAT CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED AND
WHAT ACTIVITIES CAN BE
UNDERTAKEN TO REDUCE THE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE. THANK
YOU WITH THAT I'LL BRING IT UP
TO THE DIRE SO I WILL- KEEP IT
HERE AT THE CHAIR. I'D I'D LIKE
TO- I DIG INTO THE AGENDA A
LITTLE BIT ON PAGE FORTY SEVEN
OF OUR AGENDA ON THE FOURTH.
BULLET YOU LIST THAT THERE ARE
SOME BEST PRACTICES WHICH WILL
BE PROVIDED BY CD P. H. I WAS
HOPING YOU COULD GIVE SOME
EXAMPLES OF THOSE. AND THEN I
WAS WANTING TO SEE IF- YOU ARE
GOING TO SUGGEST SPECIFIC
METRICS WITH THOSE BEST
PRACTICES TO THE REGIONAL PLANS.
AS SUGGESTED METRICS TO TRACK
AND FOLLOW- IF YOU COULD GIVE
SOME EXAMPLES OF THOSE AS WELL
WOULD BE GREAT. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTIONS I'LL START AND
THEN ASK LINDA HELEN TO PROVIDE
MORE DETAILS- THE QUESTION ASKED
ABOUT BEST PRACTICES AND THEN
SUGGESTED METRICS. AND ALL ALL
SHARE THAT PART OF THE REASON
WE'RE PROPOSING THIS WITHIN THE
CLIMATE CHANGE AND HEALTH EQUITY
SECTION TO LEAD IT IS OUR TEAM-
FOR ALMOST A DECADE NOW. HAS
DONE THIS WORK FOR MANY OTHER
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS IN
TERMS OF SHARING BEST PRACTICES
AND SUGGESTED PROCESS AND
OUTCOME MEASURES AROUND HOW TO
BOTH INCLUDE AND MONITOR. THE
HEALTH AND EQUITY ASPECTS OF
CLIMATE RELATED POLICY AND
PLANNING THAT'S REALLY WHAT
WE'VE DONE OVER OVER MANY YEARS
AS LEVERAGE THE PLANS IN THE
TOOLS AND THE DOLLARS F OTHER
AGENCIES. CAL ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY CAL NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH AND OTHERS AND
THIS WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO NOW SURE THAT SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE WITH OUR OWN
WITH THE REGION'S IN THE SIXTY
ONE LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
AND I'LL PASS IT TO LINDA WHO
HELPED WRITE. MANY OF THOSE
PLANS CHAPTERS AND PROPOSED
METRICS TO GO INTO MORE DETAIL.
THANK YOU YES SOME. EXAMPLES OF
BEST PRACTICES INCLUDE- AND- AS
MISCONDUCT POINTED OUT
COLLABORATING WITH THE
FACILITIES AND NOT AND OTHER
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
OPERATIONALIZE THE DATA THAT
COME FROM THAT PROPOSED
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM. TO DO
THINGS LIKE AND DOCTOR OF THE
CHRISTMAS AND WORK WITH THE
NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE OR EVEN
AT JUST BELOW THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT MOBILE TO. ISSUE
ALERT LIKE EXTREME HEAT ALERT-
WHEN THEY'RE WHEN THE
TEMPERATURE REACHES A THRESHOLD
IT MAKES THE EVIDENCE SHOWS
THERE ARE HEALTH IMPACTS IN THAT
LOCAL POPULATION BASED ON THEIR
GEOGRAPHY AND WATER PHILIPPINES.
BUT THAT- BASED ON HISTORICAL
TEMPERATURES WOULD NOT NORMALLY
TRIGGER HEAT UP A LARGE. ONE
WORKING TOGETHER Q. BUT THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
ESTABLISH THINGS SUCH AS THE
COOL BUDDY PROGRAM WHEREBY LOCAL
HELP. LOCAL COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IDENTIFY A CLIMATE
VULNERABLE PEOPLE BY FOR EXAMPLE
SENIORS LIVING ALONE OR PEOPLE
ON THE TOP FLOORS OF. APARTMENTS
ARE PEOPLE WHO. DO NOT HAVE OR
CANNOT AFFORD TO RUN THEIR
CONDITIONING- PEOPLE DEPENDENT
ON- ELECTRICAL AND VENTILATION
OR OTHER- BUT MEDICAL DEVICES.
AND IT IN THIS COOL BUDDY
PROGRAM THE- LOOK AT THAT-
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATION.
DEVELOPS A CADRE OF PEOPLE THAT
THAT THAT HELP Q. FIVE P.
PREVENTION BUT THE PERSON AND
GET THEM WEATHERNATION SERVICES
AND- THE PERSONAL COOLING THEIR
SERVICEMEN'S. YOU'RE
CONDITIONING A POSSIBLE AND WHEN
THERE IS A HUGE EVENT TO GO
CHECK ON THEM AND MAKE SURE
THEY'RE OKAY- BRING THEM SUPPORT
FOR EVACUATE THEM IF. NEED BE-
OTHER BEST PRACTICES INCLUDE-
CONTRIBUTING HEALTH AND EQUITY
CONTENT TO THE LOCAL CLIMATE
ACTION PLAN OR AT THE LOCAL
GENERAL PLAN PROCESS- TO THE-
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ELEMENT OF
THE DINNER PLAN FOR- INTERVIEWED
- HELP IN EQUITY BY. TO A
CIRCULAR OR AND- WHAT DEPEND
WALKING BASED PLAN I. YOU LOOK
HOW THEY MEDICAID PLAN- ALSO
UTILIZED TO WE HAVE A- OF- AT
DATA DRIVEN TRUE THAT ARE FOR.
SENSE TRACT THE CLIMATE EXPERT
POPULATION TO IN THE DAY CAN
PRODUCTION. THAT MADE HER RISK
COURT RELATED HEALTH HARM IT'S A
USABLE THE TOOLS EXAMPLE TO HELP
HER. QUESTIONS FOR BERMAN AND
GREENING OR WORSE STRUCTURE
MIGHT MIGHT BE MOST ME FOR TRAN
FOR EXAMPLE- TO- I TO WORK WITH
LOCAL WARRANTED AND RECREATION
THE PUBLIC WORKS- TO BRING THE
EVIDENCE AND DATA INVOLVING
ABILITY ASSESSMENTS TO PROMOTE
CLIMBERS BILLION INFRASTRUCTURE
NATURE BASED SOLUTION- WE WOULD
HELP THEM- I CAN TAX COMMUNITY
CLIMATE CHANGE AND HEALTH NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS AND THEN DEVELOP
PLANS OUT ON THAT REGIONAL
BASIS- THAT THEY WOULD AND
HOPEFULLY GET YOU IMPLEMENTED
THERE WERE OFFERED THE FUNDING-
OR EVEN START TO IMPLEMENT.
DURING THIS THREE YEAR ROUND. I
WOULD LIKE TO FILE UP NOW ON
FORTY SIX OF THE AGENDA UNDER
THE BACKGROUND SECOND PARAGRAPH
DOWN. IT STATES THAT CDPH
CURRENTLY HAS STAFF THAT'S
DEDICATED TO ADDRESSING CLIMATE
CHANGE AND HEALTH. AND IT WORKS
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO OTHER STATE AGENCIES TO EMBED
HEALTH INTO THEIR CLIMATE
RELATED PROGRAMS. I WAS HOPING
TO FOLLOW UP SPECIFICALLY ON
EITHER AB SIX ONE SEVEN OF
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
AND OR TCC TO FIGURE OUT WHICH
HEALTH RELATED METRICS- WE WERE
FOLLOWING TO EVALUATE THOSE
CLIMATE- RELATED PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU CHAIR ARAMBULA ALL I'LL
SHARE COMING FROM THE LOCAL
LEVEL IN THE RICHMOND SAN PABLO
AREA ONE OF THE SITES FOR A. B.
SIX ONE SEVEN COMMUNITY AIR
MONITORING IN POLLUTION
REDUCTION. AND HAVING SERVED ON
ALL LOCAL STEERING COMMITTEE-
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT ONE WHERE
THAT THE HEALTH VOICE CAN REALLY
ADD VALUE TO WHAT'S BEING TRACK
WHEN THERE'S A VARIETY OF
COMPETING INTERESTS WHEN IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MEASURE
ATTRIBUTABLE RISK FOR A
PARTICULAR SOURCE- THAT'S
CONTRIBUTING TO THE HEALTH
HARMS. ON THE EXAMPLE OFTEN
COMES UP IS THAT WELL WAS THAT
IS MY FROM A. B. OR C. THAT
LEADS SOMEONE TO BE IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM- AND CERTAINLY
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL- GIVES-
SOME HISTORY TO OUR INVOLVEMENT
WITH TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES ARE TCC. AGAIN I'M
GOING TO DEFER TO LINDA WHOSE-
REALLY HELPED BUILD A LOT OF THE
CONTRIBUTION OF METRICS AND
SUPPORT FOR OUR PRESIDENCY.
PARTNERS TO GO INTO MORE DETAIL
FOR YOU. THANK YOU AND I AM NOT
ACTUALLY RECALLING THE SPECIFIC
METRICS THAT WE- PROVIDED TO YOU
AND BENT INTO THE TWO FIFTY
PROGRAM- OR EIGHTY SIX POINT
SEVEN BUT WE DO IN A SENSE OF
WHAT NUMBER. ONE EARLY LIKE
FIFTEEN DIFFERENT STUFF STATE
PROGRAMS INTO WHICH WE HAVE
WORKING AND THAT HEALTH INEQUITY
METRICS- AND CONSIDERATION BY
LANGUAGE AND TOOLS- SO THEY.
WOULD BE THINGS LIKE- I SWEAR
THAT ROPE. GENUINE NOTHING
COMMUNITY. AND ENGAGEMENT AND
DEVELOPING THE PLANS- I THINK WE
HELPED- CONSOLE DEVELOPED-
CRITERIA FOR ASSESSING AND- AND
REACH UP TO MEANING GAUGE MEANT-
THINGS LIKE HEALTHY FOOD ACCESS-
RIGHT ABOUT PROMOTING HEALTH
THROUGH URBAN COMMUNITY GREENING
OUR LOW IMPACT DEVELOPMENT- FOR
STRATEGIES THAT USE THOSE TO
CLEAN THE WATER AND CLEAN AIR
AND PROVIDE SHADING AND REDUCE
HEAT ISLAND EFFECTS- SO I DON'T
HAVE A PRETTY GOOD SENSE OF
READING FOR THE CONCEPT- B. B.
R. ON. THAT KIND OF INDICATOR. I
MAY UP FOR- A LEVEL OF DETAIL ON
EACH OF THOSE PROGRAMS- BUT NOW
WILL TURN TO ASK IS THERE AN
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR US TO DO AN
ANALYSIS OF THOSE PROGRAMS. HOW
MANY YEARS AFTER THE INITIATION
OF SIX ONE SEVEN OR AFTER TCC-
SHOULD WE BE COMPARING TO THE
BASELINE TO DETERMINE IF THERE
IS A TREND THAT'S GOING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. FIVE YEARS. THE
FIVE YEAR YES IS IT TEN YEARS
HOW LONG. YEAH THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND- I THINK WE WOULD
NEED TO. COLLABORATE WITH SOME
OF OUR PARTNER CERTAINLY THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
ETA- AND MANY OTHERS THAT WE
WORK WITH AROUND THAT TIME
HORIZON FOR EVALUATION NOT SURE
LINDA IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT
THERE. I WILL I KNOW THAT THE
UCLA LUSKIN CENTER HAS DONE
EVALUATIONS I BELIEVE THEY'RE
PART OF THE HONDA FAMILY
COMMUNITY PROGRAM AGAIN EITHER
HE TOOK A COUPLE PROGRAMS NOT
OUR PROGRAMS- BUT- THAT HAS HAD
GREAT. EFFECT IN COMMUNITIES
WHERE THE FUNDING HAS GONE IN
TERMS OF. IMPROVING SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH AS WELL
AS REDUCING EMISSIONS AND- AGAIN
I DON'T HAVE THE DATA RIGHT IN
FRONT OF ME BUT- I DIDN'T THINK
WITHIN FIVE YEARS WE CAN'T WE
CAN'T- I HAVE SOME REALLY
MEANINGFUL. HEALTH IMPROVEMENTS
AND- AND POSITIVE HEALTH IMPATS. FROM THESE HUGE INVESTMENT. I
WOULD- I'M I'M RETICENT IT BUT I
FEEL OBLIGATED TO AS WELL- THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY HAS NEVER
REACHED ATTAINMENT TO THE
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN STANDARDS
TO THE TWO THOUSAND SIX
STANDARDS TO THE TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE STANDARDS THAT AT SOME
POINT WHEN WE HEAR ABOUT THE
ASTHMA RATES WE DO IN OUR
COMMUNITY WE HAVE TO QUESTION
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S HAPPENING
FAST ENOUGH FOR COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE. AND SO I THINK THAT'S WHY
YOU'RE HEARING FROM US THE
WANTING TO TRACK AND TREND AND
FOLLOW THEDATA TO SEE THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE OCCURRING
IN A COMMUNITY SAYS LIKE MINE
AND SO WITH THAT I WILL THANK
VERY MUCH THIS PANEL AND- ON
ISSUE TEN AND WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO PANEL SIX WHICH WILL COVER
FIVE PROPOSALS UNDER THE CENTER
FOR HEALTHY COMMUNITIES. WE WILL
HAVE THREE PRESENTERS WHO ARE ON
THIS PANEL BEGINNING WITH MONEY-
CHIRLA ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR- FOR THE CENTER
OPERATIONS WITH THE CENTER FOR
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES DR DIANA
RAMOS THE ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR CHRONIC DISEASE
PREVENTION AT WITH THE CENTER
FOR HEALTHY COMMUNITIES AND
FINALLY DOCTOR HAROLD GOLDSTINE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES WHO WILL BE
COMMENTING JUST ON ISSUE
FOURTEEN. AGAIN WE WILL PAUSE
FOR QUESTIONS AFTER EACH
PROPOSAL IS PRESENTED LET US
BEGIN WITH MONEY- CHAU. MARIA I
AM WITH H. C. M. WANTED THIS
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND WILL BE
PROVIDING UPDATES TODAY ISSUE
ELEVEN AND TWELVE. SO THE FIRST
ONE IS FOR SB SIX ONE NINE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REFLECTS
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT AB SIX ONE
NINE AIR QUALITY. THE FREQUENCY
SEVERITY AND DURATION OF WILD
SMOKE WILDFIRES SMOKE EVENTS
HAVE INCREASED DRAMATICALLY IN
CALIFORNIA EXPOSING MILLIONS TO
DANGEROUSLY UNHEALTHY AIR. THIS
REQUEST WOULD GIVE CDPH THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROVISIONS OF AB SIX ONE
NINE AND ADDRESS THE NEED FOR
CONSOLIDATED GUIDANCE ON
PROTECTIVE HEALTH MEASURES. THAT
SHOULD BE TAKEN IN THE CASE OF A
SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY BACK
CAUSED BY WILDFIRES OR OTHER
SOURCES. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REFLECTS AN INCREASE OF FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND IN
GENERAL FUND STATE OPERATIONS.
THE INCREASE SUPPORTS THREE
POSITIONS TO CREATE AND MAINTAIN
AN AIR QUALITY PLAN AS MANDATED
BY AB SIX ONE NINE. THE FUNDING
OFFICE ON GOING. CDPH CREATE AN
AUTHORITY OF AN UPDATED AIR
QUALITY HEALTH PLAN AND
CONSOLIDATED GUIDANCE AND
CONSULTATION WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM OTHER STATE
AGENCIES. APPROPRIATE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AIR POLLUTION
DISTRICTS CITIES COUNTIES
HOSPITALS AND VARIOUS ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS. CITY PH WILL
IDENTIFY CURRENT INFORMATION
SURROUNDING SMOKE EXPOSURE AND
HUMAN HEALTH AS WELL AS MAINTAIN
COUNTY LEVEL INFORMATION ON
RESOURCE SHORTAGES AND NEEDS.
CITY PH WELL ANALYZE COUNTY
RESOURCE NEEDS AND ASSESS AND
PACKED OF WILDFIRE SMOKE ON
POPULATION HEALTH. CITY CREWS
WILL PERFORM AND CONSULT ON
OUTREACH IN MATERIALS
DEVELOPMENT RELATED TO
COMMUNICATION REGARDING HEALTH
PROTECTION DURING ROCK ARE
INTENSE. CITY PH AND PROVIDE
CONSULTATION ON RISK ASSESSMENT
SELECTION AND USE OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND OTHER
EXPOSURE REDUCTION MEASURES.
THANK YOU. ESCHEWS I WOULD TAKE
THOSE NOW. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM DR DIANA RAMOS.
ACTUALLY I WILL BE PROVIDING THE
UPDATES ON ISSUES ELEVEN AND
TWELVE SHE WILL BE PROVIDING
UPDATES ON THE REMAINING ISSUES
SOUNDS GREAT- FOR THIS ISSUE CAN
YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN HOW THE STATE
NOTIFIES THE PUBLIC ABOUT POOR
AIR QUALITY THREATS. FOLLOWING
UP ON THE QUESTION WE JUST HAD
FROM BEFORE HOW DO YOU EXPECT
FOR THIS TO IMPROVE IN THE
FUTURE AS A RESULT OF AB SIX ONE
NINE. SO CITY PH WILL ACTUALLY
BE WORKING AND CONSULTATION WITH
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND
PROVIDING. THEM TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR COUNTIES TO USE
AN ACCEPTED A PLAN. AND THEY
WILL BE WORKING WITH THE
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION OUT TO THE PUBLIC.
SOUNDS GREAT WITH THAT LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO ISSUE TWELFTH. OKAY
THANK YOU SO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REFLECTS FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT AB TEN NINETY FOUR A
PILOT PROJECT TO COLLECT DATA ON
THE SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
GENDER IDENTITY DATA FILE
CONTESTS SUCH AS HOMICIDE AND
SUICIDE ARE LEADING CAUSES OF
PREMATURE DEATH AND ARE MAJOR
CONTRIBUTORS AND YEARS OF LIFE
LOST DUE TO THE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT. ON YOUNG PEOPLE. THE
LGBT COMMUNITY AS AT HIGHER RISK
FOR VIOLENT BEST BUT DATA IS
LIMITED ON THIS POPULATION WHICH
LIMITS EFFORTS TO PREVENT THESE
DEATHS. ROUTINELY COLLECTING
DATA ON SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
GENDER IDENTIFICATION OF
DECEDENTS AND CONSISTENT MANNER
IS A CRITICAL STEP IN FULLY
UNDERSTANDING THE DEPTH OF THIS
PROBLEM AND GUIDING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF METHODS TO
PREVENT DEATHS. AMONG THE LGBT
POPULATION. WELL THE CALIFORNIA
VIOLENT DEATH REPORTING SYSTEM
IS STRUCTURED TO COLLECT SEXUAL
ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTIFICATION DATA THAT DATA IS
ONLY AVAILABLE WHEN IT'S
PROVIDED FROM PRIMARY PRIMARY
DATE RESOURCES SUCH AS THE
CORONER MEDICAL EXAMINER. OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT REPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REFLECTS A ONE
TIME INCREASE OF FIVE HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE THOUSAND TOTAL
FUNDING. AT THIS THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND AND GENERAL
FUND STATE OFFICE AND TWO
HUNDRED TWELVE THOUSAND AND
LOCAL LISTINGS DANCE. TO
ESTABLISH AND ADMINISTER A THREE
YEAR SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
GENDER IDENTITY DATA COLLECTION
PILOT PROJECT AB TEN NINETY
FOUR. THE PILOT PROJECT WILL BE
IN UP TO SIX COUNTIES TO ENTER
INTO AN AGREEMENT WITH CDPH FOR
TRAINING CORONERS AND MEDICAL
EXAMINERS ON THE IDENTIFICATION
AND COLLECTION OF SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. AND GENDER ID DATA
IN CASES OF VIOLENT DEATHS SUCH
AS HOMICIDES AND SUICIDES. IN
INDIVIDUALS WHO IDENTIFY AS
LGBTQ. WHAT'S SELECTION OF AT
LEAST ONE COUNTY FROM EACH OF
THE NORTHERN SOUTHERN AND
CENTRAL REGIONS IN CALIFORNIA
AND CONSIDERATION OF
REPRESENTATION OF URBAN RURAL
AND SUBURBAN AREAS. CDPH EXPECTS
TO INCREASE PERCENTAGES OF
SEXUAL ORIENTATION INFORMATION
ACCURATELY COLLECTED PRESS
TRAINING AND INCREASED THE
KNOWLEDGE OF COUNTY STAFF
REGARDING THE COLLECTION OF
SEXUAL ORIENTATION DATA
INFORMATION. CITY PH WILL
REIMBURSE COUNTIES FOR THE COSTA
PARTICIPATING IN TRAININGS AND
IMPLEMENTING CHANGES TO CURRENT
PARTNER MEDICAL EXAMINER TOOLS
AND SYSTEMS TO PARTICIPATE. AND
THE PILOT PROJECT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK CDPH FOR WORKING SO
CLOSELY WITH MY STAFF ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS MODEL-
PRIOR TO IT BEING CHAPTER WE HAD
SUBMITTED A LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL IN WHICH I HAD EXPRESSED
THE LEGISLATORS TO HAVE THE
FOLLOWING FOR COUNTIES INCLUDED
IN THE PILOT PROGRAM FRESNO LOS
ANGELES STANISLAUS AND SANTA
CLARA COUNTIES. WHAT CRITERIA
CDPH USING TO DETERMINE WHICH
COUNTIES WILL BE ENGAGING IN
THIS PILOT. SO THEY WILL BE
USING IT I WILL BE USING A
COMBINATION OF DATA AND ALSO
LOOKING AT CURRENT INVOLVEMENT
AND- COUNTIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING IN AND THE
CALIFORNIA VIOLENT DEATH
REPORTING SYSTEM. AND JUST
LOOKING AT COUNTY'S WILLINGNESS
AND ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PILOT PROJECT SO WHAT WE'RE
STILL WORKING ON ALL THE DETAILS
RIGHT NOW. I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE- CONSISTENT COMMUNICATION
WITH MY STAFF- WITH THAT I WILL
THANK YOU AND WHAT'S PLEASE
PRESENTS NOW ON ISSUE THIRTEEN.
YOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
YOU MY NAME IS DR DIANA RAMOS
AND I AM THE ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR CHRONIC DISEASE
PREVENTION AND THE CENTER FOR
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES ISSUE
THIRTEEN ALPHA LIMA FIRST
HEALTHY BRAIN INITIATIVE PCP THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH REQUEST WHAT TIME FUNDING
IN THE AMOUNT OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION AND LOCAL
ASSISTANCE AND ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION IN STATE OPERATION. IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
BUT PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE FOR
FUNDS TO BE AVAILABLE UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE
ALLOCATE GRANTS TO AN ADDITIONAL
SIX HELICOPTERS LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS PARTICIPATING IN
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY BRAIN
INITIATIVE CURRENTLY THERE ARE
SIX LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
PARTICIPATING IN THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY BRAIN INITIATIVE PILOT
PROGRAM ALLOF WHICH ARE
CREATING PROGRAMS THAT MEET THE
NEEDS. OF THEIR SPECIFIC
JURISDICTION. EIGHTY PH WITH A
KERR FOR APPLICATION. FOR A LOT
HEALTH JURISDICTION. THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION RECEIVING THE FUNDS
SHOWING. ALL OF THE FOLLOWING
FUNDAMENTAL PLANNING PRINCIPLE.
ELIMINATING HEALTH DISPARITIES
COLLABORATING ACROSS MULTIPLE
SECTORS AND LEVERAGING PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE RESOURCES FOR
SUSTAINED IMPACT. WE WILL
CONTINUE USING THE CDC HEALTHY
BRAIN INITIATIVE ROADMAP WHICH
OUTLINES THE AGENDA OF ACTION
FOR STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCIES AND THEIR
PARTNERS TO PROMOTE BRAIN HEALTH
BETTER CARE FOR PEOPLE WITH
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT. INCREASED
ATTENTION TO CARE GIVERS AND
BILL PUBLIC HEALTH PATH TO BE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WILL
BRING IT UP TO THE DÍAS FOR
QUESTIONS- I CAN'T I COULDN'T
HELP BUT NOTICE IN THE FIRST
ROUND OF GRANTS THAT THERE ARE-
WERE. BOTH NO INLAND EMPIRE OR
CENTRAL VALLEY LOCATIONS WHICH
WERE CHOSE AND I AM WONDERING
WHETHER OR NOT- THERE WAS
ANYTHING THAT PREVENTED OR
DISCOURAGED THESE COUNTIES FROM
APPLYING. AND THEN HOW WILL WE
ENSURE. THAT THEY APPLY IN THE
NEXT ROUND WILL WE BE DOING
SPECIFIC OUTREACH WILL WE BE
PROVIDING TA. TO HELP THEM TO
OVERCOME ANY BARRIERS AND
APPLYING. SO JURISDICTIONS WERE
INVITED TO APPLY- WE HAVE TO
KEEP IN MIND THAT THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS STARTED IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND COALBED
IMPACTED. PARTICIPATION CAPACITY
AT ALL LEVELS BUT ABSOLUTELY THE
CRITERIA- WILL IT DOES INCLUDE
ROLE PARTICIPATION AND WE HOPE
TO INCLUDE A DIVERSE OF
REPRESENTATION AND ENCOURAGE. AS
AS YOU HAD RECOMMENDED WORK OF
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS THAT
WILL BE REFLECTIVE OF ALL.
SECTORS OF THE STATE. I THINK
I'M JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE TO
ENCOURAGE OUTREACH AND TA TECH
COUNTIES. TO- HELP THEM IN
APPLYING IT IT- THEY MAY HAVE
HAD BARRIERS DURING THE PANDEMIC
BUT AS WE'RE GOING FORWARD- I
WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE AS WAS
ORIGINALLY IN THE- INITIAL B. C.
P. THAT WE FOCUS BOTH ON RURAL
AND SOME OF OUR UNDERSERVED
PORTIONS OF OUR STATE SO- WOULD
HOPE THAT THESE ADDITIONAL SIX
JURISDICTIONS WOULD TAKE THAT
INTO ACCOUNT. THANK YOU FOR THAT
RECOMMENDATION RIVER WE SURE
CHECK WITH. THANK YOU I WILL NOW
HAVE US MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FOURTEEN DOCTOR GOLDSTINE WHEN
YOU'RE READY. PICTURE WHAT HAVE
WHAT WE HAVE THE FIRST- LET'S
BEGIN EXCUSE ME LET'S KEEP WITH
DARK- DOCTOR. I THINK DOCTOR
DIANA RAMOS. YEAH THANK YOU THE
FOURTEENTH AS THE BUSINESS
COUNCIL PCP DPH REQUEST A ONE
TIME INCREASE OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND IN STATE
OPERATE AT THE PORT OF A NURSE
ADVISORY COUNCIL ON PHYSICAL
FITNESS AND MENTAL WELL BEING.
IF INCREASE INCLUDES PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE WITH INCOME RENTS OR
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY. UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. IN JUNE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE GOVERNOR'S ADVISORY COUNCIL
ON PHYSICAL FITNESS AND MENTAL-
ARE YOU AT AND- MENTAL HEALTH
WELL BEING WAS COURT AND IS
BEING LED BY THE FIRST PARTNER
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON ADVANCING
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY AND MENTAL
WELLNESS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
EPA TO OVERSEE THE COORDINATION
OF THE COUNCIL THE HIGH LEVEL
FACILITATION AND CROSS SECTOR
COMMUNICATIONS REPORT COUNCIL
DEVELOPMENT AND ENGAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES. OVERSEE CONTRACTS
FOR BOTH EVENT PLANNING AND
SOCIAL MARKETING CAMPAIGNS.
OVERSEE PREPARATION OF AN ANNUAL
REPORT SB THE LAYERS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND ALL
APPROPRIATE STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. WE WILL ALSO
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR COUNCIL
MEETINGS AS WELL AS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANT CONFERENCE AND
TRAINING SERVICES. EXECUTIVE
COMPREHENSIVE SOCIAL MARKETING
CAMPAIGNS IN DESIGNATED MEDIA
MARKET AND COMMUNITY STATEWIDE.
IDENTIFY EVALUATION STRATEGIES
TO MEASURE CHANGING ATTITUDES
AND BEHAVIOR AND IMPLEMENT
ACTIVITIES THE MEASURE THE FACT
THAT SOCIAL MARKETING CAMPAIGNS
. ALL OF THE REQUEST. FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN DOLLARS
AND IN TWENTY. TWO TO TWENTY
FIVE FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
COORDINATE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUSINESS COUNCIL AND EIGHT POINT
SIX MILLION OVER THREE YEARS FOR
SOCIAL MARKETING CAMPAIGN AND
DESIGNATED STYLE MEDIA MARKET
AND COMMUNITY STATEWIDE- FIFTY
THOUSAND WOULD BE TO SUPPORT THE
COUNCIL A CONTRACT WITH
SACRAMENTO STATE. FOR LOGISTICAL
ADMINISTRATIVE AND COMMUNICATION
REPORT. AND THERE WERE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE- BROUGHT UP. DO YOU
WANT ME TO ADDRESS VOEPEL YES
PLEASE. OKAY THE FIRST QUESTION
WAS HOW MANY RESEARCH BEEN DONE
TO PREPARE EFFICACY OF PROMOTING
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY A PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN. AND OVERALL
THERE IS CURRENTLY INSUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE TO DETERMINE WHETHER
MASS MEDIA CAMPAIGNS INCREASED
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY AND- FITNESS.
BUT RESEARCH HAS SUGGESTED THAT
MASS MEDIA MADE HIM FOR THE
PERFECT TYPE IS THE COLLECTIVITY
SUCH AS WALKING- AND THE OTHER-IS FOR- SOCIAL MEDIA CAMPAIGNS
ARE ALSO INCREASINGLY BEING USED
TO PROMOTE HEALTH AND OFFER
DISTINCT ADVANTAGES OVER
TRADITIONAL MEDIA INCLUDING THE
ABILITY TO TARGET SPECIFIC
SUBGROUP. GENERATE INCREASED
SOCIAL SUPPORT AWARENESS AND
INFLUENCE SOCIAL NORMS. WE HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN USING SOCIAL
MEDIA- FOR THE PRE DIABETES
CAMPAIGN HERE IN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THIS WOULD BE A CONTINUE ON THAT
TRAJECTORY FOR THE WORK THAT
WE'VE ALREADY DONE AND THE SPEED
DIABETES. CAMPAIGN CAN NOW BE
THE BRIDGE FOR- THAT PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY AND MENTAL HEALTH. THE
OTHER QUESTION IS ACCORDING TO
RESEARCH WHAT ARE THE MOST
COMMON BARRIERS TO PEOPLE
ENGAGING IN PHYSICAL ACTIVITY.
SO- IF YOU THINK THE MOST COMMON
BARRIERS OVERALL ARE WITH
RESPECT TO PHYSICAL ACTIVITY AND
EXERCISE OF LACK OF TIME IT'S
LIKE OF EXERCISING FEELING TOO
TIRED LACK OF COMPANY AND LACK
OF MONEY- SEARCHING ON ON HIGH
OVERVIEW RESEARCH AMONG LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS ARE PROJECTS
THAT LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITIONS MAY PRESENT
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY INCLUDING LACK OF
RESOURCES THAT SUPPORT ACTIVITY
LACK OF WELL MAINTAINED PATHS
ARE PARTS AND PERCEPTION OF
COMMUNITY LIKE WHAT. AND LACK OF
FAITH YOUR PERCEPTION OF
DISORDER OR CRIME A LACK OF
SAFETY OFTEN REPORTED VERY YOUR
MIND- BATTERIES AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND HISPANIC ADOLESCENT AND.
ADULT AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. SOME OF WOMEN
REPORT LACK OF TRUST. AND LOCAL
OF OPPORTUNITY. WE'RE ALSO.
CHECK THAT THE PROACTIVE. AND
THEN THE FINAL QUESTION IS HOW
DOES THE PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN ADDRESS THOSE #RIERS
MEDIA AND IN PARTICULAR SOCIAL
MEDIA CAN BE USED TO ALERT
INDIVIDUALS THE COMMUNITY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY BOTH YOUR PERCEPTION
SOCIAL FOR INFLUENCE NORMS OF
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY BOOSTS SELF
EFFICACY AND DISPEL MYTHS
REGARDING POTENTIAL THREATS- THE
OTHER THING TO HIGHLIGHT IS THAT
. RESOURCES TO MENTAL HEALTH WE
ARE. IN IN OUR COMMUNITY OUT
WOULD ALSO BE PROVIDED THE MEDIA
CAMPAIGN WHERE I CAN THINK OF
CORPORATE A STRONG MENTAL HEALTH
COMPONENT WERE LINKED TO
MULTIPLE RESOURCES AND
ACTIVITIES- AT THAT THE COUNCIL
WILL BE DEVELOPING AND WE KNOW
THAT MASS MEDIA ITSELF AND NOT
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY. ADDRESS
HOUSEHOLD FINANCIAL ISSUES OR
INCREASED LEISURE TME SERVICE
UNDERSCORES THE NEED TO
INTEGRATE MEDIA SOCIAL MEDIA AND
OTHER INTERVENTIONS HE PH CAN
LEAD AND CHANGING THE PARADIGM
OF WHAT EXERCISE LOOKS LIKE IT
COULD BE AS SIMPLE AS YEAH I
THINK IN YOUR LIVING ROOM RIGHT
AFTER DINNER AND THIS WILL HELP.
INCREASE NOT ONLY YOUR YOUR
OVERALL WELLNESS. GERMAN HELP.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR TO SEE A
DOCTOR EMILY GOOD THIS YOU- I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT THE THIS
PROPOSAL I THINK THE- GIVEN WHAT
WE KNOW OF WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY DURING COVERED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE STUCK INSIDE
THEIR HOMES ACTIVITIES GONE DOWN
DRAMATICALLY- WHAT I
PARTICULARLY LIKE- THERE TWO
THINGS ONE IS- THAT THE FITNESS
COUNCIL IS NOW LOOKING AT THIS
BALANCE BETWEEN PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY AND MENTAL HEALTH THOSE
TWO THINGS GO TOGETHER REALLY
WELL BUILT ON ALL CHILDREN
THRIVE IN THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
THAT IN PARTICULAR WHAT DO YOU
AND OTHER SUPPORT IN
200-017-2000 EIGHTEEN FOR THE
DIABETES PREVENTION PROGRAM AND-
WE KNOW THAT SOCIAL SUPPORT IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO BEHAVIOR CHANGE
AND THE THAT THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WAS AS SUCCESSFUL AS THEY WERE
USING A SOCIAL MARKETING
CAMPAIGN TO PROMOTE DPP THIS
SEEMS LIKE THE NATURAL NEXT STEP
FOR THAT. AND SO OFTEN. PEOPLE
LOOK AT DIABETES AND THINKING
THINK OF IT AS A NUTRITION
pPHYSICAL ACTIVITY SO I. YEARS
AGO YOU TOLD ME A STORY I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU MEMBER OF BEING IN
THE ER AND SOMEBODY TOOK THEIR
SHOE OFF AND WHAT COULD WHAT
ELSE CAME OFF WITH THE ISSUE-
THAT HAS STAYED WITH ME-
PHYSICAL ACTIVITIES FUNDAMENTAL
TO THE TO THE SOLUTION TO THAT
I'D BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T THOUGH
ALSO SAY- AND IT IT. BILLY NOT
SOMETHING FOR THIS SUBCOMMITTEE-
NATIONALLY 8% OF ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN THE COUNTRY
DON'T HAVE A P. E. TEACHER IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S 50% EVEN MORE
EVEN FEWER LATINO AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN KID SO IT IT IT'S A
BOTH HAND BUT WE ARE WE IN
CALIFORNIA IN DESPERATE NEED FOR
MORE P. E. TEACHERS ESPECIALLY
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. OKAY THE
ONLY QUESTION I HAVE THAN FOR
THE PANEL IS WHETHER OR NOT-
THIS PROPOSED PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN IS DUPLICATIVE OF SOME
OF THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
WITHIN ALL CHILDREN. THE ACES
EXCUSE ME THE ACES AWARE
CAMPAIGN WHICH IS ALSO
PRIORITIZING PROMOTING HEALTHY
LIFESTYLE CHOICES SUCH AS
EXERCISE. IS IT DUPLICATIVE IS A
SEPARATE HOUSING I THINK I'M
HEARING YOU ON AND YEAH I MEAN I
THINK THERE IS- I THINK THE ACES
WORK IS MUCH BROADER THIS IS
MUCH MORE SPECIFIC JUST TO THE
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY SAIVA. DR
THOMAS. DOCTOROW MOST. SO THERE
BIG DIFFERENCE IS THAT WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO ENCOMPASS THE
WHOLE- TRAJECTORY AND THE WHOLE
SPECTRUM OF EVERYONE IN IN
CALIFORNIA FROM CHILDREN TO
GRANDPARENTS IN YOUR SAID
ASSEMBLY ANSWER BACK THE
DIFFERENCE BUT THE OTHER BIG
THING IS LEVERAGING YES YOU
HIGHLIGHTED VERY WELL THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE OCCURRING BUT THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO NOW CONNECT THE
DOTS AND REALLY LEVERAGE ALL OF
THE FANTASTIC WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE HERE IN CALIFORNIA A
PROMOTED. WITH THE FERRY AT.
YOUR SOCIAL MEDIA CAMPAIGN THAT
ARE GOING TO BE THE TARGET AT SO
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE
THE WORK THAT'S BEING DONE AND
NOT FORGETTING CONTINENTAL THAT
MENTAL HEALTH. EXACTLY AND YOU
KNOW I'VE I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S COUNCIL ON
PHYSICAL FTNESS FOR. TWENTY
YEARS PROBABLY- I DON'T THINK
THEY'VE EVER HAD THE RESOURCES
TO REALLY DO SOMETHING
SIGNIFICANT AND HERE'S A CHANCE
TO DO THAT. SOUNDS GREAT WITH
THAT I WILL THANK THIS PANEL AND
WOULD ASK THAT WE NOW PLEASE
PRESENT ON ISSUE FIFTEEN. SO
THAT IS ME AGAIN ISSUE FIFTEEN-
TAXES- PROPOSITION NINETY NINE
AND FIFTY SIX ADJUSTMENT. THE
GOVERNMENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REFLECT THE FOLLOWING
ADJUSTMENTS TO PROPOSITION
NINETY NINE AND FIFTY SIX THE
FACT THAT TAX REVENUE YOUR
LATEST FUNDING FOR CDPH CENTER
FOR HEALTHY COMMUNITY PROGRAM.
AND I BELIEVE THE FIRST ONE ITS
PROPOSITION NINETY NINE RESEARCH
ACCOUNT. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REFLECTS A DECREASE OF ONE POINT
NINE MILLION IN PROPOSITION
NINETY NINE RESEARCH ACCOUNT
OPERATIONS. AS A RESULT OF
UPDATED PROPOSITION NINETY NINE
REVENUE PROJECTIONS. THE
DECREASE COULD SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND EIGHT
ADMINISTRATION AND ONE POINT TWO
MILLION AND EXTERNAL CONTRACTS.
THE REVENUES ARE USED FOR
TOBACCO RELATED DISEASE RESEARCH
. THERE WERE QUESTIONS THAT.
WERE ASKED THE FIRST ONE IS.
STAKEHOLDERS REPORTED FIFTY PAGE
INTENDS TO REDUCE FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CANCER REGISTRY
BY ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION DUE
TO REDUCTION IN PROPOSITION
NINETY NINE RAPID YOU IS THIS
ACCURATE THE ANSWER IS YES. THE
FOLLOWING QUESTION IS WHAT WILL
BE THE IMPACT OF THE- CALIFORNIA
CANCER REGISTRY OF THIS
REDUCTION. AT THE IMPACT IS
BASICALLY IN THREE AREAS THERE
WILL BE DECREASED QUALITY OF
DATA AND SUBSEQUENT LOSS OF
FEDERAL FUNDING. BOB BY THE
QUALITY WE NEED WE NEED THAT THE
QUALITY WOULD BE IMPACTED BY THE
DIMINISHED ABILITY TO CONFIRM
CHAPTER CASES. THE MONEY IS
BEING USED FOR AT THE LONGER
WAIT TIMES FOR DATA AVAILABILITY
. IN ADDITION LOTS OF MATCHING
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR REGIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS. THAT USE THAT DATA
COLLECTED WHICH WOULD BE THE
DATA COLLECTION CONTRACTORS THAT
RECEIVED THE INITIAL- CHAPTER
REPORT. THEY WON'T HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO HAVE THE MATCHING
FUNDS AND THIS WOULD RESULT IN
FURTHER DECREASES. AND DATA
QUALITY. AND FINALLY THE
ELIMINATION OF POP UP APPRECIATE
THE BROCHURE. THE FAT OF FIGHT
THEIR FACTORY REQUIREMENT OF
HAVING POSITION INFORMED CANCER
PATIENTS. THAT THEY MAY BE
CONTACTED BY BY RESEARCHERS. SO
CURRENTLY IF THE BROKE IS.
RENTED BY THE PAGE BUT IT SIMPLE
TO NOTE THAT THE PTO. OF THE
BROCHURE WILL CONTINUE TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE AND THE POSITION
OF THE SITE HOW THEY WILL
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO
THEIR PATIENTS. THANK YOU AYE- I
THINK THE QUESTION AND I'M HAPPY
TO FOLLOW UP OFFLINE I WANT TO
ENSURE SIMILAR TO HOW WE HOW IT
SUPPLEMENTATION LANGUAGE EARLIER
THE NONE OF OUR TOBACCO TAXES
ARE GOING TOWARD STAFFING OF-
LET'S SAY SHERIFF'S AND FRESNO
COUNTY. THAT INSTEAD THESE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE FOR INTENTIONAL
PROGRAMS AS IT STATES FOR
EVIDENCE BASED HEALTH PROMOTION
AND HEALTH COMMUNICATION
ACTIVITIES- ARE WE CONFIDENT
THAT THERE ARE NO RESOURCES
GOING TOWARDS- SHERIFF'S IN
PARTICULAR COUNTIES HOW DO WE
HAVE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- OR HOW ARE WE-
FOLLOWING UP ON THE- SO THAT IS.
NOT FOR US TO BE THAT. ABLE ON
BACK AND I CAN ASSURE YOU THOUGH
WHAT WHAT I CAN ASSURE YOU IS
THAT WE ARE USING THE FUNDS. TO
OBTAIN THE DATA THAT WILL DRIVE
ACTION WELL IN TERMS OF CANCER
RESEARCH HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO I
CAN TELL YOU THAT THAT'S WHAT WE
ARE DOING AND OUR OUR
CONTRACTORS. ARE ARE GREAT
PARTNERS AND ARE HELPING US GET
BACK EITHER SORRY I WANT TO MAKE
SURE OF IS TALKING ABOUT TOBACCO
TAXES WITH THAT COMMENT ABOUT ON
SATIN TATIAN VERSES- THE CANCER
REGISTRY- JUST TO ENSURE THAT.
THEY WERE. THANK YOU START. IS
IT THE SAME RESPONSE OR IS THERE
A DIFFERENT RESPONSE FOR TOBACCO
TAXES. I CAN'T I CAN'T GIVE YOU
THAT PERFECT- RESPONSE SO I
WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK. TO YOU
ON. I WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP AS
I ARE. NOT JERRY SILICON VALLEY
WAS OUR INNER. RECTOR HELLO
MISTER CHAIR MY NAME IS TERRY
SILICON VALLEY DAHLMAN AND I'M
ON THE LIST TO HELP OUT HERE IF
NEEDED I'M AND ACTING DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR CENTER FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES. AND I CAN SAY FOR
THE FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE-
FROM THE TOBACCO TAX IN OUR
PROGRAMS- WE HAVE- SEVERAL
EVALUATION TOOLS IN WHICH- WE
ENSURE THAT THE FUNDS ARE USED
FOR THE STATED PURPOSE SO.
WITHIN OUR TOBACCO CONTROL
PROGRAM WE ARE PROVIDING.
FUNDING TO WHAT WE CALL LOCAL
THE AGENCIES WHICH WOULD BE OUR-
COUNTY PARTNERS- THE FUNDS WOULD
BE PROVIDED IT FOR THE SPECIFIC
USE AND SO WE WOULD BE ENSURING
THAT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO YOU
KNOW LAW ENFORCEMENT OR- OR
OTHER AREAS IN THE COUNTY.
BROUGH OUR GRANTS AND THE
ASSESSMENT OF OUR GRANT AN
EVALUATION OF OUR GRANTS THAT WE
DO HAVE SOME PROCESS HE'S SET UP
TO ENSURE THAT THE FUNDS ARE
BEING USED FOR THEIR INTENDED
PURPOSE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
FOLLOWING UP AND SHOWING YOU
SOME EXAMPLES OF COUNTIES WHO
MIGHT NOT BE ACTING IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OR UNDER THE INTENT.
OF ENSURING THAT WERE PROMOTING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND- INSTEAD SEEMS
TO BE- SUPPLANTING OTHER FUNDING
AND- AM CONCERNED THAT WE ARE
NOT ADDRESSING HEAD ON- THE
ISSUE THAT THESE FUNDS WERE
INTENDED FOR AND SO. I AM
ANXIOUS TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
THAT FOLLOW. UP TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. ABSOLUTELY WERE
DEFINITELY TO UP WITH YOU ON
THAT. WITH THAT I WILL THANK
VERY MUCH PANEL SIX WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO PANEL SEVEN WHICH
WILL PRESENT FIVE PROPOSALS. FOR
ESTIMATES FOR THE CENTER FOR
FAMILY HEALTH WE WILL HAVE FOUR
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
INCLUDING THREE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ONE REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CLINICAL LABORATORY ASSOCIATION
WHO WILL COMMENT ON ISSUE
NINETEEN THE GENETIC DISEASE
SCREENING PROGRAM ESTIMATE. WE
WILL HOLD ALL QUESTIONS UNTIL
THE END LET US PLEASE BEGIN WITH
THE GENETIC DISEASE TESTING
PROGRAM ESTIMATES. WHEN YOU'RE
READY. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RICHARD ONLINE I'M A DIVISION
CHIEF FOR THE GENERIC THAT THE
SCREENING PROGRAM THE GST. AND
I'M HAPPY TO FIRST- PRESENT AN
OVERVIEW OF OUR ESTIMATE. YES
PLEASE BUDGET OUT OF THE PEN OR
THE ACTIVITIES OF TWO MAJOR
PROGRAM- THE GENETIC TO DETECT
IN FINER TO THE T. THE WARRANTS
AND PRINTING SCREENING ALSO
KNOWN AS MBS AND PIANO. OUR
ESTIMATES OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY A
DOWNWARD TRENDS AND LYFT BIRTH.
TRANSLOCATE BOTH THEN BE A PIANO
SIX SPEND THE TRUTH AND REVENUE
SO I'M TALKING ABOUT THEM
TOGETHER. YEAH NO SIMPLE
ADDITION RATES OF MEMBERS OF
ALSO DECREASED. SCREENING TREND
AWAY FROM BIOCHEMICAL SCREENING
. THE PIANO OF CHANGING MORE
THAN ANYA AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE BECAUSE- OF IMPLEMENTATION
. CELEBRATED INACCURACIES OF THE
PENANG BRINGING. WHICH WAS
FUNDED IN THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR AFTER BIRTH YEAH NABC WITH
THE- BUT THEY HAVE TO DENY IS
ALSO KNOWN A- A NON INVASIVE
PRENATAL SCREENING OR AN IP HE-
HAVE A MUCH BETTER DETECTION
RATE AND ACTORS TO GIVE THEM THE
CURRENT BOTH LOCAL SCREENING
PROGRAM. AND THAT'S THE CURRENT
STANDARD OF CARE FOR I MEAN FOR
DOWN SYNDROME AND TRICYCLE WITH
EIGHTEEN AND THIRTY. DECEMBER
THIRD THE FINANCE PROGRAM OF THE
VOLUNTARY STATEWIDE PROGRAM
MANDATED BY STATUTE- THAT
MANDATES THAT WOULD MEAN
ACCORDING TO THE STANDARDS SET
BY ORGANIZATION ASK MARKET BASED
APPROACH CURTAIN CALL'S OF
OBSTETRICIAN GYNECOLOGISTS. AND
IT'S FOCUSED ON MAKING A UNIFORM
EQUITABLE SCREENING AVAILABLE
FOR THE ENTIRE POPULATION. AND
VERY IMPORTANTLY INCLUDES-
FOLLOW UP ON FOR THE DIAGNOSTIC
SERVICES AS PART OF OUR
COMPREHENSIVE FIFTY. SO FAR
EXPENDITURES THAT THE CURRENT-
FOR THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THE
ESTIMATE AS LITTLE CHANGE
OVERALL PERSON THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT. HOWEVER FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THE AMERICAN FLAG THE
FINANCIAL INCREASE OF UP TO
TWENTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION AND EXPENDITURES.
ALMOST ALL THESE ARE TO DO
INCREASE OF- HELPFUL SYSTEM.
WITHOUT LIMITATION OF THE AFGHAN
AND SCREENING. AS WELL AS THE
MAJOR SYSTEM REDESIGN OF THE
TENNIS PROGRAM. AND ARE IN.
SYSTEM MIGRATION COSTS FOR A NEW
CLOUD PLATFORM THE POPE AND THE
S. AND P. ENOUGH. WHICH WAS
REQUIRED BY THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY. ON THE REVENUE SIDE
ARE HOPING THAT FOR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TOTAL A HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE MILLION. WHICH IS A
DECREASE OF ELEVEN POINT NINE
MILLION COMPARED TO THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. THAT
DECREASE IS PRIMARILY
ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE DECLINE IN
THE BIRTHRATE THAT THEY
MENTIONED EARLIER. THIS DECLINE
IN REVENUE TO THE POTENTIAL
NEGATIVE EFFECT ARE PROTECTED ON
COMMISSION. WITHOUT ANY FEE
CHANGES SO- THROUGH THE RULE
MAKING PROCESS IT IS S. P. WALL
PROPOSED INCREASE- TWO HUNDRED
ELEVEN DOLLARS IT'S PAST TIME
FOR THE NEWBORN SCREENING AND WE
ARE ALSO PROPOSING CRITICS OF
THE- THREE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO DOLLARS FOR SELF IN A
SCREENING. IN A FIVE DOLLARS PER
NEURAL TUBE DEFECT SCREENING
THEM ON THE PIANO OUTSIDE
BEGINNING JULY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AND IF YOU CHANGES ARE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE LOSS OF
REVENUE TO CRITICALLY. THE GREAT
THE PLAN LIVE BIRTH. AND
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE CLOUD MIGRATION SYSTEM
REDESIGN THAT I MENTIONED. THE
FOLLOWING EXPENDITURES RELATED
TO HIGHER CONTRACT RATES UP
SUPPORT FOR SCREENING. WHAT THE
SPEED CHANGES AND RESTRUCTURING
WE PROJECT REVENUES FOR TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE WILL TOTAL A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION WHICH IS. AN INCREASE OF
THIRTY SIX MILLION OVER THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ATTACK AND
WILL BE- I PUT IN MORE THAN. IT
EXPENDITURES. THAT'S THE FOR MY
ESTIMATE OVERVIEW- WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO ADDRESS THE
LABORATORY CONCERNS OUR- I WOULD
LIKE YOU TO ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA IF WE
CAN ON THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU
OKAY. RIGHT THERE
CONCERNS ON THE AGENDA SENTIFI
THE LABORATORIES RELATED TO
PRENATAL SCREENING- THE FIRST
WORD- THE FIRST BORDERS
PARTICULARLY ASIAN BUT
PROHIBITING ALLOWED FROM
PARTICIPATING- SO IN A MEETING.
AND TO CLARIFY THE FITNESS
PROGRAM IS MORE THAN THAT HAVE
WELCOME AND WE HAVE TO ACTUALLY
CANNOT PERFORM. BUT ANYWAY WITH
OTHER PROVIDERS REPORTER. BUT
HIS BACKGROUND HE PAGE MANDATED
TO APPROVE. WELL AS WELL AS FROM
THE PROGRAM TO ENSURE EQUITY OF
ACCESS AND UTILIZATION. WHAT THE
POPULATION HIGH QUALITY
STANDARDS FOR SCREENING AND
FOLLOW UPS OF. NOT STARTS WITH
THE SPACE BETWEEN EDUCATIONAL
MATERIALS THAT INCLUDE ENTRANCE
BETWEEN THE INSURANCE. AND
ALTHOUGH FUND SUBSEQUENT
REFERRALS FOR FOLLOW UP SERVICES
SUCH AS AN ACCOMPLICE.
REPUBLICAN OFFICIALS UNDERSTAND
HER OPTIONS FOR DIAGNOSTIC. HE
SAID. DECEPTION IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES CALIFORNIA LAW AND
REGULATIONS THAT PROHIBITED- FOR
THE DEFENDING REPERTORY.
OFFERING THE TESTING THAT THE
DENNIS. PROGRAM OFFERED THE NEW
OF A THAT ALL PEOPLE ARE
PROVIDED WITH THE BEST MOST
BECAUSE- AND COMPETENT THE
SCREEN. WITHOUT REGARD TO OUR
REYES BUT FOR SOME OF THE OR
OTHER K. ALL POLL THE- REASON
FOR THE LEGISLATURE. TO CREATE
THE THING WIDE ENOUGH FOR MORE
THAN FIVE AGO. AND SCREAM OUT OF
THE ALL THE OF NEED TO BE RUN
WITH PRINCIPLE. PEOPLE THAT THE
RETURN THE TOWN'S PARK WITHIN
THREE SCREEN PANEL PROTEST.
ENERGIZED STATEWIDE. PROGRAM
WILL REDUCE EQUITABLE. OF
SCREENING FOLLOW UP SERVICES.
AND COMPROMISED THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO MONITOR POPULATIONS
HEALTH. PUTTING ON TO THE SECOND
BULLET THE LABORATORY CONCERNS
AND- THE- ABOUT- MANDATING THAT
ALL HAVE WORK ON BE IN WITHIN
CALIFORNIA- WE OBSERVE PIANOS
PROGRAM WERE APPROACHED BY
SEVERAL LABORATORIES OPERATING
CONDUCTED. YES NAY SERVICES
WITHIN CALIFORNIA SO THERE WAS
NO INDICATION. PROCUREMENTS OR
LAPTOP READING OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE. BEYOND A CLEAR NEED TO
SUPPORT- IF IN A IN THE THROUGH
THE PROPOSED DEVELOPMENTS REMAIN
WITHIN THE STATE. THERE'S ALSO A
RISK BOB THAT SUPPOSED JUSTICE
SHIPPING. AS WELL AS POTENTIALLY
INCREASE TURNAROUND TIMES
IMPROPER. I'M FOR STATE
CONTRACTING ROLES ARE ARE THAT
WOULD BE CONTRACT THE LOWEST
COST POSSIBLE PROVIDE SUCH
SERVICES. MELENDEZ CONCERN WAS
NOW IT IS SHOWING FOR INSTANCE I
THINK IT'S STAKEHOLDERS. I'M FIT
AND REALITIES IN H. ACTUALLY
CONDUCTED OUR FIRST. YOU HAVE
RELATED STAKEHOLDER MEETING IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. WHICH INCLUDED
REPRESENTATIVES FROM
LABORATORIES ACON ANOTHER THAN
THE PRENATAL BIOETHICS
COMMUNITY- WERE INVITED AND
PARTICIPATED IN A DISCUSSION
ABOUT PLANS. IN LABORATORY. THEN
IN. TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE PH SURVEY THAT
THE CANNELLA ALLOWED HIM TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO THE
PIANOS PROGRAM WE'VE GOT A
SERIES OF MEETINGS WITH. THE
FIFTIES AND A LAMP. WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MEET REGULARLY WITH
SERVICE PROVIDERS. RESPONDED TO
QUESTIONS FROM FAMILY MEMBERS
AND OTHERS. FINALLY WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH A CALIFORNIA
PROGRESS UNDER THE BALLOT I'M
GOING TO ELECTRIFY THE
COMMUNICATIONS- EXISTENCE AND
THAT'S PROVIDERS AND OTHER
LIGHT. CONTROL. WE HAVE A
DETAILED QUESTION. NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM CHRISTY FOR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF LABORATORY
ASSOCIATION PLEASE BE IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A MISTER CHAIRMAN
MY NAME IS CHRISTY POINT I'M
HERE AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA CLINICAL
LABORATORY ASSOCIATION OUR
ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN HEARING
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS
WE HAVE AS MEMBERS HOSPITAL
BASED LABS LARGE COMMERCIAL LABS
THAT COVER THE UNITED STATES.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
CLOUDS IN SMALL INDEPENDENT
SPECIALTY LABS I'M HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE PRENATAL
SCREENING PROGRAM AND WE DO HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT'S RECENT PROPOSED
CHANGES TO HOW THE FETAL
CHROMOSOME AVENEL ABNORMALITIES
WILL BE SCREENED. THESE CHANGES
WILL NEGATIVELY IMPACT ACCESS TO
TESTING FOR PREGNANT WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA. EFFECTIVE JULY ONE
OF THIS YEAR THE PRENATAL
SCREENING PROGRAM IS REPLACING
ITS CURRENT TESTING WITH THE
ADVANCED CELL FREE DNA BLOOD
TESTING. THE DEPARTMENT DOES
STATE THAT PARTICIPATION IN THE
STATE SCREENING PROGRAM IS
VOLUNTARY FOR PREGNANT WOMEN
HOWEVER AFTER JULY FIRST
PREGNANT WOMEN WILL NO LONGER
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS MORE
ADVANCED TESTING OUTSIDE OF THE
PROGRAM. THE DEPARTMENT HAS
DECLARED THAT IT WILL BE ILLEGAL
FOR PREGNANT WOMEN TO GET THIS
TESTING DONE AT A LABORATORY
OUTSIDE. SO EVEN THOUGH IT IS
TECHNICALLY VOLUNTARY. A
PREGNANT WOMAN DOES NOT HAVE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM BUT
IF THEY DON'T THEY CANNOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE CELL FREE DNA
TESTING. I DO UNDERSTAND- THAT
THEY HAVE SAID THAT IN THE PAST.
THERE HAVE BEEN LIMITS ON THE
TYPE OF TESTING THAT WAS OFFERED
THROUGH THE PEANUTS PROGRAM
HOWEVER THIS NEW TESTING IS A
CURRENT KIND OF FAR BETTER
APPROACH TO TESTING. AND WE DO
THINK IT'S UNFAIR TO LIMIT THAT
OUTSIDE OF THE PROGRAM. A
PREGNANT WOMEN SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHERE SHE HAS
HER TESTING DONE FOR THIS NEW
TYPE OF PROCEDURE. AND THE OTHER
ISSUE IS THAT WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT LABORATORIES ARE BEING
PROHIBITED NOW IN THIS WAY.
CALIFORNIA LABORATORIES HAVE
BEEN PROVIDING THIS TYPE OF CELL
FREE DNA TESTING FOR MANY YEARS
AND HAVE PERFORMED MILLIONS OF
THESE TESTS. THESE LABORATORIES
HOLD VALID LICENCES ISSUED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ACCREDITATION BY THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA I'M SORRY UNDER THE
CLINICAL LABORATORY IMPROVEMENT
AMENDMENTS OR CLEA. AND
ACCREDITATION BY THE COLLEGE OF
AMERICAN PATHOLOGISTS TO PERFORM
CELL FREE DNA TESTING. AND IN
FACT THE LABORATORIES HAVE BEEN
OPERATING UNDER THESE LICENSES
AND ACCREDITATIONS TO BE
PERFORMING TESTING AND FOLLOW UP
TEST FOR THE DEPARTMENT'S
CURRENT PROGRAM CURRENT PRENATAL
SCREENING PROGRAM. THIS NEW
PROHIBITIN WILL RESTRICT OF
THOSE SAME LABORATORIES HAVE
BEEN PERFORMING THESE TESTS IN
THE PAST. FROM BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO THESE TESTS
OUTSIDE OF THE NEW PROGRAM ONCE
THE TRANSITION TAKES PLACE.
ANOTHER CONCERN WITH THE
PROPOSED TRANSITION IS THAT
LABORATORIES HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT
EVEN THOUGH THEY DO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM. THEY
WOULD HAVE TO GUARANTEE THAT ALL
THE TESTING WOULD BE DONE ONLY
AT ONE OF THEIR LABORATORIES
PHYSICALLY LOCATED IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I'VE BEEN IN I
KNOW THERE WAS MENTIONED THAT
THERE WAS- LABORATORIES WERE
GIVEN THE OPTION. BUT WE DO KNOW
OF SOME LABORATORIES THAT DID
WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM AND WE'RE TOLD THAT THEY
COULD NOT. BECAUSE THEY COULD
NOT GUARANTEE THAT THE TESTING
WOULD BE DONE IN CALIFORNIA OUT
THERE CALIFORNIA SITE. AND THE
REASON THIS IS A CONCERN IS
BECAUSE- A LOT OF CALIFORNIA
LABORATORIES HAVE SPECIALTY
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES. AND THEY HAVE SPECIFIC
TRAINING AND PERSONNEL FOR
DIFFERENT TYPES OF TESTS. BY
CONSOLIDATING THE SPECIALTY
TESTING AT SOME OFTHEIR KEY
LOCATIONS. THE PATIENTS REALLY
DO GET THE BEST IN CLASS SERVICE
AT THAT LOCATION. THERE IS NO
BENEFIT TO THE PATIENT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO RESTRICT WHERE THE
TEST IS PHYSICALLY PROCESS.
THERE WAS MENTION THAT THERE WAS
CONCERN THAT THERE BE LOST
SPECIMENS. OR INCREASE THE TURN
AROUND TIME BUT REALLY- WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SHOW THAT THE
LABORATORY INDUSTRY. HAS REALLY
DONE A GOOD JOB- IN REGARD TO
ALL OF THE TRANSACTIONS AND-
THERE ARE VERY FEW SPECIMENS
THAT ARE LOST. IN THE TURN
AROUND TIME IS REALLY IMPROVED I
MEAN AS YOU KNOW WHEN YOU ORDER
SOMETHING ON. AMAZON YOU CAN
PRETTY MUCH GET IT THE NEXT DAY
EVEN IF IT'S ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND ALL OF THOSE LOGISTICS THAT
LABORATORIES HAVE DEVELOPED
SPECIALLY DURING COVERT- TO
EXPAND CAPACITY THEY REALLY.
HAVE GOTTEN IT DOWN ON BEING
ABLE TO PROCESS THESE SAMPLES
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE. AND THEN
THERE ARE ALSO SOME ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSED
TRANSITION BUT WE WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THE MOST IMPORTANT
ONES DURING THE LIMITED TIME WE
HAVE TODAY. BUT THESE OTHER
ISSUES DO NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
BEFORE THIS PROGRAM TRANSITION
TAKES PLACE. I AM I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN MENTION OF SOME MEETINGS IN
TWENTY NINETEEN BUT REALLY THOSE
WERE A LOT MORE LIMITED AND
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF CHANGES
THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE SINCE THEN
A LOT MORE INFORMATION THAT HAS
COME OUT. AND SO REALLY- THE
ISSUE IS THAT THERE'S NOT BEEN
ENOUGH PUBLIC A COMMENTER PUBLIC
INPUT. OF PHYSICIANS WHO WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING THE
PROGRAM. AND THE PATIENTS WHO
MATERNAL FETAL KERR IS DICTATED
BY THESE TESTS. HAVE NOT REALLY
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD.
OTHERS BEEN SPECIFIC GROUPS
INVITED TO THESE MEETINGS BUT
IT'S NOT BEEN AN OPEN PUBLIC
PROCESS. SO WE'RE ASKING FOR A
PUBLIC HEARING TO BE HELD TO
ADDRESS THE MANY PUBLIC POLICY
CONCERNS. IN REGARD TO THE
TRANSITION OF THIS PROGRAM. AND
I REALLY DO THINK IF WE WORK
TOGETHER WE CAN FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE IMPORTANT UPDATE. WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING PATIENT ACCESS TO
THIS NEW TESTING. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CAREFULLY REVIEW
THE PROPOSAL. AND MAKE ANY
AMENDMENTS TO PROTECT PUBLIC
ACCESS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
GIVING THE TIME TO SPEAK ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSU AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU I'M GOING TO BEGIN
WITH MR ONLY I WAS HOPING YOU
COULD COMMENT AND RESPONSE-
SPECIFICALLY HOW IS IT DIFFERENT
THAN NOW. WHAT HAS OCCURRED- ARE
ARE WE LIMITING CHOICES- TO
THOSE WHO ARE PARTICIPATING IN
OUR PROGRAM TODAY BEFORE THIS
PROPOSAL OR- IS THAT CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT THE STATE'S DONE IN
THE PAST. WELL AS I MENTIONED
I'M NOT FOR THE PAST THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. ALL OF PRENATAL SCREENING
HAS BEEN DONE THROUGH THE STATE
PROGRAM. IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES THE INCEPTION OF THE
PROGRAM AND THEN DEVELOP THAT'S
THE WAY LAWS REGULATIONS. THAT
WOULD HAVE MANDATED SCREENING
DONE. AND HAVE READING- CHANGED
OVER THE YEARS- ANALYTES HAVE
BEEN ADDED OTHER CHANGES HAVE
OCCURRED WITH PRENATAL SCREENING
THE PROGRAM HAS ADAPTED THOSE
CHANGES. AND WE SEE THE ADOPTION
OF THE DNA OF. THE ANOTHER
CHANGE IN TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
BECAUSE WE'VE DONE OVER THE
YEARS- THAT WOULD YOU WOULD-
KERRY OUT AS AMENDED AS A STATE
WIDE- BROWN THE- BUT STILL
VOLUNTARY BUT- THE WE ARE.
OBLIGATED TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
THE LAST FORMING THE SCREENING
ARE DOING SO IN THE END- TO
CONFORM FASHION SO THAT THERE IS
EQUITY IN THEM THE WAY IT
PROVIDED AS TO WHETHER THERE
WOULD BE CHOICE- THERE WILL BE
MULTIPLE LAYOUTS CONTRACTED FROM
SCREENING INFO- THERE'S NO
SHORTAGE OF- CHOICES FOR- UP TO
TWO. SCREENING FOR TRISOMY.
TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN. COULD I MAY
FOLLOW UP THEN IF I CAN- EARLIER
YOU SAID IT WAS BEST IN CLASS
SERVICE AND THAT THERE WAS NO
BENEFITS TO THE PATIENT FOR THE-
POLICY THAT'S BEING PROMOTED
HERE- I'M I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE BENEFIT FOR THIS.
DATE TO EMPLOYING. PEOPLE
OUTSIDE OF OUR STATE WITH PUBLIC
DOLLARS AND I'M HOPING YOU CAN
COMMENT ON. WHERE THE BENEFIT
FOR US IS A SYSTEM TO SENDING
THOSE RESOURCES OUT OF STATE.
YEAH EFFORTS TO CIVICALLY FOR
THAT OUT OF STATE PROCESS- AND
THAT REALLY IS JUST. BECAUSE OUR
LABORATORIES- HAVE MULTIPLE
LOCATON SO THEY'LL HAVE A
PHYSICAL LOCATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WHERE THEY DO SOME
OF THE TESTING BUT IT HAS TO DO
WITH THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
TESTING THEY MIGHT HAVE MAYBE A
MODERATE COMPLEXITY TESTING
LABORATORY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
BUT THEN THEY HAVE A HIGH
COMPLEXITY TESTING LOCATED
SOMEWHERE ELSE MAYBE IN UTAH OR
NEVADA. AND IT MAY JUST BE FOR
PERSONAL REASONS OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT AND SO REALLY IT'S
JUST THE PRESIDENT OF THE STATE
TELLING LABORATORIES WHERE WHICH
TYPE OF TESTING CAN BE DONE AT
EACH OTHER FACILITIES THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT. BECAUSE WE DO THINK THAT
IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAT THE
TESTING IS DONE. YOU KNOW AT A
THE FACILITY THAT HAD THE PROPER
OBVIOUSLY PERSONNEL IN- THE
PROPER RESOURCES. AND IT JUST
LIMITS THE OPTIONS FOR THE STATE
AND SO IF THE STATE. WANTS TO
HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
LABORATORIES THAT CAN PERFORM
THIS TESTING WE JUST THINK IT'S
LIMITING TO TELL THOSE
LABORATORIES. THIS SPECIFIC YOU
KNOW ANY PARTICULAR TYPE OF TEST
HAS TO BE DONE ONLY GOT ONE OF
YOUR FACILITIES THAT'S LOCATED
IN STATE. MARYLAND I'LL TURN THE
QUESTION AS WHETHER OR NOT WE
HAVE THE CAPACITY WITH THE-
LABORATORIES WHO WOULD DO THIS
AND STATE TO DEAL WITH THE
VOLUME OF TESTING THAT'S
REQUIRED HOPING- YOU CAN COMMENT
ON THAT MISTRAL. YES CERTAINLY-
THE LABORATORIES THAT HAVE
APPLIED TO CONTRACT WITH THE
STATE- HAVE INDICATED THAT THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO ALL OF
THE THIRTY SECOND ST- ELLSWORTH
REQUIRE WITH OUR INITIAL-
REQUIRED OF THEM SO- WE BELIEVE
THAT. THERE ARE SEVERAL
LABORATORIES IN THE LABORATORIES
THAT ARE CAPABLE AND HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO. ALL THE. BUT A
TEACHER. I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUED- COMMENTARY AND- THE
INFORMATION ON THIS BUT WITH
THAT I WILL THANKS VERY MUCH
THIS PANEL WE WILL NOW PRESENT
ON ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY. THANK
YOU. I THINK SELDOM FROM
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH WHAT
DIVISION IN THE WAKE NOVEMBER
ESTIMATE THERE IS NO GENERAL
FUND INCLUDED FEATHER WITH
PROGRAMS WELL WE HAVE ENOUGH
FEDERAL FUNDS TO COVER FOOD
LOCAL SERVICES. AND STATE
OPERATIONS EXPENDITURES. AFTER
MY BRIEF THE SPIDEY IN FOOD
EXPENDITURES FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR AS A RESULT OF TWO KEY
FACTORS. FIRST AFTER THE SLIGHT
DECREASE IN PROJECTED
PARTICIPATION UP TO THE IN THE
CURRENT YEAR TO NINE HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS
EACH ONE. OF THAT IS A SLIGHT
DECREASE FROM NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS LAST YEAR
THAT WE ARE STILL MUCH HIGHER
THAN PRE PANDEMIC LEVEL OF ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
BUDGET SPENDS EACH MONTH. THE
SECOND FACTOR IS THE COSTS PER
PARTICIPANT. THERE WAS A SLIGHT
DECREASE AND ACTUAL COST PER
PARTICIPANT. IN THE PRIOR YEAR
WHICH IMPACTS OUR EXPENDITURE
PROJECTIONS FOR CURRENT AND
BUDGET YEAR. THE DECREASE IN THE
CURRENT YEAR IS OFFSET BY AN
INCREASE IN BRITAIN BATCH
VEGETABLE BENEFITS WHICH BEGAN
IN JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND CONTINUE THROUGH THE END OF
THIS MONTH AS PART OF FEDERAL
CONTINUING RESOLUTIONS. THE
FRUIT AND VEGETABLE INCREASE WAS
INCLUDED IN THE RECENTLY SIGNED
FEDERAL BUDGET SO IT WILL NOW
CONTINUE THROUGH SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND THEREFORE
WE WILL MAKE THAT UPDATE IN THE
MAY BE BEST. THANK YOU. ANY
QUESTIONS THE NOVEMBER ASPECTS.
I'M I ONLY HAVE ONE SO FIRST OFF
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION FOR CONTINUING
THAT UNTIL SEPTEMBER THAT WILL
GO A LONG WAY TOWARDS ADDRESSING
FOOD INSECURITY ON PAGE-
SEVENTY. FIVE OF THE AGENDA
TALKS ABOUT FOOD EXPENDITURE
ESTIMATE AND ON IT IT SAID THAT
THERE WAS A DECREASE. IN COSTS
DUE TO A DECREASE IN FOOD
INFLATION AND THAT FLIES IN THE
FACE OF WHAT MANY OF US ARE.
FEELING AND AWARE ABOUT
REGARDING CONSUMER PRICES
OVERALL THE FOOD BEING INCLUDED
IN IT BUT I WAS HOPING YOU COULD
ELABORATE ON WHETHER OR NOT WE
NEED IS THERE AN OUTDATED- HOW
IS IT NOT REFLECTING THE RECENT
SIGNIFICANT INFLATION IN FOOD
PRICES THAT MANY OF US ARE
FEELING. SEVEN NOVEMBER ESTIMATE
WAS CALCULATED. PROBABLY
FINALIZE IN ABOUT SEPTEMBER AND
THEN THERE'S NOT NECESSARILY A
DECREASE IN THE INFLATION BUT A
SMALLER RATE OF INFLATION THAT
WHAT WE HAD PREVIOUSLY INCLUDED
AND SO ANY CHANGE IN SOMETHING
CENTS SEPTEMBER AND AN INFLATION
RATE SINCE THEN WILL BE
ADDRESSED THEY COULDN'T NAY
REVISION. I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
I JUST WAS TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
IF IT WAS OUTDATED AND SO- WITH
THAT I WILL THANK YOU AND WE
WILL NOW PRESENT ON ISSUE.
TWENTY ONE. I HAVE AS WELL- THE
ECG OF REQUESTS A THIRTY FOR
TWENTY FIVE PERMANENT POSITIONS
TO CONTINUE SUPPORT OF WHICH
NEARLY IMPLEMENTED ELECTS AND
SYSTEMS STATE GENERAL FUNDS ARE
NOT BEING REQUESTED THESE
POSITIONS WILL BE FUNDED BY THE
EXISTING FEDERAL WAY GRANTS.
WITH THE SUCCESS IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE NEW YORK SYSTEMS
INCLUDING THE ELECT CARD AND ITS
COMPANION THE CALIFORNIA WENT
OUT. THE NEED FOR CUSTOMER
SERVICE TO WORK FAMILIES AND
LOCAL AGENCY STAFF HAS INCREASED
IN ADDITION YOU WORK SYSTEMS
WILL REQUIRE REGULAR UPDATES AND
CONTINUOUS QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE VARIOUS TECHNOLOGIES AND
SERVICES. THESE PERMITS POSITION
ARE RELIANCE ON TEMPORARY
CONTRACTORS WILL DECREASE. IN
ADDITION TO EXPANDING CUSTOMER
SERVICE AUTHORIZATION OF THESE
POSITIONS WHILE ENABLE US TO
EXPAND THE USE OF VAST
QUANTITIES OF NEW DATA. TO
IDENTIFY AND ANALYZE TRENDS AND
ANOMALIES TO TARGET THOSE IN
NEED AND WHAT SERVICES TO
IMPROVE THE PUBLIC FAMILY
EXPERIENCE AND TO ENHANCE
PROGRAM INTEGRITY BY PREVENTING
DETECTING AND RESPONDING TO
FRAUDULENT OR ABUSIVE ACTIVITY.
IN ADDITION TO THESE NEW
POSITIONS WOULD HAVE ALL THREE
DIRECTED INTERNAL VACANCIES IN
STAFF TO SUPPORT ONGOING POST
EVEN IMPLEMENTATION WORK. AND
FOR CONTEXT- TO DATE SINCE
LAUNCHING OUR PILOTS IN JUNE OF
TWENTY NINETEEN. WE HAVE ISSUED
A NEARLY ONE POINT TWO MILLION
CARDS AND ARE CURRENTLY ITCHING
ABOUT SIX THOUSAND NEW CARDS
EACH WEEK. WE HAVE HAD THIRTY
SEVEN MILLION TRANSACTION OF THE
NEW WHAT CARD IT AUTHORIZED
OVERS M. WE ARE NOW CURRENTLY
SEEMING ABOUT RECEIVING OUR
SEEMS HE'S ME ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
TRANSACTIONS EACH WEEK SO VERY
BUSY. I'M ISSUING CARDS- SETTING
UP FAMILIES TO USE THE NEW
CALIFORNIA WORK ACT AND
SUPPORTING TRANSACTIONS. EVERY
WEEK THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU I- ONE OF THIS PROGRAM AND-
INNOVATE. THE DATA POINTS IN THE
AGENDA ON PAGE SEVENTY SIX SAYS
THAT 95% OF WORK FAMILIES HAVE
REPORTED SATISFACTION THAT THEY
FOUND THIS TO BE BOTH CONVENIENT
AND SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
STIGMA ASSOCIATED WITH THAT. I
JUST WANTED TO UPLIFTED TO MAKE
SURE YOU FELT THE APPRECIATION
FOR OUR- IMPLEMENTATION WILL NOT
- WITH. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND IF WE CAN PLEASE PRESENT
ON ISSUE TWENTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY. MY
NAME IS DIANE WEDNESDAY AND I'M
THE DIVISION CHIEF FOR MATERNAL
CHILD ADOLESCENT HEALTH AND THE
CENTER FOR FAMILY HEALTH. I'LL
BE PRESENTING- ISSUE TWENTY TWO
ON THE CALIFORNIA HOME VISITING
PROGRAM. PUBLIC HEALTH REQUESTS
NINETEEN POINT SEVEN FIVE
POSITIONS AND THIRTY SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION FROM GENERAL FUND
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TO.
TWENTY THREE AND I'M GOING TO
EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA HOME
VISITING PROGRAM. MANY MORE
FAMILIES WILL BENEFIT FROM AN
EXPANSION OF HOME VISITING
SERVICES CDPH CURRENTLY SERVES
ABOUT THREE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED FAMILIES ANNUALLY. IF
APPROVED WE PLAN TO DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF FAMILIES CURRENTLY
SIR. I'M VISITING HAS DECADES OF
RESEARCH DEMONSTRATING A RETURN
ON INVESTMENT OF UP TO FIVE
DOLLARS AND SEVENTY CENTS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR SPENT ON SERVICE.
PLEASE LET ME KNOW IF I CAN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FOR YOU.
THANK YOU I'M A HUGE FAN OF THIS
PROGRAM HAVING AUTHORED
LEGISLATION AND WORKED IN THE
SPACE FOR YEARS AND LOVE HEARING
ABOUT. US HAVING THE ABILITY TO
DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF FAMILIES
THAT HAVE BEEN SERVED I WOULD
ALSO POINT TOWARDS THE INITIAL
EVALUATION BEING DONE BY UCSF
SHOWING SOME VERY POSITIVE
RESULTS OF THIS PROGRAM. AND
ANTICIPATE US BEING ABLE TO
EXTEND THOSE POSITIVE RESULTS TO
MORE FAMILIES. WANT TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS WE WILL NOW
ASK IF WE CAN PERCENT ON ISSUE
TWENTY THREE. OKAY I'LL BE
PRESENTING ON ISSUE TWENTY THREE
AS WELL. CDPH THE BLACK INFANT
HEALTH PROGRAM. ASSEMBLY PH IS
REQUESTING TWELVE POINT FIVE
MILLION IN STATE GENERAL FUND
AND SEVEN POINT TWO FIVE
PERMANENT POSITIONS IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
I'M GOING TO FURTHER EXPAND THE
BLACK INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM.
THIS MONEY WILL ALLOW FOR THE
BLACK INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM
EXPANSION INTO AREAS NOT
CURRENTLY BEING SERVED AND WILL
PROVIDE FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT BATES
TO EXPAND THEIR CASELOAD.
CURRENTLY THE BLACK INFANT
HEALTH PROGRAMS ARE ESTABLISHED
IN THIRTEEN COUNTIES AT
SEVENTEEN PROGRAM SITES COVERING
APPROXIMATELY 90% OF WERE BLACK
BIRTHS OCCUR. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THE PH HAS SERVED NINE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED BLACKBURN
THING PEOPLE. THANK YOU PLEASE
LET ME KNOW IF I CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS- ON THE PROPOSAL ON
PAGE- EIGHTY IT SAID HAT WE
WILL ADD COUNTIES WERE POCKETS
OF NEEDS EXIST I WAS HOPING TO
SEE WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS
POSSIBLE FOR US TO SEE MAPPING
OF THOSE NEEDS ACROSS THE STATE
IN TERMS OF THE HIGHEST RATES
OF. BLACK INFANT MORTALITY. WELL
I DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION IN
FRONT OF ME RIGHT NOW BUT I'D BE
HAPPY TO GET BACK TO WHAT. I
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT AND JUST TO
I'M ALWAYS WANTING TO MAKE SURE
WERE- PROVIDING RESOURCES TO THE
COMMUNITIES WITH THE GREATEST
NEEDS AND- WOULD APPRECIATE THAT
MAP WHEN IT IS AVAILABLE.
CORRECT IT'S NOT. WITH THAT I
WILL THANK THIS ENTIRE SEVENTH
PANEL WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
PANEL EIGHT- WHICH IS ON ISSUE
TWENTY SIX TO EMPLOYMENT AB
THREE AT THE END OF LIFE ACT WE
WILL HAVE ONE PRESENTER ON THIS
PANEL WHICH WILL BE DOWN- DATA
MORE DEPUTY DIRECTOR. AT THE
CENTER FOR HEALTH STATISTICS AND
IN FOR AN FOR MATIX AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH CAN YOU PLEASE BEGIN. YES
CAN AFTERNOON THATI THINK YOUR
TERM WILL LET AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND- CDPH REQUESTS ONE
POSITION AND GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND A HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER. TO MANAGE
AN INCREASE IN PROCESSING THE
END OF LIFE ACT DOCUMENTS DUE TO
REDUCED WAITING CARRIED BETWEEN
INITIAL AND FINAL REQUESTS
IMPLEMENTED BY SB THREE EIGHTY.
BASICALLY CDPH REQUESTS ONE
ASSOCIATE GOVERNMENT PROGRAM
ANALYST. THAT WOULD PROVIDE
GENERAL ASSISTANCE TO MEDICAL
PROVIDERS ON SUBMISSION OF END
OF LIFE ACT FORMS. THEY WOULD
MONITOR THE END OF LIFE ACT
COLLECTS THE AND ANALYZE THE
FORMS FROM PROVIDERS PERFORM
DATABASE ENTRY MAINTAIN
CONFIDENTIAL DOCUMENTS AND DATA
BASE AND UPDATE AND MAINTAIN THE
END OF LIFE ACT WEBSITE. IN
ADDITION CDPH REQUEST
EXPENDITURE FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. PARTS
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SERVICES
DIVISION IN TERMS OF THE FINAL
APPLICATION FORM PERMITS WEB
BASED PORTAL AND UPDATE THE
INTERPRETER FORM WITH GENDER
NEUTRAL LANGUAGE. AB X. FIFTEEN
EGGMAN CHAPTER ONE STATUTES OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN SECOND
EXTRAORDINARY SESSION ESTABLISH
THE END OF LIFE ACT WHICH
AUTHORIZES AN INDIVIDUAL WITH
THE CAPACITY TO MAKE MEDICAL
DECISIONS AND WITH A TERMINAL
DISEASE TO REQUEST AID IN DYING
DRUGS. IF THE FOLLOWING
CONDITIONS ARE SATISFIED. THE
CONDITIONS DIAGNOSED THAT
INDIVIDUAL THE TERMINAL DISEASE
THE INDIVIDUAL HA VOLUNTARILY
EXPRESSED A WISH TO RECEIVE AID
IN DYING DRUGS. I INDIVIDUALS A
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA.
INDIVIDUALS WITH PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL ABILITY TO SELF
ADMINISTER THE EVEN BUYING DRUGS
THE INDIVIDUAL DOCUMENTS HIS OR
HER REQUEST BY SUBMITTING TWO
ORAL REQUESTS THE MINIMUM OF
FIFTEEN DAYS APART. IN A WRITTEN
REQUEST TO HIS OR HER POSITION.
IT ALSO REQUIRES THAT
INDIVIDUALS POSITION TO SUBMIT
TO CDPH THE DOCUMENTATION OF THE
END OF LIFE ACT PROCESS
INCLUDING THE INDIVIDUALS
WRITTEN REQUEST FOR AID IN DYING
DRUGS. AND ASSOCIATED POSITION
TRACKLIST FOLLOW UP AND OTHER
COMPLIANCE DOCUMENTS. CDPH IS
ALSO REQUIRED TO ANNUALLY REPORT
CERTAIN INFORMATION ON HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE AID IN DYING
DRUGS HOW MANY DIED AND THE
CAUSE OF DEATH. THE NUMBER OF
POSITIONS PROVIDING AID OF DYING
PRESCRIPTIONS AND VARIOUS
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION IS ALSO
COLLECTED. IN ADDITION CDPH IS
REQUIRED TO MAKE AVAILABLE THE
POSITION COMPLIANCE AND FOLLOW
UP DOCUMENTS ON ITS WEBSITE. SB
THREE EIGHTY IT SHORTENS THE
TIME BETWEEN ORAL REQUEST FOR
AIDS AND DYING DRUGS. IT AMENDS
THE END OF LIFE OPTION ACT BY
ALLOWING AN INDIVIDUAL TO
QUALIFY FOR EVEN TRYING DRUGS BY
REITERATING THE WORLD REQUEST
AFTER FORTY EIGHT HOURS RATHER
THAN FIFTEEN DAYS. THE S. B. SB
THREE EIGHTY ALSO ELIMINATES THE
FINAL AT THE STATION REPORT
REQUIRED TO BE FILLED OUT BY THE
INDIVIDUAL WITHIN FORTY EIGHT
HOURS SOUTH OF MINISTERING THE
AID IN DYING MEDICATION. AS WELL
AS INCLUDING GENDER NEUTRAL
LANGUAGE IN THE INTERPRETER FORM
SUBMITTED BY CDPH ACCORDING TO
CDPH THE CERTAIN TIME PERIOD
AFTER THE INITIAL REQUEST IS
LIKELY TO RESULT IN AN INCREASE
OF END OF LIFE ACT REPORTING
FORMS RECEIVEDBY THE
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK PANEL EIGHT
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
FINAL PANEL OF THE DAY WHICH
WILL COVER THE ESTIMATE AND TO
PROPOSALS. FOR THE CENTER FOR
HEALTH CARE QUALITY. WE WILL
HAVE ONE PRESENTER CASEY DONOVAN
WHO IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR. AT
THE CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE
QUALITY AT CDPH- LET US BEGIN
WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON THAT EVENING
I GOT TODAY- MY NAME IS KATHY
DONOVAN THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE QUALITY.
FEEDS THE KIDS RESPONSIBLE FOR
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT OF LIFE AND
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES AND
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS- THAT
ASSESSMENT TO LIVE WE ASSESS AND
THE DELIVERY OF HEALTH CARE FOR
QUALITY AND SAFETY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. EIGHT SIX YEAR
PROPELLED THE THROWBACK
CONDUCTING PERIODIC INSPECTIONS
AND COMPLAINT INVESTIGATIONS OF
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES AND
PROVIDER AGENCIES TO DETERMINE
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL AND
STATE LAWS AND REGULATIONS. DO
YOU THINK YOU LICENSE AND
CERTIFIES OVER THIRTEEN THOUSAND
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES AND
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA IN THIRTY
DIFFERENT LIFE INSURANCE
CERTIFICATION CATEGORY. THANK
YOU EVALUATE HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES FOR COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL REGULATIONS UNDER A
GRANT BUT THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICAID AND MEDICARE MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID SERVICES AS WELL AS
SURVEYS- FACILITIES FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW AND
STATE REGULATION. AS NOTED IN
THE AGNDA SUMMARY SPEECH SECURE
CONTRACTS WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. TWO THIRTY AM CERTIFIED
HELP FACILITIES THAT ARE LOCATED
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE AMOUNT
OF THE L. A. COUNTY CONTRACT FOR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. IS ONE
HUNDRED AND SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION. IN ADDITION FIFTY Q.
OVERSEES THE CERTIFICATION OF
NURSES AND- HOME HEALTH AIDE.
AND HEMATOLOGIST TECHNICIAN AND
A LICENSING OF NURSING HOME
ADMINISTRATORS. MAJORITY OF
SPEECH FIXTURES ACTIVITIES ARE
SUPPORTED BY LICENSING FEES
COLLECTED FROM THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES. THAT WE OVERSEE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. BEFORE I
PROCEED WITH THE PRESENTATION OF
AGE SIX YEARS P. FIFTEEN THE
COMMITTEE DID ASK FOR AN UPDATE
ON THE STATUS- OF CCGS COMPLAINT
WORKLOAD- TO THE CURRENT UPDATE
ADDS A QUARTER ONE OF FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. 61%
OF LONG TERM CARE COMPLAINTS ARE
BEING COMPLETED WITHIN THE SIXTY
DAY STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS. I'LL
ADD THAT OVER 96% AND IMMEDIATE
JEOPARDY CAME THIRD HAVE BEEN
INITIATED TIMELY. AND PRIOR TO
THE ONSET OF COKE MIGHT COME IN
1972% OF THE LONG TERM CARE
COMPLAINTS WERE BEING COMPLETED
TIMELY. AT THE DIRECTION OF
STATE AND FEDERAL GUIDANCE. FROM
THE NINETEEN IT SAYS THAT YOU
DID A CHANGE OF FOCUS TO
INFECTION PREVENTION AND
IMMEDIATE JEOPARDY CASES WHICH
RESULTED IN COMPLAINTS OF LOWER
RISK TO BE TEMPORARILY DELAYED.
SINCE THE LIFTING UP THAT
DIRECTION THE H. TWO Q. HAS
THREE OF THEM THAT COMMITMENT TO
RESOLVING H. COMPLAINT. PAGE
SICK YOU HAD MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS TO REDUCE THE SIZE OF
THE COMPLAINT AND FACILITY
REPORTED INCIDENT BACKLOG. BY
DEVELOPING LEAN PROCESS MAPS
THAT BUNDLE INVESTIGATION AND
STREAMLINED AND KICK STREAMLINED
EFFORT TO CLOSE ORDER INTAKE.
SINCE APRIL ONE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE CCQ HAS RESOLVED 70% OF THE
COMPLAINT BACKLOG THAT EXISTED
AT THAT TIME EXCLUDING MEDICAL
INFORMATION BREACHES. STATE
THANK YOU PLAN TO MAINTAIN AND
BUILD UPON THE SUCCESS WE HAVE
ACHIEVED SO FAR AND REMAINS
FOCUSED ON RESOLVING AND REMAIN
THE REMAINING COMPLAINT AND
FACILITY REPORTED AND THAT
BACKLOG. I'D LIKE TO PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT- TASK FOR ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. I'M I'M
LOOKING AT PAGE ONE OH FOUR OF
THE AGENDA AND GIVEN ALL THAT
WE'VE LEARNED FROM THE PANDEMIC
REGARDING INFECTIOUS DISEASE IN
NURSING HOMES ARE TWO POSITIONS
AND FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
ANYWHERE NEAR ENOUGH. RESOURCES
TO TRULY MAKE THE TWELVE HUNDRED
NURSING HOMES WE HAVE AND
CALIFORNIA SAFE. SO I WILL SHARE
THAT- FROM THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC WE DID RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR
INFECTION CONTROL AND
INTERVENTION AND EDUCATION
BEYOND THE ACUTE CARE SETTING.
AND REALLY REACHING INTO LONG
TERM CARE SETTING IN KHAGARIA
SETTING- THROUGHOUT THE LAST FEW
YEARS- IN ADDITION TO OUR HEALTH
CARE ASSOCIATED INFECTIONS
PROGRAMS THAT- DID PROVIDE A LOT
OF THAT EDUCATION WE DID-
TEMPORARILY REDIRECT- SOME OF
OUR- FACILITY SURVEYORS. DURING
THE SUSPENSION OF OUR REGULARS
SURVEY WORKLOAD TO AUGMENT THAT
THE HEALTH CARE SAID THAT
INSPECTION TEAM AND BECOME THE
END SECTION PREVENTION
SPECIALIST THAT ALSO PROVIDED
EDUCATION TO OUR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES SO. BETWEEN THE TIME
THE TEAM THAT WE ALREADY HAD-
AND THE ADDITIONAL THIRTY TO
THIRTY FIVE- SURVEYORS THAT WE
BUILT THE EXPERTISE WITH OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS WE'VE MADE
SIGNIFICANT. IMPROVEMENTS AND
PROGRESS IN EDUCATING THE LONG
TERM CARE PROVIDERS AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO PROVIDE
CONSULTATION TO- SIBLING
DEPARTMENT- AND THOSE FACILITIES
THAT ARE REGULATED BY THE-
ENTITIES- LIKE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES ANOTHER DEPARTMENT SO I
THINK THAT- GOING IN A. LONGER
TERM INTO THE FUTURE- WILL BE
YOU KNOW LOOKING AT WAYS TO MORE
EFFICIENT TO LIVE AND- INFECTION
CONTROL- MITIGATION MEASURES-
WE'VE ALSO ROLLED OUT- PLAN
ONLINE TRAINING PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES FOR FREE EDUCATIONAL
TRAINING. FOR CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANT AT WORK IN LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES- AND THAT HAS
MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING
THE EDUCATION AND THE TOWARD THE
UP TO THE PEOPLE THAT NEED TO BE
EXERCISING AND FOLLOWING THOSE
PROTOCOLS. I LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT CONVERSATION I BELIEVE
DOCTOR WOULD AND I BOTH SHARE AN
INTEREST IN ENSURING THAT WE
ARE. PROTECTING OUR VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS THAT ARE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND WOULD
WANT TO ENGAGE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO APPROPRIATELY
RIGHT SIZE THIS PROPOSAL SO THAT
WE ALL HAVE THAT CONFIDENCE
NECESSARY. THAT WE'RE DOING ALL
WE CAN FOR- OUR ELDERS WHO ARE
AND SNAPS UP. WITH THAT I WILL
THANK YOU AND ASK YOU TO PLEASE
PRESENT ON ISSUE THIRTY FIVE.
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT ISSUE
THIRTY FIVE- ADDRESSES THAT THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY CONTRACT- DPH
IS REQUESTING EXPENDITURE OF
FORTY- FROM THE LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FIND. AT
EIGHTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
ANNUALLY- TO EXTEND AND AUGMENT
THE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
FACILITY CERTIFICATION CONTRACT
WITH R. L. A. COUNTY PARTNERS.
IN PUBLIC HEALTH- TO ACCOUNT FOR
UPDATED INDIRECT COSTS AND
EMPLOYEE BENEFIT RATE PERSONNEL
COSTS AT LEAST. IT'S EXTENSION
WILL ALLOW TIME FOR L. A. COUNTY
BETWEEN LOS ANGELES TO READ
THEM- CONDUCTING LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION SERVICE MUCH LIKE
THE H. TWO Q. WILL BE DOING. AND
ALLOW THE PH TO STRUCTURE THE
NEXT THREE YEAR CONTRACT ON
MEASURABLE PERFORMANCE METRICS
PANDEMIC. THIS IS A ONE YEAR
EXTENSION- FOR US TO ALLOW
OPPORTUNITY FOR L. A. COUNTY TO
RE ENGAGE- INDOS MEASURABLE AND
PERFORMANCE METRICS AND THEN
TAKE THOSE FORWARD. INTO THE
NEXT THREE YEAR CONTRACT. I'M
GONNA DO AGAIN A LITTLE ON THIS
IS IN A- FOR THE LATENESS OF THE
HOUR CAN YOU PLEASE COMPARE HOW
LA COUNTY'S PROGRAM. COMPARES TO
THE STATE PROGRAM TO THE REST OF
THE STATE TERMS OF REIMBURSEMENT. SO BUT SENSUAL COUNTY WITH
REGARD TO- A SALARIES THEIR
SALARIES ARE SAMPLES WITH THE
COUNTY- WHICH IS SEPARATE AND
DISTINCT FROM- SALARY- RATE. FOR
ST SOUTH AND THEN WITH REGARD Q.
AND REIMBURSEMENT AND FUNDING
FOR THOSE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
PART PERFORMED BY L. A. COUNTY
PARTNERS THERE IS THEN- ON
AUGMENTED SPEED THAT IS CHARGED-
SPECIFICALLY TO FACILITIES IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY- THE HIGHER
COST ST- OPERATING IN THAT AREA.
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY. THE COST OF
LIVING INCREASE- I NEED FO
ENHANCED RATES FOR THOSE
FACILITIES- FOR THE OVERSIGHT AT
THAT WORK. NUMBER LET ME THEN
ASK THE QUESTION EXPLICITLY DO
THE EMPLOYEES FOR ELLIE COUNTY
GET HIGHER WAGES THAN THE STATE
EMPLOYEES. SALARY RATE OR L. A.
COUNTY- INDIVIDUAL BETTER
PERFORMING THE WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE DEPARTMENT- DO YOU RECEIVE A
HIGHER SALARY THAN AND STATE
STAFF YES SO SHOULDN'T PEOPLE
WITH THE SAME JOB GET PAID THE
SAME AMOUNT REGARDLESS OF WHERE
IN THE STATE THEY LIVE AND WORK.
AND IF IT'S JUSTIFIED THAT BY A
HIGHER COST OF LIVING IN LA THEN
CERTAINLY STATE EMPLOYEES WHO
ARE IN SAN FRANCISCO SHOULD GET
EVEN HIGHER WAGES DO THEY- OUR
DEPARTMENT THAT THE STATE DOES
HAVE A- GEOGRAPHIC AUGMENTATION
OR- SALARY- AND REIMBURSEMENT.
FOR STATE STAFF- THAT WORK IN
HIGH COST AREAS- IT IT IS NOT
DIRECTLY- COMPARE A BULL- AT AT
THAT EXACT AMOUNT- FOR L. A.
COUNTY- AGAIN THESE ARE. NO
SALARY THAT ARE NEGOTIATED
THROUGH THE LABOR PROCESS
BETWEEN BEING STATE EMPLOYEES-
VERSUS COUNTY EMPLOYEES- I'D BE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE MORE DETAIL ON
WHAT THE DIFFERENCES ARE BETWEEN
THE SALARY- IF THAT WOULD BE. IN
A HELPFUL INFORMATION IT WOULD I
THINK I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
IF THERE'S A BASIC FAIRNESS.
ISSUE HERE IS THE CONTRACT WITH
L. A. COUNTY TAKING RESOURCES
AWAY FROM THE REST OF THE STATE.
AND IDEALLY MANY OF US LOOK
TOWARDS THE RATES THEY HAVE AN
L. A. COUNTY AND WANT TO BE
UPLIFTED TOWARDS WHERE THEY ARE
TO ENSURE WE CAN BOTH BE
COMPETITIVE AND- RECRUITING AND
RETAINING THE BEST TALENT AND
NOT. ONLY HAVING IT BE IN LA.
AND SO- WOULD APPRECIATE THAT
FOLLOW UP AND WITH THAT I WILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL OF THOSE
WITHIN THIS PANEL AS WELL AS ALL
OF OUR PANELISTS WHO WERE HERE
TODAY- WE HAVE CURRENTLY A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
WOULD LIKE. TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND THEREFORE I WANT TO
URGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
BRIEF SO THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM
EVERYONE. WE WILL START WITH IN
PERSON PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE
HEARING ROOM IF ANYONE WOULD
LIKE TO COME FORWARD- WITH THAT
WE WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND AS A
REMINDER THE PHONE NUMBER AND
PASSCODE IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ON. THE
BOTTOM OF THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
NUMBER IS. ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR FOUR IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS YOU CAN CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE. AT.
916-319-2090 NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. OPERATOR
WE ARE READY TO BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT. PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT THAT IS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HILLARY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
COMMITMENT TO THE FUTURE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. WELL THAT
COMMITMENT IT'S DIFFICULT FOR
THE FUTURE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIANS WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO DEDICATE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE. HEALTH
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN UNDERSTAFFED
AND UNDERFUNDED FOR DECADES.
DESPITE THE COMPLEX AND DIVERSE
AND NECESSARY RESPONSIBILITIES
UNDERTAKE. WORKFORCE ISSUES HAVE
BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE PANDEMIC
AT THE RESPONSIBILITY PLACED ON
LOCAL HELP JURISDICTION HAS
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY. FOR
EXAMPLE IN JOAQUIN VALLEY. THREE
LIKE TO HELP PROFESSIONALS ONE
ON THOUSAND POPULATION
HIGHLIGHTING AN INCREASE HELLO.
AND PUBLIC HEALTH. READER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF THEIR ROLE PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS CONTINUE TO CREEP
OVER LOOK AT THEY ARE PROHIBITED
FROM PARTICIPATING IN LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM. A LICENSED
HEALTH CARE WORKERS IT WOULD
CREATE A LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM
DEDICATED TO PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL WOULD HELP RECRUIT
AND RETAIN PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES MOST
PUBLIC HELP THE DEFENSE REQUIRE
HIGHER LEVELS OF EDUCATION
INCLUDING POSTGRADUATE DEGREES
DESPITE THAT THERE ARE CURRENTLY
NO EXISTING PROGRAMS FOR NON
LICENSE PUBLIC HEALTH PERSONNEL
TO HELP WITH THE COST OF THEIR
EDUCATION WE ASKED THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT A
DEDICATED LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS. THANK
YOU. FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT TODAY. THANK YOU ARE NOT
CALLER PLEASE. YOU'RE WELCOME A
SEVENTY SAY YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
AN APPLICATION ON BEHALF THE
NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP ONE OF
THE EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING
PROGRAMS OFFERED THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA HOME VISITING PROGRAM
WE ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
PROGRAM THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AND-
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSALS
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL THIRTY
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION OF THIS
PROGRAM. TO EXPAND HOME VISITING
PROGRAM MODEL TRANSITIONAL
COUNTY WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S METRIC OF
ADDING MORE FAMILIES WE
ENCOURAGE THE ADMINISTRATION AND
WE'RE COMMITTED TO INCREASE THAT
NUMBER BY FIFTEEN MILLION THREE
TO APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED MORE FAMILIES COULD
BENEFIT. ME BY CHANGING SERVICES
FOR WORKING FOR COMMITTEE
PROTOCOLS ON THIS REQUEST AND
LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSING IT
FURTHER THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR ATTENTION. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU THEIR
COMPROMISED EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING LINDA
WAY WITH WESTERN PHENOMENON
POPPY EXPRESSING SUPPORT FOR
SEVERAL ITEMS UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
WITH THE HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE FUND THAT WOULD
DEDICATE FUNDING TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS CLINICS IN
TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS WE SUPPORT
THE BCP TEXT BACK CALIFORNIA
HOME VISITING PROGRAMS AND
REITERATE AT THE NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIPS REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. SB SIXTY
FIVE PC P. BLACK INFANT HEALTH
P. C. P. ND AB TEN NINETY FOUR
B. C. P. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU HAVE A COMBINED ONLINE
. OPEN I THINK IT TOP OF THE
URBAN COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA
SEVERAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVE
THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AVENTURA RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION AND I'M
GOING CUTTING FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. ATTORNEY THE
PARTICULARLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT. I'M
MORE OPEN SUPPORT OF IT AT THE
NATIONAL INVESTMENT AS OUTLINED
BY THE TICKET AND EARLIER IN THE
HEARING. ON TO ADDRESS THE
PUBLIC HEALTH- PIPELINE. ISSUES
AS WELL AS RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU BETTER COME FROM NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING CRIPPLED FROM
BEHALF OF HLA HELD A WIDE AND
THE EPIDEMICS COALITION. MISTER
CHAIR YOU KNOW OVER THE COURSE
OF THE PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA TEEN
ALARMING INCREASES IN OVERDOSE
DEATHS SKYROCKETING AT THE IRATE
AND ONGOING HIGH TRANSMISSION
RATES OF HIV. AND HEPATITIS WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
HIM BUT INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
HEALTH. HOWEVER WE BELIEVE
TARGETED FUNDING REMAINS
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES ARE ALLOCATED
TO TACKLE THE GROWING PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISES THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT LGBT
Q. BY PARKING OTHER VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE ITSELF TO SUPPORT THE
SIX PROPOSALS FROM THEM YEAH
DEMICHELIS CHEN WE ARE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE HEALTH
EQUITY IN RACIAL JUSTICE FINE.
AS WELL THE PROPOSAL PERMITS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION TO EXPAND
TESTING PER HIV HEPATITIS B. AND
SYPHILIS AND HOSPITAL ER'S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
CONTINUED. SUPPORT AND
LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU
WELCOME FROM NINE NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
GIRABOLA ED THE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS OSCAR SPENDABLE I AM THE
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
MANAGER WITH THE LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
ALSO KNOWN AS HEALTHY EXCEEDS
ORGANIZATIONAL CALLING SUPPORT
OF THE HELP THAT COULD IN RACIAL
JUSTICE BOND. FUND IS THAT
UNIQUE AND BOLD FUND THAT WOULD
DEDICATE NO LESS THAN A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS CONNECT AT A
TRUCK ORGANIZATIONS THAT KNOW
OUR COMMUNITY'S BEST. TIME THAT
WE HELP OUT BIT THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DO SO MUCH
FOR COMMUNITY AT HOPKINTON SO
WITH VERY LITTLE RESOURCES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU BETTER COME
FROM MINE EIGHTY FIVE AIRLINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THANK YOU FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON TRADE
SECRET TRADE FROM THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE WE APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORT FOR THE
HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE
BUT LAST YEAR. I REQUEST THAT
YOU MAINTAIN SUPPORT FOR ONE
HUNDRED MILLION I'M GOING FOR
THE FUN. WHAT WE SUPPORT FUNDING
FOR LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
THE JANUARY BUDGET WE ALSO
REQUEST DIRECT FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WHICH HAVE UNIQUE KNOWLEDGE OF
COMMUNITY NEEDS AND IMPORTANTLY
HOW TO SOLVE THEM. WE ARE ALL
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WE WORK BEST
AND FOR THE MOST PEOPLE WENT ALL
THE PUBLIC EALTH IS FULLY
FUNDED IN ANOTHER YEAR OF
HISTORIC BUDGET SURPLUS IN THE
THROES OF DEEPLY INEQUITABLE
SOCIAL AND HEALTH IMPACTS TO
COMBAT NINETEEN. COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS CAN'T BE LEFT OUT
AGAIN THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. GIVE IT A COME
FROM MINE A SEVENTY THREE YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT- TREAT THE COOK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE THE LION BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND THAT
PUBLIC SPEAKERS FOR THE GOOD
DIALOGUE RELATED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S- FITNESS BUT MENTAL
HEALTH COUNCIL. AND JET- WOULD
LIKE TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR
THE TEN MILLION DOLLAR AFTER
CREATION RECOMMENDED AS PART OF
THE BUDGET THANK YOU. Q. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU BETTER
COME FROM MINUS SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARIA BARBOUR
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
AROUND COMMUNITY BENEFITS I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. HOWEVER
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE LANGUAGE
AS OPPOSED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET CALIFORNIA'S NONPROFIT
HOSPITALS ARE COMMITTED TO
IMPROVING THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF THE COMMUNITY. AND PLAY
A KEY ROLE IN ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS OF THEIR COMMUNITIES OUR
COMMUNITY BENEFIT PROGRAMS. FROM
INVESTMENTS IN FOOD INSECURITY
TO WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
SUPPORTING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROGRAM AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS OR PROVIDING
RECUPERATIVE CARE HOSPITAL
PROGRESS HERE THE IDENTIFIED
HEALTHCARE AND OTHER NEEDS
REGULARLY EVERY THREE YEAR PAP
HOSPITAL REEVALUATE THEIR
COMMUNITY NEEDS. AND MAKE
COMMUNITY INVESTMENT BASED ON
THE FINDING THOSE NEEDS VARY
FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY OR
SOMETIMES I THINK THE THIRTY
UNFORTUNATELY THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
THREATENS TO UNDO MUCH OF
BACKGROUND WORK. THE PROPOSAL
REQUIRED HOSPITAL TO SPEND 25%
HUMIDITY BENEFIT DOLLARS ON THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH WE
ARE CONCERNED WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS THE TECHNICAL
MANAGE AT PREDETERMINED POWER
POSSIBLE CONTENDER COMMITTEE
BENEFIT SALAS IT DOES NOT ALLOW
FOR FLEXIBILITY AN EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS. SUCH A COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC OR- NOR DOES
NOT ALLOW HOSPITAL AFTER PARKER
TAYLOR THE COMMUNITY BENEFIT TO
THE COMMUNITY NEEDS. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT OUR
HOSPITAL BILL ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE THEIR WORK WITH THE
PALER. CARE COMMUNITY. FIRING
EIGHT POINT REQUIRE OF THE ALLOW
FOR HOW. DEPENDING ONE ARCHETYPE
ID CHAIN. THANK YOU VERY. THANK
YOU OPERATOR NO CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU THAT A COME FROM A TWO
LINE OF THE- GOOD EVENING AND
THANK YOU CHAIR. MY NAME IS
SCHORR AND LEGISLATURE ADVOCATE
WITH A- LOCAL ONE. CALLING IN
SUPPORT FOR BY INCREASE CITY.
CENTER FOR HOW. CARE QUALITY I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TRAFFICKING THERE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO ADDRESS
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE.
ESPECIALLY CONCERNED WITH THIS
REGARDING RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION PER HEALTH FACILITY
NURSING VALUE ACRES- SURVEYORS
AND URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO FIND
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU BETTER COME FROM MY
NINETY YEAR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING. CHEN ARAMBULA I WOULD
DOWNEY WHITTLING HANSON JIRO
QEDANI REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION THERE ARE TWO ISSUES
ARE LIKE ELEVATE. FIRST I WOULD
pLIKE TO APPLAUD THE COMMITTEE
FOR DISCUSSING AND WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
INCREASE FUNDING AND STAFFING
FOR THE BLACK INFANT HEALTH
PROGRAM TO EXPAND THE NUMBER. OF
SITE AND PARTICIPANTS AND AT
EIGHT VIRTUAL COMPONENT. MY
FATHER LEFT HIM- BOOK OUT NEXT
LINE OF NINETY THREE A LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING COUNTY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
WE'RE REGISTERING SUPPORT
NITROGEN PROPOSAL BEFORE THE CUT
COMMITTEE WANTED BE PACKAGE OF
PROPOSALS FROM THE AND THE
EPIDEMIC COALITION WHICH WE ARE
IN NUMBER AS- WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
PUBLIC HEALTH INVESTMENT. BUT
WANT TO CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO
THESE CRITICAL TARGETED
INVESTMENTS PROPOSED BUYING AND
BY THE END THE EPIDEMIC
COALITION WHICH WILL HELP TO
ADDRESS HEALTH DISPARITIES THAT.
YOU CLASS AND. OTHER VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES EIGHT. THANK WE
SUPPORT THE ONE FUND IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB TEN NINETY
FOUR. WHICH IS ISSUE TWELVE ON
TODAY'S AGENDA AND WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR AND P. PH FOR THEIR
ATTENTION TO THIS AS WELL AS THE
CHAIR AND HIS STAFF FOR THEIR
DEDICATION AND LEADERSHIP ON
EIGHTY CA NINETY FOUR. WHICH
WILL SHED SOME MUCH NEEDED LIGHT
ON HOW THE LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY
IS IMPACTED BY VIOLENT DEATH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL GO
LINE IS SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THERE IT'S MICHELLE SHE
ACTS AS A VARIETY OF ADDITIONAL
ISSUES- COULD YOU THINK THAT
MIGHT BE THE COMPANY FROM THE
BANKING ACCOUNT EXPERTS COMPLAIN
I THINK BUT I THINK THAT
INFORMATION WITH HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. I NEED YOU SEVEN
REPORT THAT SPENDING FOR THE
CONTINUATION OF IT DEFENDANTS
URGED CREATION STATE WIDE GRANT
FROM OTHER NIGHT OF THE LOCAL I.
T. IF YOU NINE WITH THE COURT
KIND HEALTH IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
ISSUE TEN. INVESTMENT DON'T
PUBLIC CONFINEMENT PLANNING IT
JUST AS A CONSIDERATION THE
RATHER. COMPELLING ANTHONY FOR
HEALTH DEPARTMENT THAT ARE NOT
IMPLEMENT THE PLAN WE ARE ISSUE
THIRTEEN ALPHA LIMA OKAY OF THE
BRAIN INITIATIVE AT THE CORE
ISSUE TWENTY TWO THE FUNDING FOR
HOME VISITING PROGRAM YEAH THE
FUNNY PRECURSOR OF THE-
PROGRAM'S BEFORE. NO NEW
PROGRAMS AND ENCOURAGE THX FOR
ADDITIONAL MODELS AND IN
CONSULTATION WITH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT SO THAT WE ENSURE WE
REACH THE MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES. IT'S IMPORTANT ISSUE
TWENTY THREE- INCREASE FUNDING
FOR THE BACK OF THE HOUSE
PROGRAM ENCOURAGED ATHLETES TO
PROVIDE ONGOING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ACT WHICH HEARING AND
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT BEFORE
IMPLEMENTING ANY CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM I'M NOT GOING TO EXPECT
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR. AND THE GREEN. FUNDING FOR BOOK FOR LOW
INCOME AT.
GOOD EVENING SIR MEMBERS PER
THOUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OF MERCED. I WANT TO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE COUNTY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION. DOLLAR
PULLED OUT ALL THE PUBLIC TO
CREATE A DEFICIT OF. ONE
FORGIVENESS PROGRAMFOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU OVER TO LINE
AND NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND WE'RE- ORDER IT PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE DOLLARS AFTER BIRTH
. DISTRIBUTE BOOKS TO LOW INCOME
CHILDREN. IN ADDITIONAL AFTER
READING AND LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
DURING THE CRITICAL EARLY YEARS
OF A CHILD'S LIFE. YOUR FIRST
TRY CALIFORNIA HAS WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT IN
THE CURRENT. THERE'S STILL A LOT
OF WORK TO BE DONE AT THE
OVERCOME CHALLENGES CALL. THE
FOR DEEP EVEN THREE TO POINT THE
STATURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
ABOUT TO LINE AT NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
EVENING THAT ARE CHAIR THIS IS A
MONTH TO MARCELLA SPOCK CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION REGARDING ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTEEN WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET AND IN PARTICULAR THE-
THE FUNDING FOR THE HEALTHY
BRAIN INITIATIVE PILOT PROGRAM.
AT THE COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERING
THE BUDGET THE ASSOCIATION DOES
ENCOURAGED THAT THAT BECOME
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE HEALTHY
BRAIN INITIATIVE PILOT GIVEN THE
GROWING IMPACT OF ALZHEIMER'S IN
CALIFORNIA WITH A POPULATION OF
THOSE LIVING WITH ALZHEIMER'S
EXPECTED TO GROW BY A HUNDRED
AND 27% IN THE NEXT TWO DECADES.
WE'VE SPONSORED AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTEEN AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
WHICH CREATES ON GOING FUNDING
FOR THIS PROGRAM GIVEN THAT IT
HAS EXEMPLIFIED. THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS ARE ABLE TO
AND ENGAGE IN UNDER- IN ENGAGE
IN UNDERSERVED POPULATION
ADDRESS THE HEALTH CARE
DISPARITIES AND LEVERAGING. UP
PUBLIC AND NONPROFIT
PARTNERSHIPS TO CREATE A
SUSTAINED IMPACT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH BOTH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE STATE
LEGISLATOR. BURKE FUNDING
REGARDING THE H. B. I. PILOT
PROGRAM THANK YOU SO MUCH HAVE A
WONDERFUL EVENING. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JOHN GOOD EVENING CHAIR
NUMBER IT CAN LUIS REPRESENTING
CHILDREN NOW SPEAKING ON ISSUES
TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY THREE THE
COURT ADMINISTRATION BEEN
BACKGROUND CHECK FAMILIES
PROGRAM WHICH HAD BEEN
NECESSARILY HAVE IT DURING THE
PANDEMIC MEET THE PUBLIC HELP
CREATE THE- OPPORTUNITY EXPENSE
DEPENDING PROGRAMS AND ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ABOUT THAT
WOULD EVEN BE NECESSARY. TO HELP
THESE PROGRAMS NEEDS THEIR PRE
PANDEMIC NUMBER OF AUTHOR MARK
HAMLIN. WHO WOULD REALLY BENEFIT
FROM THE POT THAT. GRAHAM
BENEFITS FROM EVENT BASS COMPANY
PROGRAM THANK YOU THAT MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE ONE-
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN CONSUMERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
SPEAKING TO ISSUE TO UNDER THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY. THAT SPONSORS OF AB
FOUR FIFTY FROM LAST YEAR WE ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE BUT ENSURING AND
TO HAVE ENOUGH RESPECT TO STAND
UP THE NEW PARAMEDIC LICENSING
REVIEW BOARD. WE'RE JUST TAKING
A CLOSER LOOK AT FIFTY FIFTY
WHICH WOULD INCREASE PARAMEDIC
LICENSING FEES BY SIXTY FIVE
DOLLARS. AFTER A FIFTY DOLLAR
INCREASE OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
AND WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
OUR CURRENT PARAMEDICS ARE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WANT TO BECOME
PARAMEDICS DON'T SEE THESE THESE
AS A BARRIER. TO ENTERING THE
FIELD- SO WE HOPE TO ENGAGE THEM
FOR STAFF AND THE LEGISLATURE TO
DETERMINE IF THIS IS THE RIGHT
APPROACH. TO ENSURE ADEQUATE
FUNDING OR IF THERE MAY BE ALL
AND OTHER ALTERNATIVES THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU KNOW BE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME MEANING THE
CREDIT CHECK RECOMMENDED HEALTH
FACILITY ABOUT YOU WE'RE NURSE-
AND A MEMBER OF SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET TO
INCREASE THE PH- CENTERS FOR
HEALTH CARE QUALITY. TO ADDRESS
URGENT RELATED TO HEALTH CARE
FACILITY EVALUATOR NURSE
WORKFORCE. TO ENSURE THE
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT OF ALL HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
COME FROM MY NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CUT
SAID THIS TO ME MARZBAN
REGISTERED NURSE AND I AM THE
FOCUS BILLION VALUE LATER NURSES
WELL THE PROBLEM NUMBER S. YEAH
YOU LOCAL ONE THOUSAND CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT. FOR A BUDGET
INCREASE FOR THE SPEAKING CENTER
FOR HEALTH CARE QUALITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND THAT WAS OUR LAST-
CALLER IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU OPERATOR I WILL TAKE
THAT AS THE CONCLUSION OF PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR TODAY AS WE ARE
WINDING DOWN THIS HEARING I WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK STAFF
FOR PREPARING SUCH A ROBUST
AGENDA AND HOPING TO FRAME MANY
OF THE DISCUSSIONS THAT WE HAD
HERE TODAY. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK DGS FOR CLEANING FOR TECH
FOR DISTRIBUTING FOR SERGEANTS
FOR KEEPING US ALL SAFE- TO ALL
OF THE PANELISTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT AND ADMINISTRATION TO
FINANCE AND THE L. A. O. WANTS
TO EXPRESS APPRECIATION BUT MOST
OF ALL- TO THE PUBLIC FOR
PARTICIPATING IN IMPROVING OUR
PROCESS- YOU MAKE US BETTER WHEN
YOU- PARTICIPATE TENT SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS AND REALLY DO
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU HAVE TO STAY
HERE IN THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE. WITH
THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED FOR THE
NIGHT HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.